the c-span area by typing the keyword
c-span
now harper's magazine editor lewis
lapham in january he spoke about social
and political shifts in the united
states at the overseas press club in new
york his comments last about a half an
hour
[Applause]
well we've talked today about students
beginning in their careers we've talked
about correspondence ending their
careers we've talked about the names
aj liebling and if stone have come up
one of the things i most admire about
the profession is it has allowed some
people to say what they mean and to
stand by it to live by it uh
louis lapham uh editor of harper's
subscribed yesterday's new york observer
is america's favorite grouchy magazine
editor i don't i don't think of him that
way i think of him as an iconoclast i
think him as a trenchant observer
someone who says exactly what he's what
he means and says it extremely well
and someone who provokes me uh and
sometimes elucidates sometimes provokes
but i think that's the very best
tradition of american journalism and so
ladies and gentlemen i give you lewis
slapham
[Applause]
well i'm uh delighted to be here i see
many
friends in the room and i'm
sorry i didn't get the piece out of mr
frank
but
i was i thought i was going to come and
talk to a very small lunch and tell old
stories about
the days when i was a foreign
correspondent and so forth but
bill persuaded me to talk about the
new american ruling class which is a
subject to which i and how does
journalism fit into the
new order so
i'm not a marxist and i'm not a
revolutionary i'm sometimes i'm not even
a grouch but the
i know that the the word class arouses
suspicion and uneasiness in an american
audience and
i have no objection to a ruling class no
country can exist without a ruling class
that was true in uh rome in the first
century that was true in the united
states in 1787 that was true and
written at the zenith of empire and it's
true now
so the only question in my mind is what
kind of a ruling class
uh what what's the name what's its
nature what what what's the character
and what's its worth made to what
specifications
and with what's uh
passions or objectives in mind and it
seems to me that the
american
ruling class or governing class or
possessing class whatever you want to
call it
my favorite term for it is equestrian
class because that is an old roman term
the rank was for sale for four hundred
thousand
sisters in in rome and the first century
a.d and the and and
the governing class in america is it's a
rank that is for sale
that's
also always been true in the united
states
but
something has happened to that
class over the last 50 years i think
i think it is no longer as specifically
american
class
i i think it's
lost its interest in politics
and i don't think it has much use
for
an intelligent press
and
you now will ask me
who are we talking about
and the figures vary and numbers of
other writers have written on this
subject
bill greiter's written about it kevin
phillips
christopher lash michael lind
essentially we're talking about
is that one or two percent of the
american population
that owns
90 percent of the nation's wealth and 75
percent of its capital assets
it's an oligarchy
uh
it's not a large percentage
but it's a fairly large
absolute number i mean maybe we're
talking about
two million
people perhaps
essentially these are the people who
write the laws who write the news run
the schools
direct the corporations
uh own the media on and on the banks
uh the rich and the servants of the rich
lind michael lind in his book that he
published last summer called the
american nation
uh refers to what he calls the donor
party
the donor party is the
group of no more than two hundred
thousand people in the united states
who give political campaign gifts in
excess of five thousand dollars
to become a candidate
you must be first elected
by the
donor party that is the
beginning and end of the american
democracy it's 200 000 people from
because if you don't have money you you
don't unless you're steve forbes or
perrault
you have no you don't even appear on
television
the another way of describing the
the the oligarchy or the equestrian
class would be to just think of the
shoppers on madison avenue or rodeo
drive or the
residence of the zip code section in new
york in new york new york one zero zero
two one
which is this narrow golden rectangle in
the city of manhattan
where the annual income is something
like two billion dollars a year income
within that one
zip code section
another way to think of it would be the
way that the public broadcasting
network thinks of it which is um
i did a book show on television for a
couple of years for pbs
and
there
the pbs number which is like the
harper's number
for the
total universe of
americans
that is that makes the market for
the trade list of the new york times
books
for magazines like harper's new yorker
foreign affairs for the
documentaries that appear on pbs for
most of the leading policy journals and
so forth we're talking about no more
than two million people
if that many
that's the
whole universe
now the people that uh
essentially live within that universe um
run the schools own the banks write the
laws and so forth
um
it's the view from the box seats
and
the first thing that's changed in the
last 50 years is the sense of
responsibility
i
believe maybe i'm a romantic but i do
believe that 50 years ago
this class felt some degree of
responsibility
toward the lower borders
there was a sense that privilege
entailed obligation
there was the attitude was derived in
part from the attitude of the british
ruling class the late part of the 19th
century
from whom we
the americans picked up the
white man's burden at the direction of
rudyard kipling who wrote that poem as a
matter of fact there's a campaign speech
for teddy roosevelt
but that attitude is also confirmed by
the american victories in world war ii
and
i i happen to have been thinking great
deal about this subject lately because i
am writing a book about the
social and intellectual history of yale
university
over the second half of the american
century begin 1950 to the year 2000
the american century as you know is a
phrase coined by henry luce yale 1919
uh former chairman of the yale daily
news and so forth and the
whole sense of american
empire american primacy american
supremacy american obligation
is very much in place
it at yale in the 1950s which is when i
was there as an undergraduate
and
several of the professors in both the
english department and the history
department were recruiters for the cia
the
sense that the of a
noble mission of bringing the
uh white to a darkened world
the careers was very much part of the
meal year
and
yale then as yale now is in the business
of making the american
equestrian class that is why one pays
26 27 000 a year to send a child to
either
yale harvard princeton or the other
universities that do this sort of thing
um
the people
at
uh
in the 50s identified themselves with an
inter with an american commonwealth
there was
an american
ideal it was an american idea there was
a sense of obligation
i don't think that the current
um
kids the the ones that i know at new
haven
or
the our current
oligarchy has the same feeling at all
i think that
the
members of the american equestrian class
today
inclined to think of themselves as
align themselves with an international
economic
order
rather than an american commonwealth
there's very little patriotism in
in this among the people that i'm
talking about
they have more in common with their
peers uh their economic peers
in england japan or germany
than they do with their
with a run-of-the-mill americans in
omaha or sin city
and it you see it in the character of
somebody like richard nixon who was very
much at home with the
shah of iran or
marcos
or noriega people of that those are the
kind of people that he
liked could talk to understood
deep fear and hatred of the ordinary
american citizen
corporations the american corporations
today receive
much if not most of their income from
abroad
coca-cola now no longer has a domestic
division
it's a world company and
the uh
so they're not thinking in terms of the
of an american nationalist uh
economics
a lot of as you this is also obviously
true of the movie industry
which without foreign sales
cannot afford to pay the kinds of
salaries they now pay it's also true of
our
banking industries and airlines and so
on
so
it's an international
economic
uh world order and this is very clear
this is i sound like buchanan but
buchanan is right in this i i don't
think this is a matter of opinion i
think this is a matter of
sheer statistics that
you can see it with
nafta you can see it
in any number of ways you i i saw it
most clearly
the year that the challenger exploded
the
six months after the
challenger exploded at t and ge were
called to testify before the senate
foreign relations committee
because the cold war was still going on
and at t and ge had decided to send up
their newest satellite on the soviet
rocket
it was the only rocket going
and the
foreign relations committee took took
took this very seriously and said
you can't do this this is trading with
the enemy and so on this is our most
sophisticated
technology and so forth and so on and
that the two corporations said we really
don't care what you think senator it's
not important because this is about
money
and if we don't send it up on the
russian rocket we're going to lose to
the french
we can't afford to lose to the french
and you could make the speech to you
know your friends at the council on
foreign relations but
no and goodbye
another way of looking at the
um
increasing isolation of the american
equestrian order
is in the move to the suburbs
that's everybody a lot of other people
have written about that but we now have
a
country that is becoming increasingly
feudal in its organization
we have uh
the united states spends
20 billion dollars a year on public law
enforcement that includes
all forms of public law enforcement
city
county
sheriff's fbi justice department so
forth we spend 40 billion dollars on
private law enforcement
again it's the
the retreat
from the public
realm
privatization of everything
the private is
50 years ago
the notion of the public sector the
public sphere the public commonwealth
would have connoted a good
today in most uh
usages the word public
connotes filth squalor
incompetence
bad housing
fool politicians
and leaking grains and so forth and the
word private is associated with the
clear
crowd streams of colorado and all good
things
flow from the private sector as opposed
to the public sector that is a
something that has happened in in 50
years
another another way you see the
uh withdrawing is the sense of
the american sense of humor
50 years ago most of the jokes or many
of the jokes were
the
have-nots
making fun of the haves
this was the
humor of menkin this was the humor of
the movies of the 30s this was the humor
of the new yorker in in the 30s and so
on
today it's reversed the humor is the
haves making fun of the have-nots
it's the humor of the david letterman
show it's the humor of pj o'rourke it's
the period it's the hero it's the it's
the humor of the
hip movies of quentin tarantino
i happen to find it very repellent but
nevertheless it is the the tone that's
in place
second thing that's happened in the last
50 years and corollary to what i'm
talking about
in terms of the character
of the american equestrian class is the
absence of interest in history or
politics
the
one would have expected
circa 1950 1955 even as late as 1960
that the
people
who enjoyed economic privilege would
also be interested in
the history of the united states uh
interested in
the intellectual content of the media of
newspapers
i went to work at
the new york herald tribune in 1960
which was the paper then owned by john a
whitney
a leading republican
presence in in new york and on that wing
of the republican party
and he his ownership of the
tribune at the time was in the line of
pulitzer who was the democrat or greely
who was a republican or even colonel
mccormick
of the chicago papers who was
extreme what we would today call a
stream right
but whitney's interest was primarily uh
tonight a political one he had an idea
he had a political idea
and the ownership of the the papers
reflected that
they no longer do
i mean now
you would not associate i would not
associate uh
the corporations that own
the networks or that own the big or the
disney company or whatever the big media
syndicates are with a political idea i'd
associate them with an economic idea
with the new international economic
world order yes but with a
with an idea that
that somehow politics mattered
i wouldn't think so and and you can see
that uh
in the newspapers this morning the front
page of the times today talks about the
money likely to flow to the democratic
republican candidates for the house in
next november's election and clearly the
lines are
the same lines as dwayne andreas the
head of
adm
who gives with the left hand to the
democrat and to the right hand with a
republican because it really doesn't
matter
there there is only
in in my view and lots of other people's
view there's only one political party in
the united states at the moment
and the point is power the point is to
be have
connection to have access to
uh
the committee or to the tax legislation
or to the
telecommunications bill or
it has very little to do with with ideas
that is again a change i think over the
last 15 years
you see this that
on the stage at yale university no
longer can study
political history
of american political history there are
something called cultural studies
so the historic the america the telling
of the american tale has been broken
down into telling
of the black american tale or the
feminist american tale or the ethnic
native american american tale and so
forth and so on and you can go through
the entire
you can take
as the
there is no curriculum
that went in the 60s but you know in
order to satisfy the requirement for
late 18th century history united states
you can take it in
uh domestic pewter
butter churns the plight of women on the
frontier and so forth all interesting
subjects but but
not a coherent
historical
view
all right if if if i'm
correct then in the
two uh points about the
american equestrian class over the last
50 years
point one being
the the feeling of no responsibility
toward
the less fortunate
and uh
to
the absence of interest in either
history
or politics
as a passionate interest
then what then becomes the uh the
function of the press
and the again the parallels to me are
very similar when i first started
working for the newspapers i my first
job was a newspaper reporter for the san
francisco examiner in 1957 a hearst
newspaper
and i was the only
ivy league person in the
entire place
to use the word journalist was would
have been uh nobody used the word
journalist only englishman and fops used
the word journalist
americans used the word reporter or
newspaper man
nobody was paid any money event to speak
up and nobody expected
to make any monies i mean there was one
did not go into
newspaper reporting to become rich
one came in for
probably in my case romantic ideas
growing out of the
depression and out of the
autobiographies of novelists on the
order of john o'hara's hemingway but the
notion was to somehow get at the truth
and tell a story
it's a romantic notion
but the uh
there was uh and we tended
as
as newspaper guys
to identify
with the people in the bleachers not
with the people in the box seat
and
that changed in the middle 60s by 1967
um the the ranks of the uh of the
newspaper what was the newspaper
business
begins to fill up with people from
harvard and yale and princeton
the salaries begin to go up to 300 400
000 a year for television personalities
and the identification shifts from the
uh
the crowd the bleachers
to
the swells in the box seats
and i now think that's where we are i
think we now have by and large present
company accepted a courtier press a a
i think of most of the major
news persons in the united states and i
think of
rosencrantz and guildenstern in
shakespeare's hamlet
the idea that somebody like bob woodward
is presented as an investigative
journalist is a joke
that can only be appreciated by somebody
who remembers
uh what the what investigative
journalism was that and the
i turned down as the editor of harvest
magazine
all the president's men in 19 whatever
it was 73
because there's not a single name source
and i mean i said
okay that's gossip stuff that's great
but that's not
what i learned as a
as a journalist
and most of his
most of what now or much
of what now passes for
big time journalism is that kind of
whisper gossip
the dying bill casey of parts in my
shell-like year
the truth about iran contra et cetera et
cetera
or in the as in uh where halberstam's
book the best and brightest not a single
name source
conversations all invented and
reconstructed it passes in in a world
that doesn't care about history
uh as truth
the um
or as to as uh as entertainment
and i i don't have to
dwell on all of that i mean but
as the
in in uh
in 1960 there was still something called
the newspaper business
literature theater movies
by 1970
all of those what were once discrete
disciplines
have been fused into something called
media
we
you know as the
politicians become less responsible
and like minded
so do uh
so do
uh our journalists so does our
journalism i mean
to go back to the
the roman example
when uh
at the zenith of rome's military power
the returning general would
have a triumph through the streets of
rome
standing in the chariot
and behind him would come the train of
captured slaves and
elephants trophies and so forth
and but they would stand behind his
shoulder in a chariot they would stand
behind the shoulder there would be a man
who would say
remember
you are mortal
today our journalists we are now the
zenith of our economic power
um
the wonder of an admiring world in many
different ways
and
we ride in in triumph through the
streets of
new york or washington or london and our
media
stands behind
behind us in in the chariot and says
know that you are a god
and that's the you know essentially
that's the cover of
fortune magazine
or the you know the worship of bill
gates
and so it's a very
dangerous attitude i think
i think we have a less and less grasp of
reality
we now have a country in which the ratio
between
what the
ceo of a corporation makes
and the lowest paid assembly worker
or clerk in the same company the ratio
is 184 to 1.
and
even as recently as 20 years ago
duration was the ratio is 15 to 1 which
is what it is in
france england and japan
and
that kind of
um
i've run out of time i'm sorry i've gone
too long but
but that
given that kind of uh world of wish
reverie dream uh the public relations
man who's sometimes difficult to tell
from the washington columnist standing
behind you in the chariot whispering in
your ear that you're a god
given that i i i can't think of a more
necessary
corrective
than
both the art and craft of journalism
and i'm proud to be associated with
people who
also believe that and with the
six young people who i hope will
sharpen their pencils and
go out and
do battle in the
coming days thank you
we have just just a moment or two
for a question uh i'd be interested in
it seems that the the american embrace
of the global economy and all these
things you've talked about have created
critics of the system from a buchanan on
the right but also for other voices on
other ends of the political spectrum and
is that what does that mean why is that
happening
i mean why are there criticisms well no
why would it be that on there is a from
a liberal perspective there's criticism
and also as well as from a populist or
right-wing perspective and it seems to
be pretty pretty broad
condemnation
well i mean there are all kinds of ways
of breaking that down i mean there are
complaints about everything i mean one
of the complaints is that the government
is not us however we define the us it is
it is a them and not a we and
and so we go around we play the game of
musical chairs as to who is the us and
to who's them and and
by
i can't possibly answer that question in
all of its but everybody's angry because
people on both the left and the right
see that the system
that something's wrong
we have a congress so futile that it
cannot negotiate a disarmament treaty
with its own citizens who own 200
million guns
or or we have a we we have a uh we have
a uh
budget debate the government shuts down
twice in in this winter
on what essentially is i mean a balanced
budget is an imaginary number
literally i mean it happens in the out
years seven years from now which of
course never happens it's it's peter pan
it's it's
we are talking about
angels dancing on the heads of pins when
we're talking about what the
budget is going to be like seven years
from now and the government shuts down
twice
and people get
angry at that sort of thing every poll
shows
80 percent of the american people want
to protect the environment
and the and the people in washington
wave that one away that you know just go
right over that one and and begin
taking down the environmental
regulations with no
reference to
the supposedly
nominally sovereign people
and the nominally sovereign people
are getting
very
angry properly so in my view
well thank you very much for coming
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
thank you
american perspectives continues in a
minute with marilyn quail speaking on
women in the republican party first a
few program notes
tomorrow at 8 pm on book notes columnist
and commentator clarence page discusses
his recent book showing my color implied
essay
hmm
first monday of the summer june 24th
welcome to the washington journal
looking at a live picture of the capital
a little bit of overcast as
flags are flying at half staff in honor
of bill emerson who died over the
weekend of cancer 58 year old
congressman from missouri
republican
and also the announcement of the death
of the weekend of
terrell bell former secretary of
education in the reagan administration
but this morning as we kick off this
first half hour we're joined by john
aloysius farrell better known as jack
farrell of the boston globe political
correspondent then we're going to talk
to a fellow by the name of wiley miller
who
has won something called the golden
spike award given to him by his fellow
cartoonists and we'll learn more about
what the golden spike award is and and
what he did to win it later on in the
program then our newspaper roundtable
lewis lapham editor of harper's magazine
joins us and they have a new article in
their issue by gene lyons
who is talking a lot about bloodsport
doesn't like the book or
james stewart's version of what goes on
inside the clinton white house and then
there's immaterial who is the
editor-in-chief of the american
spectator and he has a new book coming
out of a biography or autobiography
unauthorized of bill clinton and then
finally we'll talk to michael kinsley
from seattle
this is uh the big day and you can look
at the newspapers this morning and see
it everywhere stories about slate the
microsoft version of a magazine on the
world wide web and we'll we'll learn
more about this of course as we go but
this morning uh we're going to also
introduce you to some folks that are
here for a program that we're putting on
at c-span uh the 200 000 scholarship
competition you can see here on our desk
here what the folder looks like and
we're welcoming 25
first-time voters to washington winners
of our contest the grand prize winner
who got five thousand dollar scholarship
down to uh
2500 for four more and then a thousand
for the other 20 and they're going to be
here we're going to meet them all as the
morning goes on but as we pick this up
jack farrell and look at
newsweek magazine they're talking about
first-time voters the children of
gridlock is what they call this piece
and they have a new poll out
in the article written by john leland
and john mccormick they say that uh
these are children of gridlock talking
about the people between the ages of 18
and 29 a generation whose political
landscape has been shaped not by
watergate or a world war but by
infighting and stalemate and they say
for clinton in particular they are
critical constituency in 1992 according
to the national election study survey
college-age voters supported clinton
more strongly than any other age group
but this year he could not count on that
support in a newsweek poll of potential
voters 18 to 29 far more
identified themselves as independent
than as either democrat or republican
and though the poll gave clinton a
healthy lead nearly one-third said they
did not care very much who won the
election
yeah i remember i guess it was in the
spring of 1992
that ed rollins gave a talk at the
chamber of commerce and he talked about
this
group and he said that
he predicted that the republicans were
going to lose them in 92
and he said that this is a group that is
going to swing back and forth in every
election they're going to pick a
favorite they're uh
probably the generation of voters least
bound by any kind of partisan ties to a
democratic or republican
party and uh they're probably gonna be
up for grabs every four years actually
every two years because they vote for
congressional elections as well in this
poll it points out a number of other
things 39 of young adults feel
government leaders can't make progress
because quote our problems have become
so complicated
42 percent consider themselves
independents compared with 27 percent
who are democrats and 26 percent who are
republicans
probably those two
facts are interconnected i think i think
that the the partisan gridlock that they
see in washington makes them
independents and also makes them
pessimistic about how
how good the system is at solving the
problems that are important to them
here's another statistic though that
doesn't track from from the
statistic statistics on parties 44 say
that clinton understands our concern 16
say that dole does well that's it
i think that could be a generational
thing i mean you look at clinton playing
uh blues brother and saxophone and and
you look at
bob dole with that sort of stern voice
um and i think that
clinton obviously speaks
well as to younger voters as someone
who's a little bit closer to them
look at the two news magazines here side
by side this
morning this of course has excerpts the
bob woodward book it was front page
yesterday and today in the washington
post
both newsweek and the washington post
companies that bob woodward works for
post newsweek owns newsweek then time
magazine decides to profile the two
potential
first ladies what's your take on this um
i thought the second day of the
washington post was interesting in that
for those
out there who wanted something nasty to
read about liddy we discovered that she
had to schedule an appointment to
talk to her husband about
whether or not he should run for
president because
they just didn't have enough time or
they're not together enough back in
their apartment so she actually had to
go to the schedule and get an
appointment so you're talking about the
second excerpt of the four-part series
in the post of the bob woodward book so
now we've got a little uh
bit of gossip to talk about each one of
them today here in washington as
we begin the week how much does all this
matter i hope it doesn't matter a lot
like i said it's interesting to talk
about it'd be something everybody will
chat about over the at the water cooler
this week um or send email to each other
i guess that's more on page four
actually it starts on page one but
here's a picture uh in the washington
post our c-span camera there yesterday
out in fairfax county
to get part tom daschle there
talking about a new agenda and this ends
up on the front page of the washington
post right there at the bottom democrats
agenda aims for the middle
house and senate democrats unveiled a
21-point congressional campaign agenda
yesterday as they seek to move the party
to the political center and appeal to
swing middle-class voters in an effort
to regain control of congress in this
fall's election
i may be mistaken but i probably
i assume that that would probably have
about the same effect as the
story about the first lady's seances why
i just don't think that that uh
a proposal by congressional democrats is
going to have an awful lot of
credibility out there people know who
congressional democrats are and um i
don't think they're going to really care
that they've issued a little their own
contract with america jack farrell
originally from huntington long island
will be with us for the next 34 minutes
and we're going to go to the phones
remember we need an article from you in
this first segment i call about anything
that you find in the morning newspaper
and do more than just read the headline
please give us some
meat to talk about here and in the
stories later on in an hour we're going
to go to a dole clinton line instead of
the way it operates here during this
first hour and that means that we'll
have a telephone number for those who
support bob dole and those who support
bill clinton just for the roundtable the
rest of the morning in an hour we're
going to do that right now it's wide
open so give us a call and tell us
what you're reading this morning
another piece in today's wall street
journal on the same subject of
yesterday's
dashiell gephardt performance
democrats
family's first agenda gets tepid support
from candidates they went out and talked
to some candidates this is written by
christopher george's congressional
democrats seeking to show they are more
than the party that opposes house
speaker newt gingrich proposed a modest
family first agenda
they would push if they regained the
majority in congress but the 21
relatively non-controversial principles
such as college tax tuition or tuition
tax breaks unveiled here yesterday just
a few miles outside of washington drew
lukewarm support from democratic
congressional
excuse me candidates contacted around
the nation yeah again i think you know
people in america know who congressional
democrats are they know who bob dole is
they know who bill clinton is and an
awful lot of uh all this stuff is uh
just flack to fill the week as as we get
towards the election
so what's worth talking about then
i thought that
this is the most important story
and will be the most important story
this is a far more important election
than ours
the repercussions if it was not turning
out the way it is turning out
would be horrible for this world you'd
have uh resumption of tensions increased
uh arm spending all over the world and
uh thank god it's turning out the way it
is and and we're not paying enough
attention to it but
excuse me this article by jack kelly
says that boris yeltsin has spent 2.3
million
and that uh
mr uh gennady zoo gone off ten thousand
yeah
so what's going on
democracy has broken out in uh in the
soviet union with all its flaws but i
mean think about i mean 100 years from
now people are going to look back at
this century and they're going to say
you know what was important and one of
the most important things would be that
the west stood firm against
totalitarianism of both right and left
and and this means that we're winning
the post-cold wars as much as we won the
cold war
time for phones first look at this story
you might want to pick up ross perrault
exclusive interview in usa today says he
is ready in 18 of the 50 states
exclusive interview i mean this is
amazing it says
in rare interviews does anybody think
that getting ross perot to talk is rare
i read the same thing today i was
interested in it in rare interview from
his office i think that
mimi hall said owensboro kentucky good
morning you're on what are you reading
this morning i'm reading the uh
messenger in choir messenger inquirer in
owensboro yes and what story caught your
attention it's the cal thomas article
cal thomas column yeah column and what's
he writing about
it says key watergate figures troubled
by lack of outrage on foul gate and
charles coulson says during the dark
days of watergate we would have we would
have meetings where grown men would get
sweaty palms in those days
you put on bravest face you could but
inside was panic i suspect there's a lot
of panic on right now
and is there
what's your perception of all this
well i i think
there's a whole lot more to this story i
wish they would release them 2 000
documents that they're holding on uh
executive privilege speaker said over
the weekend that there would be a
contempt of congress vote by wednesday
if they don't
turn over those documents you think they
actually would vote contempt of congress
uh
i suspect that they would yes what do
you think i think they will yeah i mean
you have a republican congress that's
what they're there for but what do you
think the white house is going to do
between now and wednesday they'll seek a
some sort of accommodation whether or
not they can find a compromise i'm not
sure about but we have to remember that
we went through this
right before christmas with the senate
a question of privilege and in the end
the white house cave turned over the
documents and there was nothing in them
so
i'm not so sure those 2000 documents are
going to provide much more insight
there's not a word on the front page of
the washington times today about the bob
woodward book as a matter of fact they
write about the roger morris book up
here
and they go into a story about whether
or not he was a junior spy for the cia
when he was over in europe and russia
back in the 70s i think it's interesting
that we uh we started out with that
russian trip back in the 92 campaign in
which he was a spy for the kgb and now
we're
deciding that he's a spy for the cia and
probably either one has
about the same veracity which is zilch
hendersonville tennessee what are you
reading please brian stay with me for a
minute i'm reading to nashville
tennessee and the name of the article is
uh fantasy man gets 15 years and who's
it by
it's by crime carmichael and and the
story is about uh it goes to the
gullibility i believe of the american
people and uh the uh a man called up
women and asked him that he'd never met
before and ask them to blindfold
themselves
and to take out their clothes and wait
for him in bed and he was charged with
four counts of rape by deceit or
something like that how many women
waited
uh quite a number this gentleman was an
african-american and all the women were
caucasians and not that anything to do
it was incredible gullibility and the
first place mr farrell
last night on woodward specifically said
that liddy doe had to make the
appointment because she wanted to talk
about business not because there wasn't
any time i never heard anything about
time but one thing i wanted to say brian
i'm not trying to segue into something
the gullibility of the american people
now we started off with wilbur mills in
the title basin jim wright we've had the
bank scandal we've had the post office
scandal we've had the most corrupt
democratic congress
probably in
if possible if ever now we've got this
democratic administration the most
corrupt five out of nine
cabinet members
under indictment or with special
counsels
number two at justice in in prison uh on
and on and on and on and the democrats
have nothing to run on but one word
l-i-e they sit up there and they lie
about everything the reporters when you
have a press conference they they attack
trent lotter a republican but daschle
sits there
mantras lies lies lies yesterday that
program was shameful that you ran and uh
if this kind of strategy can win america
is doomed thank you mr farrell well you
know i just look forward to that golden
age when we have a republican president
and a republican congress and all of a
sudden all the world's problems
disappear
front page of roll call house delays
reform week
there is debate today in the senate a
vote tomorrow on whether or not to shut
off debate and go to a final vote on a
reform package to reform campaign
finance the house says they're putting
it off for a week they don't get it i
mean
clinton had an option in 1992 where he
could have pushed real reform in
washington and he decided not to because
it would have upset the apple cart on
capitol hill and gingrich had the same
option in 94
and they decided they weren't going to
push it either now this is too little
too late and they can't even get this
pass so
they just don't get the feeling out
there which is that the american people
are sort of fed up with the gamesmanship
in washington and they'd like some real
reform they'd like to be able to look at
their representatives and believe that
the representatives are
doing things in their interest instead
of the campaign contributors interest
and
it's going to take maybe another couple
of
house sweeps or
sweeping out the house in washington
before
they do get the message newport news
virginia what are you reading this
morning please reading the newport news
daily press what article a democrats
remote family's first planned proposal
targets middle class workers and that
was uh from yesterday's event out here
in fairfax county did you watch it uh no
well i saw only a part of it i saw i
watched c-span about i have a lot of
church things to do but i watched part
of it and where do they put it this
morning in the paper oh it's on page
a3 and it's it's the top it's the whole
top of the page and what do you think of
the proposal that they made yesterday i
think mr farrell dismissed it out of
hand too quickly uh the idea of
of having uh kids only health insurance
or
some help with people paying for their
daycare
of canning deadbeat dads around you're
talking about getting people off of
welfare and one of the things that keeps
them on is the fact that they're
concerned about their kids
or these other problems i think that
this is the opening shot of a very
interesting democratic convention
because they have to do something i mean
they know who the president's going to
be the county's going to be so this i
think would be a very contrasting
convention to what the republicans are
likely to put on giving pat buchanan who
i also watched yesterday so i think that
uh mr farrell was a little too risk in
uh in discounting this thing mr farrell
well i think that probably the uh what
the caller did at church yesterday have
a lot more uh
weight in improving the world than uh a
democratic press conference but
i'm glad to find that he disagrees with
me jack farrell is a university of
virginia graduate reported for the
denver post for five years has been at
the boston globe almost 10 years will be
next year
uh mike lane the baltimore sun today a
cartoon in the sun
do you have any comment
well first of all you're presupposing
that it was just staff at what didn't
this was not an order that came down
from the top and we do have a
historical precedent 20 years ago where
somebody did order it all the way down
from the top
i think we have to wait a while to
figure out what the real story is behind
the fbi files it could go either way our
next caller in gaithersburg is reading
the washington post good morning hi good
morning i've got the uh
excerpts from the bob woodward book the
choice and he's got an article in here
today about bob dole i was looking
forward to this because yesterday we had
the um
the revelations about the first lady
basically he he tried to say that she
was talking to dead people
and uh was superimposed against an
article by bob dole that talked about
his vice presidential choice i thought
that was kind of unfair so i was looking
forward to some
meet on bob dole but what we have here
is such a controversial stuff as dole's
decision-making style was elliptical and
dole and his wife were beginning the
formal process of deciding whether he
would run and so forth and what i'd like
to ask is whether we can still call bob
woodward an objective reporter an
objective um journalist caller let me
ask you this bob woodward told us
yesterday in this piece that mr clinton
did not talk to him and mr dole spent 12
hours with him uh what impact do you
think that had on the outcome of this
article well i'm sure it had some impact
but but i don't think that you can blame
uh bill clinton i don't think you can
put the responsibility on the clintons
for bob woodward's book i mean he has to
uh we have to take it just as it's
written and and from what i can see in
the excerpts it's very much biased
against the president and the last book
was biased against the president so i'm
wondering if we can still call bob
woodward an objective journalist thank
you thanks for calling
well the thing about bob woodroot's
books is that they're always more
thoughtful and balanced and fair once
you actually read the book and that the
hype that precedes them and the excerpts
that are chosen
to publicize the books are always the
most titillating uh thing and they and
and i think it's i mean i know why they
do it they do it to promote the sales of
the book but in the end i think it does
uh harm to the credibility of these
books do you think bob woodward has
anything to say i mean here's an excerpt
of this book and um
i think this they've done so much here
in in newsweek i'm not sure this is an
excerpt uh because they have a piece
here by
we got one by howard feynman one by es
by evan thomas
and maybe this is by howard feynman and
then you finally get to the choice by
bob woodward where they run this and
then a couple pages later they run this
one's on bob dole one's on on bill
clinton do you think bob woodward has
anything to say about what actually gets
in these in the in the paper and in
newsweek um i don't know i don't know
enough about
how it works so uh i'd be only guessing
because here in uh newsweek they focus
on gene houston right here and um did
did you did you get a sense of where all
that material was coming from and i got
a sense of you know what amazed me is
that i i guess it was a few years ago
hillary had the session with uh
was it michael lerner the fellow who was
the politics of meaning tycoon
yes and uh and and he claimed to be her
spiritual advisor and she got she read a
little letter to esquire saying or the
new york times saying this was not my
spiritual advisor people have come into
the white house who i talk to and then
they walk out of the white house and
they claim that
they have a great influence
influence with me and i'm sort of
surprised that it happened again that
uh but where do you think bob woodward
from reading this excerpt yesterday
where did he get the material oh it
sounds to me like he got it from this
woman houston why would she do that if
it self-promotion
well this is she's a big shot now i mean
the astrologer who was advising nancy
reagan
uh you know probably cashed in he had a
lot of newspaper columns sold some books
but in this little newsweek piece here
on gene houston this paragraph uh is
written this morning the white house is
no longer flattered by the attention
talking about you know attention from
from her while houston herself is not
commenting on woodward's book
administration aides now say that
houston's friendship with the first lady
isn't particularly close at all
and they bristle at houston's claim to
woodward that she was instrumental in
persuading mrs clinton to travel to asia
quote she's magnifying her own
importance in hillary's life says one
aide
i mean what what do you do what do you
do when you're in a position at the
white house or bob dylan by on
trusting
anyone that comes into your
the privacy of your home well i mean i
guess you have to realize it's like
keeping a diary anytime you keep a diary
in washington you have to realize that
someday somebody's live will be
subpoenaed and reading at a
congressional hearing and you probably
have to assume that whoever you talk to
unless they're really close friends and
even really close friends sometimes
they'll turn around and stab you in the
back as well and that actually goes both
ways i mean aslan iguineau about
about the clinton's loyalty to her
leesburg florida you're reading what
this morning please daily commercials
and what are you reading in the daily
commercial first lady speaks of mrs
roosevelt and why did you pick that this
morning well that's when the front page
stands out like a sore thumb and who who
wrote it it's by james holloway and
sonja ross associated press
and what about this piece got your
attention what do you want to comment on
well i think it's ridiculous it's
another thing for them to stir up some
campaign rhetoric over
it's another thing for who to stir up
campaign rhetoric
i'd have to say the republicans
they're you're blaming the republicans
for this article i'm sure i am
how
well i just think it's more propaganda
more feeding of the people for the
frenzy on the clintons themselves
let these people do their job no wonder
we haven't had nothing done
the president can't do anything there's
too much going on he can't run the white
house
how do the republicans though how are
they responsible for a bob woodward
book quoting a woman named jane houston
published in a paper called the
washington post
well it's my understanding that uh data
commercial one is owned by republicans
and also ap
the ceo is republican
the ap is republican for me the ap is
republican israel by republican yes
mr farrell well probably most uh
newspapers are actually run by
republicans i mean that's ap
traditionally publishers i don't know
enough about the asp to say who are
there uh who actually owns the ap do you
know
well the ap is a as a just like c-span's
cooperative of all the newspapers
i'm fighting for this guy brian
but i want to know what i mean when you
hear a man say that uh this is a plot
for the republicans this is this is it's
a first of all
i stopped believing anything that i read
coming out from any political source
back in january because in an election
year everything you hear from both sides
is going to be completely self-serving
second of all
this is the kind of stuff that i mean if
there's a problem here it's not so much
that the republicans are writing the
front page of the memphis paper it's
that um
the memphis publishers and uh the
washington post and newsweek are trying
to sell issues of their um
publications in a very competitive news
environment and they uh exaggerate the
titillation and play down the russian
elections here is uh a fact from
somebody named m
simone
the 603 area code i don't need to show
that in particular i'm crying foul first
you say poll 28 percent democrats 27
republicans 42 independents that are
those are uh
young people by the way then you give
two uh call-in numbers only the dems and
the republicans clintons and doles
where's the one for independence what
we're doing this morning in about 35
minutes is only for the morning this
morning this is june the election isn't
until november
uh it's just for this morning we'll have
the independence in here
a lot and one of the reasons we're doing
this is this right here which we showed
earlier the news magazines decided this
morning that they were going to focus on
the two parties the leading parties at
the moment and we're just going to do it
for this morning so just
hold on we'll get back to everybody will
be represented here before the year is
over we go to atlanta georgia go ahead
please hello how are you fine what are
you reading uh investors business daily
the kylie's polls offer though a little
comfort written by thomas mcardle
and just points out that 57 percent of
the people believe that the file
flap was a deliberate attempt to gain
confidential information yet uh clinton
is still leading in the polls how do you
explain that
um
i don't believe that people think it's
that important yet and i think that
quite frankly a lot of people think it
could continue to be
republican demagoguery but i'd like to
just comment on a previous caller that
blamed
the book thing on the republicans if you
know i think sometimes if the republican
party was responsible for eliminating
all diseases known in the world all we
would hear about is people blaming newt
gingrich for the rate of unemployment in
the health care industry and
one of the things that bothers me
is especially during election year
is that i don't believe that the press
takes an adversarial enough
approach to what politicians say
uh when tom daschle or
even a republican doesn't make any
difference says something that is
factually untrue
i wish they would be called on it at
that time like wolf blitzer finally
called the president
on the medicare thing about the slashing
and
gutting of the medicare when it was a 50
percent increase over seven years
compared to a 51 percent increase over
seven years this went 18 months before
anybody called the president and he
blamed the press and
i and it really bothers me because
unless you're willing to watch c-span or
read alternative sources you really
don't know what's the truth and what's
not and
i think that frankly in my opinion it's
galvanizing
the support for people that
well let's put this way the biggest
single complaint republicans have
right now the people that i know is is
the hypocrisy and the lies from the
democrats nobody talks about the issues
thanks
mr barrel well probably the biggest
single complaint that democrats have is
the hypocrisy and lies from the
republicans you're getting a lot of very
party-line callers today this is normal
oh is this normal sure
uh
by the way here's the this i wonder if
this will be controversial here's page
2b of usa today
honk to the chief white house to hold
auto celebration
president bill clinton couldn't attend
last weekend's auto centennial events
but he's making amends by throwing his
own party next month clinton and vice
president gore plan to host the white
house centennial automobile celebration
now is he going to pull his mustang
convertible out of mothballs down in
arkansas and drive it up here i haven't
i haven't gotten that far on this i
don't know whether he is or not the
white house is modeling the event after
drive american quality in 1993
extravaganza in washington d.c on the
mall near the capitol that was a
showcase for the big three autos built
in the usa and canada he also has the uh
the famous uh el camino with the
astroturf in the back i guess there's
several presidential cars
we can try it out
cincinnati you have the cincinnati
enquirer good morning
good morning and what are you reading
yes sir uh welcome from cincinnati
i watching your show this morning i'm
reading an article on the cincinnati
enquirer on the gopcs darker
uh
i have to agree with the article
uh mr farrell seemed to think that there
was nothing that came out of the
thousand
papers that were finally turned over
through sabine
let me interrupt go back to the article
and tell us more we don't know exactly
what you're talking about
well uh basically
there's a feeling that they were
using
these papers are the fbi files to dig up
dirt to be used in possibly future
campaigns
the white house contends mr livingston
and his aides
obtained the fbi uh background summary
of former reagan and bush administration
employees to
update
lifts on the white house pass holder
uh
the uh what do you think is going what
do you think is going on here
well i frankly i think it smells a
little bit like watergate
and uh
again i don't agree with mr farrell
out of the original
thousand pages that were finally
obtained out of that they were able to
get this evidence of the fbi files so
something did come out of it which uh to
to a degree was is productive yeah how
did you feel uh during those watergate
years what was your feeling about what
was going on then on watergate yeah
frankly it was wrong
absolutely wrong
i'm a republican but
the time has come for the people of this
nation to quit voting their politics and
start voting their future thanks mr
farrell your reaction i i think he must
he misheard me what i was talking about
was the last time there was a
uh a confrontation with the threat of a
criminal contempt citation of congress
and that was back in december between
the senate and the white house and i
said that
when those documents were finally
released there was it was turned out to
be much to do about
nothing
next call here we go down to florida
fort walton beach florida good morning
what are you reading i'm reading the
northwest florida daily news and what
article are you reading okay they have a
picture and an article on one of the
major motels in navarre which is about
14 miles from here major motel that is
planning on
reopening about a hundred rooms we're
still recovering from opal around here
really yes there's still a lot of damage
standings are gone
a lot of cleanup but
may i express my thoughts about the
president sure
yes okay
i think
i could never think of voting for anyone
but
president clinton i think he and his
wife had done
wonderful things for our country so i am
very much a clinton fan what do you make
of uh stories like the uh
that we've been talking about in the
last 24 hours about
things
about the new book mrs clinton talking
to uh eleanor roosevelt does that kind
of thing bother you well
it really doesn't when i understand that
all she did was just
play a role like it wasn't as if she
believed in that
mystic
advisor or anything like that so and i
think it's just
and i am also with this man or some
other caller that i think this man that
wrote this book
has less and less
to
really
let us know what don is what's
real in this world because i think he's
so
anti-clinton that it's terrible all
right thanks you know it'd be
interesting to know at what point
somebody watches all this and says
that's it i'm going the other way
oh you mean switch switches yeah when
you watch the i mean articles come out
and everybody and all of the different
sides line up for and against and and
then all this i mean where is it in that
middle ground they said this is it this
is the straw that broke my back my gut
instinct is that um what happens is it
cements attitudes that are already there
that if you sort of think if you're a
republican and you
sort of think clinton was doing a
a midland job and all of a sudden this
start it's coming back then it drives
you back into the republican fold and
makes you very impassioned like the
callers we've had today um and if you're
a democrat you see it as a republican
conspiracy and um sort of cement your
attitudes and then of course the
independence in the middle
are going to weigh things and be of
course the swing voters in the fall have
you heard of this man
chopra no
never heard of it nope who is he
well he's a man that is from india
originally and uh the weekly standard
writes him up here talks about how he
picked up about 11 million dollars in
the last few years and public television
uses him for fundraisers and he's a man
that speaks a lot about spiritualism and
things like that and
they're basically accusing him here
alleging that he's a plagiarist
in this and that they go into some
detail about his personal life and
i it just it came at a time over the
weekend uh based on this article that
i thought you might might have heard of
him he used to be a follower of the
maharishi mahesh yogi is that the guy
who brought the beatles to india i think
it's the guy that lives in fairfield
iowa but we may learn that before the
program is over that he has a group of
followers people that follow uh
mr yogi or maharishi whatever however
you addressed him formally uh george
harrison mia farrow chopra counts naomi
judd elizabeth taylor joan london
michael milken diane von furstenberg and
other glitter glitterati in the know
among his followers that's what this
article by matt
labash says that guy still likes it the
guy who brought the beatles into you
george harrison
atlanta georgia you're next go ahead
please hi hi i'm watching um excuse me
i'm reading the atlanta constitution and
what are you what specific article are
you reading well
actually
when i tuned in i didn't know what was
going on but i had just been reading
arabs warned israel that's a you know
that actually turns out to be the lead
story in most papers this morning let's
see uh here it is in the washington post
by john lancaster yeah arabs warned
netanyahu on land return why did that
get your attention
well uh
i'm very sympathetic to the arab cause
and uh my children descended on the
father's side from uh rabbis
but i'm very sympathetic with the arabs
and uh i don't think we should be uh
sending so much money and over to israel
if they can't try a little bit harder i
think a lot of people might feel that
way all right thanks by the way for
calling in the los angeles times it's
also the lead arabs warned israel not to
retreat on peace
i thought it was an interesting comment
i read somewhere
over the weekend which which uh it was
saying uh
bill clinton had a bad week because of
the uh
files and the white water report and he
couldn't even get the israeli election
to work out the way he wanted it and it
sort of struck me as
a unique american arrogance that uh to
think that we could
control the way the israelis elect
governments
well at the top of the hours we said
earlier we're going to switch to a dole
clinton line at two lines and just for
this morning and just for the next
couple of hours so that we can uh find
out how you feel about all this we'll
have
bob tyrell here who runs the why are you
laughing whether we need more
partisanship this morning well this
morning we're going to have that this
morning independence you'll be back
after this morning don't get mad just
hold on it'll we'll be back to normal
and then lewis lapin will be here and he
has an article in uh harper's in the the
issue just out that says by gene lyons
it says that bloodsport
i'll let him tell you what they really
think but he they don't think much of
the of the book bloodsport and mr
stewart did you read that it should be a
great debate um i've been following gene
lyons
arguments and a lot of them are
compelling and i i might stick around to
watch
him and tyrell's face off
barnegat new jersey what are you reading
this morning uh i'm reading uh robert
novak's more than filed his column this
morning and uh in the new york post yes
sir and why did you choose that one i
think we've got the same column maybe
here in the washington post on page 23.
is it uh here it says it's the pure over
the fbi background files raises deeper
questions about the security office is
that the way it starts off right right
and why did you read that
well i've been reading quite a bit i'm a
registered democrat have been all my
life
and
i'm getting tired of people calling and
saying that bill clinton is the most
honest trustworthy and everything else
this man has been surrounded by
brown who's been was being investigated
now ping is being investigated
cisneros is being investigated uh you
got that o'leary who thinks that the the
tax money is all hers did you vote for
mr clinton i no when i he came on he's
the first democrat i ever voted against
when i saw him and that wife of his the
back of the hair on the back of my neck
stood up so you've never really changed
your mind about him
no it just keeps getting worse because
this man
he's the most evil thing that god ever
created all right thanks um
tell us how you really feel
this is the place to do that the most
evil man that god ever created now back
to this uh parole article in today's usa
today in this piece by mimi hall she
says that
mr pro
won't say whether he's going to run as
the reform party candidate but if he
were to run today according to their
poll he'd get 17 percent of the vote
in spite of that there's still a 16
percent split between bill clinton and
bob dole in bill clinton's favor if mr
pearl runs according to their poll
well i
i still think that
bob dole is one of the most compelling
figures that i've ever
covered here in washington and that if
he has a good convention that he's going
to come out of the convention people are
going to give him a second look in
september when they decide
who they're actually going to vote for
they'll watch the debates they'll see
how he handles themselves in the debates
and they'll make their decision
then and i don't think that these early
polls mean a lot other than to say that
people are generally kind of happy with
the way the economy is the way the
situation in the world is
and these are strengths that clinton can
continue to rely on
this is um
about our time but this is a first day
of slate
which we're going to talk to michael
kinsley before the morning's over
are you paying any attention to
cyberspace oh absolutely i think i think
it's a great idea the problem is
finding the time to seek it out i mean
one nice thing about magazines and
newspapers is that somebody delivers it
to you
if you can find a way that when you log
on your office computer
to have it show up
i think you have a lot more success it's
much easier to read a newspaper when
it's on your doorstep look at time
magazine gives two pages to this today
you know a sample form from slate up
here this is in time and you pick up us
news and go to the
front page of the live section the you
know the word online slate why do they
get so much attention to this uh he's a
smart guy and he's uh he's proven it by
doing well with other magazines and and
of course it's a cyberspace it's sort of
high-tech sexiness to it so then you
look at broadcasting in cable magazine
and they talk about uh taking on
ted one goliath versus two davids you've
got bob wright of nbc and they're going
to start on the 15th of july with an all
news network and sometime later the fall
we're supposed to have a network here
with mr murdoch taking on mr turner
what's this mean for the american people
i think one thing is that it continually
it continues the trend of fragmenting
where they get their news from and
they'll have so many different options
that you know those days when walter
cronkite
could turn the country against the
vietnam war with a couple of comments or
they're gone already but this is going
to even further the process
for those of you who
have
a newspaper that carries non-sequitur
here's what it looks like this morning
and this is a
gentleman that has been responsible for
winning something called the golden
spike award and he's going to join us
his name's wiley miller and he's going
to join us here in a few minutes to talk
about what the golden spike award is and
how he won it
mr farrell what uh what is the rest of
uh this week in june like here in this
town
uh i i i call it silly season i think
it's just going to get get worse i mean
the claims encounter claims on both
offense and defense from the republicans
the democrats are just going to uh
increase
and uh hopefully we'll have a little bit
of a distraction from all this when the
olympics come and we start paying
attention to a sport that's more
i know honest
thanks for joining us honorable
not on us honest and honorable thank you
very much for joining us my pleasure as
we said earlier we have our 25 winners
in town of our scholarship contest
you'll meet some more of those folks or
some we haven't met any of them yet uh
in our next uh couple of hours here this
morning we're gonna be talking with them
uh and uh we've got some more also the
cartoonists that were in attendance at
that phoenix convention a couple weeks
ago draper hill and etta home
and this is a bit of a short break here
and then we'll continue
talking about cartooning and be back
draper hill what's the point of this
cartoon where i should say
it seems fairly obvious what led you to
want to do this oh uh a memory of a
theatrical production which probably
doesn't bear directly on keeping track
of it waiting for godot but here the
unseen factor of
a third-party challenge by someone like
ross perot
just seemed to me to give an opportunity
to show the different reactions of the
two
probable candidates do you have a
personal political philosophy that
guides you
uh
i have impulses i have likes and
dislikes uh
i grew up in an
excellent republican family in
massachusetts and found things
immediately to rebel against and as you
get older
particular positions assert themselves
and feelings become stronger and
somewhat my cartoons i think are
personality driven i'm very strong on
caricature or i try to be how did you
get into this
i
tried to draw funny cartoons for the
harvard lampoon
sports cartoons for the high school
and local paper and then i got
interested in the history of caricature
and i've written on that a good deal
english and american
and that kind of keeps my
curiosity alive in other fields how
would you rate this
presidential campaign for cartoonists so
far
well it's it's been exciting and i think
it's going to get more exciting still
normally i'd say that
unlike the conventional wisdom
presidential seasons tend to be the most
stressful on the cartoonists because you
start with a bunch of people you've got
to
adjust to
feel emotions about and then most of
them are out of the running by now so
that
it's it's a new ball game
it's an automatic new ball game by uh
early summer every time and you've got
to come up with new solutions we see
both the president and bob dole on this
which one of those faces do you uh like
the most to draw
uh
well i'm still
confessed to working for different
solutions on dole whom i can do better
from either the side or three quarters
the front clinton is fun to draw
and uh and has been
all these two uh
i don't know uh
cartoons come down to
heads that you can turn on a lathe or
heads that you construct out of your
imagination of the late president nixon
was probably something that you could
turn into a three-dimensional object
because
because you're just a shape
but the easiest cartoonists are subjects
are not always the ones you're expecting
for me gerald ford
was always the most fun to draw of any
in the last 30 years
and after a while i keep looking for
ways to do president clinton differently
and i'm
the moment you get satisfied it means
you've created a recipe and you're in
trouble because it's going to bite you
and
stay frozen by the way on your cartoon
there do you think
mr pearl will ever show up
oh
well if he just stood up he'd have an
interesting chinese hat a mandarin
expression and will he show up
i think it gets becomes less likely
in the sense i take you to be inquiring
about
less likely but never impossible but
then
godot never showed up in a home what
would you say is your philosophy of
cartooning
oh dear
i'm not sure that i have one just uh
pick up the paper listen to the news
and uh until you boil a little bit and
then come in
how often do you draw
six a week
you have a political philosophy
um
it's it's sort of day by day but i'm i'm
certainly going out of style i suppose
i'm a liberal
how did you get into this in the first
place
accidentally i suppose i've always i've
done various kinds of cartooning and uh
editorial cartooning's the best kind but
but but i always just like to draw
cartoons i think it's a birth defect
where were you born somerville texas
and how long have you worked for the
fort worth star telegram
about 24 years
and you've been doing they're patient
aren't they
very patient
now let's look up here at just this
cartoon right here what is what is this
and why did you choose this one to bring
to the cartoonist group meeting um
this may not have have come from a
specific
article in the newspaper but of course
it was just when uh when uh though it
was clear that dole had i can't see the
date any longer
that doe was going to be the uh
the nominee the republican party but
that
in in my opinion buchanan had
sort of won the platform fight
so
just a crazy twist on an old cliche how
do you like the president
clinton well contrary to what one of the
other cartoonists uh said while ago i'm
not a very good character but i like
clinton because his hair
what do you think of him politically
politically
um
i i get on his case every now and then
but uh
i think he's a
pretty intelligent fellow
at a home uh
talking to us at the phoenix convention
and and she makes her home down in fort
worth
on the desk here is an official ballot
for the 1996 golden spike award and
vote for the rejected cartoon that
surprised you the most that it was
deemed un
publishable and you're supposed to name
the cartoonist uh and this boat was
taken a couple weeks ago and wiley
miller won this is that true mr miller
yes it is
where are you this morning by the way i
am in iowa city how does it feel to to
win the golden spike award and what does
it mean oh i think it's terrific because
uh
it's
it uh
points out what we are supposed to be
doing in editorial cartooning we're
supposed to be pushing the envelope
we're supposed to be
prodding and
it's more of a
statement against censorship and against
editorial uh
waxness that's a word uh in in the
american newspapers today
we had a uh last thursday
sitting here and and we had a fellow
who's upset about a cartoon that was
published in the dallas morning news and
and we just kind of played a little game
of some people thought it was childish
but it was interesting to do and never
showed the audience the cartoon
he faxed it to us just to show what it
was like when you couldn't see something
that somebody else could
and uh i've got your winner i think i've
got your winner here is is um
is this the one that won the golden
spike award can you see us
where you are uh yes
is this the winner yeah i think that
that's the one that uh most people
mentioned all right let's get a little
closer on that if we could and uh
it says here the true function of board
meetings was this ever published uh yes
this was uh
you know from my comic strip
non-sequitur which is nationally
syndicated and there were several
newspapers across the country that would
not publish this because they they were
afraid that it would get phone calls
why
uh i i don't know they thought it was
offensive now if i had the guy's pants
down around his ankles i could see it
but uh
i i was kind of baffled about that too
but also for the papers that it did run
in uh it got a tremendous response from
the readership the people loved it did
you win
the award going away by yourself
no it was a three-way tie
and uh one of them was steve benson i
see her on my list and ed stein right
um
how often uh and i've got your it's in
the washington post your non-sequitur uh
cartoon [ __ ] explain this to someone
who's never seen it what is it okay you
know uh it happened today is the uh uh
a daily edition of what i've been doing
in my sundays uh for a little while now
i've introduced a
uh character in here in this kind of a
spiritual take on uh
on the world
using a character to go into different
lives uh in the past
and to comment uh you know to relate to
on what's going on today
uh his name is homer and uh it's a
reincarnation theme and what i get to do
with this it's it's kind of fun because
i like going in the opposite direction
everybody else goes in that's part of
being a contrarian as a cartoonist how
long have you been doing this uh
non-sequitur has been going four and a
half years
now and what does non-sequitur mean
well literal translation is does not
follow
and where did you get the titles what i
was getting at for the cartoon story
well because the uh
uh
when i developed the strip i
was looking at it and say okay what the
hell am i going to call this thing
and that seemed to be the the name that
was most apt because uh today's cartoon
is going to have absolutely nothing to
do with tomorrow's cartoon how did you
get into this business
oh god
cartooning i feel is born into uh as
most cartoonists are it's something that
starts from an early age
and you just can't leave it alone we're
not like normal people
where
you know every kid grows up reading the
comics but that that wasn't good enough
for us crime we had to draw that draw it
as well let me um let me show you this
cartoon the audience never did see this
last week this was by it's a
by buddy hickerson do you know him
oh yeah i don't know him personally now
i know well the way this all started a
fellow named bob reynolds in arlington
texas said he was so mad about seeing
this cartoon that he wrote called the
dallas morning news and i've got a
letter here from ralph langer who he
wrote to mr reynolds saying he
understood his point he was upset about
this cartoon he said he tended to agree
that it was probably over the line of
good taste i'm gonna show it
and and let our audience see what we
wouldn't let him see last week
this is show it up there it's the
quickmans by buddy richardson it says if
it's all the same to you i'd like to
postpone committing to any position at
the present time this is ross perot and
uh allegedly his wife margot there in in
the in that position and can i buy you
something he says here and and um ross
perot's wedding night day four uh does
that offend you
uh no
not at all uh do you think that the
dallas morning news uh senior vice
president mr langer an executive editor
should have said it's uh probably over
the line of good taste
uh
no
frankly
uh i i don't think that's a line of good
taste
so how far how far should you go
uh
that that's
really hard to say um
there there is a line and the cartoonist
knows it when he gets to it um
that uh is is up to the line i don't
think it's over the line
and how often have you had an editor say
that is over the line and you said yeah
i was trying to slip that one by you oh
um i don't send anything in that i think
is over the line uh because i don't want
to waste my time if it's because i know
if it's over the line that it's not
going to get published it's going to be
more trouble than it's worth um
but i do like to push the envelope let
me let me show another one of your
cartoons this is uh
from the 1996
washington post writers group sends it
out over here it says remainders
like stuff without pictures and then it
says gen x bookstore
and then as you see it goes there's one
that's called cool and then this
bookstore uh book shelf says sucks and
then all sales are like a final dude
what's the point of this and did this
get in
yes like i said this was published in
most papers but there were several
newspapers that wouldn't run it because
they think the word sucks is uh is an
obscenity um
which they are not keeping up with the
times
that
uh that it's a very generic term meaning
it's not very good
uh and the
uh
the youth of today uh my i have two
daughters who are among that group that
the world is broken up into two
divisions it's either cool or it sucks
there is no in between uh how old are
your kids uh 23 and 14.
and that language doesn't bother you no
i'm it's very generic
it it doesn't mean what
it used to mean i sucks is very common
you hear it on tv constantly now should
in your opinion the editors be allowed
to spike up
a cartoon is that the way it should work
in this system
that is an editorial decision um
you know it's their newspaper and they
have that right to
but
as editors are supposed to be the
guardians of the first amendment in
freedom of speech they should be very
judicious about that there are some
editors who just love to spike things
who go overboard on it
they should
let just about everything
run it is not the newspaper's job to
protect people from being offended
the the cartoon that will not offend
somebody somewhere has yet to be drawn
wiley miller of burbank california
originally
virginia commonwealth university right
non-sequitur for the last four and a
half years
editorial cartoonist for seven years at
the san francisco chronicle uh all the
things that you the san francisco
examiner better get that in
i'm sorry yeah
what's left of the examiner right there
uh
hey thanks a lot for joining us this
morning and uh we appreciate you coming
by i hope to see you here on the set
someday soon okay great thanks winner of
the cartoonist the
golden spike award the american
association of cartoonists that met out
in phoenix a couple weeks ago
and as we said i'm gonna reach over here
and grab our big book of uh these are
award winners uh
from our scholarship
uh
contest and uh it started as a hundred
thousand dollar contest and was moved to
a 200 000 scholarship contest we had so
many uh
good entries and here's the the big
award winner marie gasper and we've
talked about this before where there are
nine different flags there um
and we can go through this this
book uh maybe as the program goes on to
see some of the
the contest wonders a lot of it was art
some of it was poetry some of it was
video someone was audio
and we have a we're spending a whole
week with our
25 top winners here and
those 25 are assembled on another floor
here and we're going to meet some of
them for just a couple of minutes there
you can see a bunch of folks that's a
live picture from our 8th floor room and
let me ask our award winners if we can i
think uh
we've got a few of them there with their
winners on the wall there who let me ask
the six of you that we've designated for
this segment just to give us your name
and to tell us
why you entered the contest who's first
up there somebody hold up their hand and
go first down on the far left there
yes sir right there just somebody agree
go ahead
okay well i'm actually from mulberry new
hampshire and my project was on i work
at wmur tv in manchester and we hosted
the first
republican debate back in february and i
met the candidates and was able to
just that's how i decided on what to
write for a project and my essay was on
it was a photo essay along with a
regular essay and it was about the night
down at channel nine and the protest
outside and what you were able to
actually see on tv
and was it reflected
as to what actually happened
at the debate so that was that was
mostly it next to you is uh and by the
way where are you going to school next
year uh syracuse you got a
presidential party that you want to tell
us about what you're on one side or the
other
uh this early in the morning um
i i think um after all the people i met
at the debate i think
clinton should uh be back in the white
house how about you bill jennings are
you there next time yeah i'm billy
jennings from shaker heights ohio um
basically what i did i did a poem about
the road to the white house series
and basically i just talked about how it
helped
how it helped me make like the right
decisions and get more familiar with the
different candidates in this year's
election how did you get interested in
this in the first place basically my mom
told me about it she said um you're
going to enter a lot of different
chances to win a scholarship and this is
one of the first ones i did is your mom
here with you this week yes she is
well hope get it look forward to meeting
her before the week's over
what about you in politics have you made
a decision are you going to vote for uh
yeah i'm pretty much a clinton fan
where are you going to college to miami
university right there in ohio yeah okay
brad taylor's standing next to you
yes good morning sir good morning
where's your home
centerville ohio
and uh what got you into this
well after participating in a congress
simulation in my class called congress
in the classroom
i basically i was senator phil graham so
i basically started following c-span and
various other things
so i entitled my report called
informative decisions and i basically
showed in detail how c-spanned and what
effect it had on my decision
and i will admit that i am uh
duel for president
when did you make up your mind to be for
mr dole uh
probably back in february and uh right
after i made up my mind i went i
participated in something called ohio
and i got to go to the iowa caucus and
work for him so i really i got to meet
him there too so after that i really was
very proud of him and i thought he
should lead our country what are you
going to do next year
i'm not sure but i am going to be going
to miami university along with billy
here so
so you you too can duke it out
politically while you're down yes
buddy thor tharp i believe is that the
correct pronunciation that's right good
morning good morning now uh where are
you from i'm from tallahassee florida
and how'd you get into all this i just
um saw the commercial and i've been
doing videos for since forever and i
just knew i had to enter a video
and what kind of a video was it it was a
video that showed the variety of
c-span's programming and i also wrote a
song
called c-span's the one kind of you know
at the end to pull everything together
you're the one that did c spanzer one
right
we'll have to get that out and play it
later uh what about next year what are
you gonna do um this fall i'm going to
go to new york university film school
major film and television yeah we're not
talking about next year we're talking
about this fall aren't we
how about your voting decision um well i
definitely won't be voting for clinton
why not because i don't think the
american public can trust him and i
think it's time for a change and do you
have a sense yet of which way you're
going to go
is it going to be bob dole or somebody
else
i don't know yeah
standing next to you is lorraine falk is
that right lauren folk i'm sorry
where are you from i'm from troy
michigan and how did you get into this
um i found out about the contest from
the scholarship file at my school and
since i enjoy writing i thought this
would be a good way to write and learn
more about the election
and what did you put in that that uh
well i submitted my project in the
format of a news magazine it's called
politics in 96
and basically i just wrote articles that
discuss the benefits of c-span's
programming
and what about your vote have you
decided um yes i'm for clinton why
because i think he shows true concern
for the people and i think clinton can
be trusted and how about next fall where
are you going to go to school university
of michigan
thanks for being here we'll look forward
to shaking your hand later colleen is
that right haley kaelin i'm messing
these names up this morning good morning
good morning kaylene love
of what city mesa arizona how did you
get into all this i saw the ad on c-span
and my mom was like quick right she
filled it out and she wrote it down for
me and
i went for it
and what did you do
well i sort of took a play off the dick
jane and spot books that i used to read
when i was little you know c-spot c-spot
run so i did you know c-span c-span run
and running in terms of the elections
and it's basically a comic book
featuring
my
ap government teacher mr good
and dick and jane and obviously c-span
so it's basically
just a comic book detailing how dick and
jane learn and are educated through
c-span programming and they're therefore
able to vote in the election much more
educated than they would have
previously what are you going to do
politically this fall who are you going
to vote for
i'm still wrestling with that though i
tend to identify with the moderate
republicans
i'm still sort of unsure about the
candidates this year and how about
school i'm going to the university of
arizona in tucson arizona studying what
um probably political science or
international studies with an emphasis
on political science hey thank you all
we'll be back up there in that room
later on in a few minutes to meet some
more of you and thanks for being here
we're excited that you're going to be
here look forward to spending some time
before the week's over
and we're going to come back to this
room in just a moment we have uh emmett
bob tyrell
and also louis lapham to join us and in
this next two hours we're going to split
the lines only for this particular
morning between bob dole and bill
clinton there'll be a clinton line and a
dull line and all you folks that are
independents will get to you
as as time goes by this week there'll be
plenty of time to get involved but we're
going to try it this morning because
there's so strong of partisanship in the
news this morning and we want to hear
what the two sides think and by the way
on our scholarship winners we had no
idea before they won what side they were
on so those of you who looking for
balance and all this
it's a random sample
we just saw their entries we did not
know anything else about them and
the contest had about 325 winners we'll
be back in a moment
coming up at 9 30 a.m eastern time we'll
take a look at the new online magazine
slate with its editor michael kinsley
and in a moment our newspaper round
table with lewis lapham of harper's
magazine and emmett terrell of the
american spectator
first we'll visit with one of our
national scholarship competition winners
[Music]
we have a contest going on this year and
she
turned in an essay and answered the
question how will c-span programming
affect her first vote and she was one of
the delegate winners want some money to
go to school
and
also a visit from the bus do you want to
tell us a little bit about your project
and what you did
okay well
the question was how will c-span
programming affect your president's
first presidential vote
so i just um i've been watching c-span
for a while
he's been junkie all of you
so um
i don't know and i and i guess these
fans would really like
help me find out who bob dole really was
and
um that's when i first started liking
him when i watched him on c's pan when i
watched him in action in the senate when
when i learned about his history and all
that
congratulations yumnan being a delegate
winner in the student scholarship
competition could you describe your
winning project
uh yeah i wrote an essay on how
different c-span programs such as
wrote to the white house
washington journal
some congressional legislative
programming and some coverage of stump
speeches and debates
helped me find out what all the
candidates were really like
and uh
helped me find out
particularly what bob dole was really
like because he's had a lot of negative
media coverage so
it helped me make an informed choice
by filtering out all the negative ads
all the misleading negative ads by other
candidates
and it helped me look at each candidate
in a positive
way
because by listening to what they really
meant instead of hearing the media spin
on it
i i got
an impression that all their arguments
were pretty logical who are you going to
vote for in 1996
bob dole because i
support his views on most issues i think
his fiscal policy is very important
because
it uh
encourages people to go out in pursuit
of the american dream rather than the
more uh the one of the democratic party
which i think is more geared towards uh
telling people to wait and let the
american dream come to them and i just
don't think that you succeed by waiting
for dreams to come to you you got to go
out in pursuit of them i think in 88 i
was this is really interesting because i
was i was a supporter of bush i followed
politics then too
and i was very upset when dole won the
iowa caucuses i thought we could never
have this man in the white house that
would be terrible
but i think
that was partly because of the media's
negative portrayal of him of of his
supposed mean streak which i think is
non-existent but
um
so i
i did try to learn more about dolan um i
the more i learned about his history his
life is just such a powerful story it's
it's such
it's such a
uh fulfillment of
uh
of of ambitions due to determination and
it's it's really an inspiration to all
of us that we can really do something we
can really overcome odds if we are
determined enough to do it
so the more i learned about dole the
more i liked him the more i supported
him and i just
before i knew it i was volunteering for
his campaign and
i'm doing everything i can to see to it
that he gets in the white house
today the c-span school bus travels from
tok to haines alaska
washington journal coffee mugs are now
available if you'd like to order one
call 1-800-523-3174
washington journal continues
mr lapham of harpers what are you
reading this morning good morning brian
i'm reading well i'm
reading on the front page of the
washington post bob woodward
pulitzer prize-winning journalist and so
on
apparently an excerpt from a new book
and uh
talking about bob dole apparently he's
writing about both candidates and the
book is called the choice
and that to me is a joke because i i see
no choice between
the two candidates to me they are
all but one and the same but so this is
a
hype and a promotion
trying to build interest in uh
campaign that is really about nothing
much at all what about the book it's
it's also a hype of one of the
washington post's writers
yesterday was even more uh
hyper they had two stories are derived
from the book on the top part of the
page so i mean
today you caught the post on kind of a
low key day when they only
one of their writers right they're
promoting their own writer their own
book they're promoting a uh a campaign
in which
as i say there's not much difference
between the two candidates so that this
essentially is advertising copy one for
a campaign and two uh
for a writer and three for a paper
now the audience should know you agreed
that i could tell the audience that you
do not know the flap over this
this
the story from yesterday do you no i
don't know nothing about it now in
fairness to you where have you been
traveling have you did you not read the
papers yesterday i don't read the no i
don't read the papers on sunday i was in
rhode island with my family
rhode island with his family what what
is your take i mean folks out there will
not believe that he does not know what
everybody on television has been
flapping around about for 24 hours i
think it's a healthy thing
i would like to what we're talking about
is the story in uh
the post yesterday you missed the number
two story hyping the number one writer
in the post yesterday and it's here in
the it's here at newsweek by the way
and mr woodward will be here on this
program on thursday
uh here you have his advisor and her
guru
yeah
and the story is about
uh
hillary clinton while uh first lady over
the last
two years has been having seances in the
white house with eleanor roosevelt and
gandhi she uh was asked if she'd lot by
her spiritual advisor in the white house
uh jane houston a new cook yeah a new
crew
if she would like to enter into a seance
with jesus christ and she said no it
would be too personal i guess maybe
because you know christ would be on kind
of a
one-to-one basis they'd be on a level
playing field but when you took hillary
could talk down to eleanor and uganda
all right so okay that's that's
entertaining right you think it's
entertaining but uh could i ask lewis a
question
louis uh based on your wide cosmopolitan
knowledge of the world do you think
eleanor and do you think hillary really
talked with eleanor or was it someone
else that was talking to hillary well
listen i
i tend to doubt that she was talking to
eleanor but the uh we are after all in a
very religious country who and where is
she talking to
mark fabiano mark fabian
i have no idea who she's talking to i
mean we are in a
but it's very uh mainstream american i
mean mrs reagan talked to an astrologist
the
mr reagan believed that there was some
sort of armageddon arriving and with the
dawn of the millennium well i mean we're
in a country where 95 of the american
people believe in
literally in in the presence of the
devil
i mean we're surrounded on all sides of
your career trying to to uh
may be the devil i do not emulate the
devil at least no i haven't i've tried
to i try to talk in an historically
minded way and it's it's sometimes very
difficult in a country that is filled
with people who want to believe in
in the historian did you have in mind uh
gibbon
which historian vicinities which
historian are you this is
neither of those gentlemen but any
historian any any historically minded uh
um
perspective i mean we live in a country
where people buy you know i mean this
guy
this is ridiculous here you're running
down hillary she's got a sense of
history she talked to eleanor she talked
to gandhi she where she was uh reluctant
to talk to jesus christ i mean she
didn't just talk to some guy across the
room she talked to historic figures let
me just uh but in here just a second and
tell the audience uh something we've
been talking about we're gonna have
these two lines this morning and i know
some of you are just
ready to leap off the couch uh mad at us
because we're splitting the lines
clinton and dole you can see it oh we
have another line i see okay we're going
to bring in the other that's we're going
to make sure that other people get a
chance
to get their two cents in here but for
the morning we're going to try to split
these lines so that we can have a debate
here
bob dole supporters bill clinton
supporters and other
um but before we get to the phones and
we will shortly there are a couple of
things first you have a book
yes and uh is there would there if
somebody at the washington post want to
take this book and write a lead story to
put on the front page what would the
news be
i think the news story is that i have
gone beyond mean airport and the report
of state troopers around bill clinton
that he knew about drug shipment and
money laundering
in demena airport
and
i've gone beyond that to things that
clinton knew
uh these troopers were involved in after
mina airport and in association with
rogue members of the american
intelligence community i think that
would be uh
the news story there
uh on the morning times morning uh
washington times reports of another book
roger morris's book which
uh asserts that when clinton as a
student went to eastern europe he uh was
working for the cia in this book i
interviewed the people he was
visiting in eastern europe and in fact
in the latest issue of the american
spectator i have an excerpt from it
which is kind of terribly interesting in
my opinion because the people he
visited with and central in
prague
were communists and their families had
founded the communist party and that's a
very actually it's a funny story
because when he went back there as
president of the united states there was
a great controversy over this was in 94
whether the
anti-communists could tear down this a
statute to the to
bill clinton's host in 69 and clinton
turned to
hovel and said don't tear that statue
down it's part of historic preservation
even though the fellow actor spent world
war ii in moscow
are you interested yet in what he's
saying no
i mean to me it's like talking to uh
hillary's guru i mean we're now into the
conspiracy theories about clinton and
we're in now wait a second i actually
interviewed these people they exist
and
oh i mean again we're in the world of uh
uh
miracle and speculation and conspiracy i
mean on the one hand are you saying that
clinton is a communist no just stick
with what is he helping the war in
nicaragua
being a man interested in history and i
would assume interested in the text
this book says the people he visited
with
are alive today were alive then and are
communists and so i mean it's
interesting i mean if i were to um
very hard to get through life in the
last several 30 years not talking to a
congressman you're full of commentary
here i'm merely filled with it speaking
of history and historians cool
observation of who these people are now
clinton has talked to a communist so
what he lived he stayed with communists
well it was 1969 and in 1970 and there
was such a thing as the prague spring
which those people had put under heel
are you suggesting that he was somehow
an agent of no i'm
i am telling you he's a little
indelicate about the associations we
have to go to the phones i want to show
you the article we'll have our guest mr
lapin explain this to us it's by gene
lyons it's the second of two articles
that have been printed and the headline
is to make a cow laugh a bad book about
the phony white water scandal but first
bowling brook illinois a bill clinton
supporter good morning
good morning how are you
i'm very well thank you what do you want
to say about our president well justin i
want to call in support of him i think
his economic policy has been good for
the country
i think he deserves another term what do
you think of all this discussion about
the uh the gene houston story and bob
woodward in the washington post and uh
whitewater well i think that's just all
politics
i think it means nothing as to the
ability to do the job is there any point
where you will become irritated in this
and and not be a supporter no
did you and so you you feel very
strongly about mr clinton yes i do i
think his policy as i said before has
been good for this country okay let's
just let's go over to uh i i think we've
got that we don't have a call waiting so
we're going to have to get a call up
with i thought we had a bob dole call
there for a moment but uh what's your
reaction uh to this lady yes
well um
i
eric hoffer wrote a book called the true
believer and now i guess we we've seen a
lady true believer
she said that nothing that happens or
can be revealed will change your view of
bill clinton i'd like to have support
like that amongst the american people
but
on the other hand i would like active
minds to support me and if they find out
something wrong that i've done i would
hope they would withdraw their support
explain this article if you would please
sir
this is a book review by uh it's a
review of a book by a man named james
stewart who wrote a book called blood
sport
which is supposedly the
full explanation of the whitewater
scandal in the real estate deals and our
writer lyons a reporter from arkansas
points out that the book is in large
part
nothing more than malicious rumor that
there is no
evidence there is nothing
to connect clinton as governor to
abuse of power or graft in the white
water let me read what he says blood
sport by pulitzer prize winning
journalist james b stewart is a is
low-brow entertainment of a similar ilk
intended to profit the offer author and
amuse the livestock it purports to tell
the inside story what has come to be
known as the whitewater scandal instead
it offers stale rumor and specious fact
fictitious dialogue presented as
transcribed conversation inept reporting
and indictment proven by assertion
instead of argument
that's true that's that that's the
writer's
position on that book that's gene lyon's
position on bloodsport yes and and
what's your technique well gene is is uh
much like lewis he's unfazed by the
facts um he's been saying this sort of
thing uh
over the past couple of years and he'll
probably continue to say them
notwithstanding the fact that there are
now 24 convictions out of
the last whitewater case and there will
be more convictions coming down the road
that's uh lyons is saying exactly what
sarbanes has said and christopher dodd
said in the minority
uh whitewater report in other words
yes we found a lot of evidence of
various forms of malpractice but nothing
to prove
clinton's guilt on the charges
specified and that's true triangle
virginia i've got to get a bob dole call
in here go ahead triangle why do you
like bob dole
well i'll tell you what bob dole wasn't
my first uh choice to be honest with you
i i liked phil graham a lot better than
bob dole but there is nothing in this
world that would make me vote for bill
clinton bill clinton is a consummate
liar he is the most effective liar i've
ever seen
and his rise in the poll the most ironic
ironic thing is his rise in the poll
has been because of
taking on republican ideas and somehow
he has managed to make the american
people believe that he is more
republican than bob dole is
and uh i can't figure out how that is
the media has managed to push the
republicans
farther to the right in the people's
mind than they actually are and clinton
has been
and now a discussion of the future of
democracy
good evening excuse me good evening
we got to get the mic good evening
and welcome to the ford hall forum
my name is marvin grossman and i'm a
member of the forum's board of directors
tonight's program promises to be an
informative and exciting one
assembled on this stage
are three of our nation's most eminent
historians and one of its most
distinguished editors
we are proud to be co-sponsoring this
panel discussion with harper's magazine
and i would like to thank louis lapham
our moderator this evening and his staff
at harpers for their invaluable and
continuing support
panelists tonight will focus attention
on the lessons that can be gathered from
the past
and directed towards the future
at issue is what citizens need to know
to be able to be effective participants
in our democracy
what information do citizens need in
order to be active discerning members of
their immediate community
their nation and their world
and how can they acquire that
information
the forum has concerned itself with
these questions since its founding in
1908
in fulfilling our commitment to serve
the public
we ask ourselves
how can the forum best provide access to
the ideas and individuals who are
shaping history
why
when access to information can be had
from a number of sources
do we feel it's important to preserve a
stronghold for a public forum
to put it quite simply
it's because no other venue permits you
to interact in person
with individuals who are helping to
shape the lives of millions of our
citizens
although the ford hall forum is
recognized as a cultural landmark
we can reflect reflect proudly on the
list of famous speakers who have brought
their views here
tonight please consider becoming a
member of the forum or contributing what
you can to ensure the continuity of our
programming
we also request that you complete our
audience surveys
so that we are well informed on issues
that are important to you
our ushers at the back of the hall
will be available at the end of the
program to help you with memberships
accept your contributions and collect
your surveys
and now
on to this evening speakers
it is my great pleasure to introduce our
moderator lewis lapham
educated at yale and cambridge mr lapham
has been editor of harper since
1983
he received the 1995 national magazine
award in the essays and criticism
category for his monthly notebook column
indeed it was last may's notebook piece
timelines
that served as the inspiration for this
program
host of the pbs program bookmark from
1989 to 1991
lapham is the author of five books
including hotel america
scenes in the lobby of the far de siekla
over the past three years harper's
magazine has won more national awards
than any other publication in america
it is with great pleasure that i under
introduce the person who has made this
evening possible mr lewis lapham
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
delighted to be here and i'm delighted
to
have this conversation with
the eminent gentleman to my right the
most i don't think any of them need long
introduction
alan brinkley is a professor of american
history at columbia university and he
has taught at mit at harvard and at
princeton
he writes voluminously for
the
the literary press
and in 1983 he won a national book award
for
his book called voices of protest huey
long father
coughlin and the great depression
next to him is
mr john kenneth galbraith
an extraordinarily imminent writer very
graceful writer i've read
many of his books among them the
affluent society in the new industrial
state
he served the roosevelt administration
and he served as ambassador to india
in the
john kennedy administration
and he has as they say written the book
or many books on
economics
arthur schlesinger is the
won a pulitzer prize
and a national book award he's written a
magnificent book on jackson which is one
i've read more than once
and he was also a member of the kennedy
administration and he
won a number of prizes for a book called
a thousand days john f kennedy in the
white house
and he is presently the albert
schweitzer professor emeritus of the
humanities at the city university of new
york
and i can't imagine any three gentlemen
from whom i would rather hear on the
evening's topic
the evening's topic is
why
study history what do we learn from it
what's the point
we've all heard the
stories about the illiterate american
public
that knows little or nothing of its own
history about students who can't find
california on a map or who don't know
which which came first the civil war the
revolutionary war
but how does our ignorance damage us
history doesn't pay the grocers bill it
doesn't settle the
argument in the faculty lounge it
doesn't win the next election
why then worry about it
where is the uh
purpose
gibbon said that history is little more
than the
register of the crimes follies and
misfortunes of mankind
hegel said that what experience and
history teach us is that people in
governments
never have learned anything from history
so
why then
study
and i begin
with professor brinkley
thank you it's a
act of hubris i suppose to talk about
the
importance of history sitting in faneuil
hall
uh and and perhaps even greater an act
of hubris uh sitting next to ken
galbraith and arthur schlesinger
who have done so much both to
write history and to shape it
but i i this is a difficult question to
answer and perhaps for no one more
difficult than for an historian
i cannot argue uh that history
settles uh political debates or provides
us a guide uh to the future or
uh
offers solutions to our social problems
but there is a paradox i think in the
role that history plays in our world
today on the one hand uh as mr lapham
has pointed out
uh both tonight and in a very eloquent
essay he wrote in harper's last january
uh the knowledge of history among our
students and among our population uh is
declining uh and in many areas of
american life is shockingly low
on the other hand uh it may be that
there have been few times in our history
when history has been more visible in
our public culture
more debated i just think of some of the
battles over history of the last few
years the battle over the national
history standards the battle over the
enola gay exhibit at the smithsonian the
controversies surrounding the colombian
quincentennial uh four years ago
and i could go on and on as not to
mention the continuing and and incessant
battles over
uh ethnic and racial histories and
gender history
clearly somebody thinks history is
important uh and people fight over
history because they think uh it
exercised some power
in our world when i try to explain to
students uh why i think it's worthwhile
to study history i i tend to say three
things
uh
one is that i like to believe that
history is important because it adds to
uh the richness of our lives it has an
almost aesthetic value in the same way
that the literature does and any other
of the humanities do uh it deepens our
understanding of the world it helps us
to feel that we're part of something
larger than ourselves and our immediate
surroundings
i also think and although this is i
realize controversial that history is of
value
to many people because it validates
their lives in some way it helps them
feel connected
uh
to a society from which they might
otherwise feel disconnected
uh there's great controversy of course
about the way in which various racial
and ethnic and group histories have been
uh presented in recent years and and
that debate is a very important one
uh but i am not prepared to say uh that
there is no value
in the way in which individuals and
groups retrieve their history as a way
of
retrieving something of themselves
but to me at least the the most
important reason to study history is the
same reason that makes history so
controversial and so much a source of
conflict in our culture and that is that
history is whether we like it or not an
instrument of power
in this presidential election uh it's
very clear that there are at least two
histories uh that are being covertly and
sometimes overtly debated
uh the history of the 1960s uh and the
history of the world war ii generation
uh beyond that we only need think about
our politics and our public life of the
last generation to think of many other
kinds of history that have been
very powerful implements in the hands of
many different groups of people the
history of the vietnam war
uh the history of the great society the
history of world war ii the history of
world war one the history of slavery
uh
and that's just in the relatively recent
american past all over the world history
is used constantly
uh to validate to delegitimize to
empower to disempower
uh otherwise uh why would it be that so
many authoritarian totalitarian states
have exerted so much energy and devoted
so many resources uh to controlling
their own histories
to airbrushing people in and out of
history
uh to uh making sure that only an
official uh and and carefully controlled
version of the past is presented to
their public
history may not provide us definitive
answers to anything but history is all
around us whether we like it or not
and our only defense
against the way in which history is used
by others is to have some knowledge of
history ourselves
and that to me is if
among many other reasons
a good enough reason by itself
to value the study of history
ken
i should like to
mention in passing one point that
professor brinkley
uh started to
meant started on and slipped over
uh i don't see why we should have to
find uses for history
why can't we just enjoy it
it's extraordinarily interesting
why do we have to find
a purpose for everything we do
and therefore why do we have to find a
purpose for history but on the other
hand
i must
say that
i do have a strong feeling
that there is an absolutely essential
role of history
in our public understanding
and particularly
that we tend to attribute
to legislative action political action
to
the
everyday pressures of life what can only
be
explained
by the greater thrust of history
i began
teaching at harvard some years ago
62 years ago last month to be exact
and
at that time the united states was
primarily
an agricultural country
half of the gainfully employed were in
agriculture and many more were in
agricultural local villages
that sort of society
that sort of economy
did not require
social security old age pensions the old
were looked after by the young
it didn't
involve
unemployment compensation
because
there
may maybe good times and bad times in
the farm
but there's no unemployment
there was no great question of medical
care
because a terrible fact was that doctors
had very little to sell
it was only after the great
historical thrust
of medical
education
met surgical procedures
medical knowledge
that
it became
a fact a terrible fact
that having money
having the ability to pay
made the difference
between whether you lived or whether you
were sick
and whether you died
and thus the whole question
was of headache of medical care
thrust into
the public domain the public
consciousness
by historical change in the medical
profession
as social security unemployment
compensation
the whole
thrust of the
of modern
social legislation
was in very substantial measure
the consequence
of the great greater thrust of history
and there's a political consequence for
this uh
the war that
i
never at the fort hall formed
digress into politics
so i'm being purely objective
the the war that newt gingrich led
somebody called immunity the other day
the war that newt gingrich and his
colleagues
led against liberal legislation
was really when you examine it a war
against history
and therefore you cannot fully
understand this exercise in insanity
unless you are
conscious
of the larger movement of history
and therefore
along with the enjoyment of history
you derive from history also the
enjoyment
of the embarrassment
of those freshmen republicans
arthur
well i agree with everything everyone
has said so far
i agree with ken that one of the
beauties delights of study of history is
history's great fun
anyone with any intellectual curiosity
must be
attracted by the idea of discovering how
people lived in the past
how a
structure like the one we are in tonight
and what this must have been like at the
time of the american revolution
and so on time travel is one of the
favorite
devices of
of
science fiction well time travel in a
way is what history is all about
but i also
agree with alan
that
history does have certain secondary
benefits
in a way
i suppose
history is to the nation what memory is
to the in individual
individual
deprived of memory becomes disoriented
doesn't know where he's been or where
he's going
in the same way
a nation
that denies or is ignorant of its own
history
is becomes at the mercy
of the present
the mercy of urgencies which
lead every generation feels itself
peculiarly
persecuted by history
singled out for woes that are
much worse than
any previous generation has had i
remember in the 60s
hearing the
self-pity of young people in the 60s who
felt that they were
acutely the subject of the
persecution of history
and i thought of my own generation which
got out of college during
a depression
with
up to 20 of the labor force
seeking jobs is not finding them
which in a few years found themselves
in the greatest war in human history
and uh
one if one has knowledge of the past one
is able to put the
um
crises of the present in better
perspective
at the time
1948 uh when the soviet union uh put a
blob tried to stop
passage into berlin
there's great concern
george c marshall
who was the head of the
allied forces
in the west in the city in the second
world war was then secretary of state
and they had a rather tense meeting of
the
marshall and the various
undersecretaries and assistant
secretaries
and one of them said the
very pessimistic reports were brought
out of the dangers in the berlin crisis
people
thought of the mobile
wondered mobilization of forces and so
on
and finally some assistant secretary
said mr to george marshall said general
marshall
uh i'm amazed here we are possibly on
the brink of the third world war
you know
facing a crisis like this how can you be
so calm
the general mouse replied i've seen
worse
the fact that the
history has been a record of vicissitude
in crisis
provides a certain
sense of perspective on the irritations
of the of the present
i would add that though ignorance of
history
in america and in the u.s today
uh according to reliable reports is
deplorable
i heard the other day of a man who was
lecturing in the second world war and a
student came up to him afterwards and
said
oh i said you were talking about the
second world war what was the first
world war
and there are those in the who cannot
locate
cannot locate the chronologically when
the civil war took place and so on
the recent fourth of july in new york
the daily news
sent a
reporter out to times square
to ask people why the 4th of july was
being celebrated
they asked 40 people only five knew
most of them were foreign tourists
someone said oh i think that's when
asked why we were celebrating the fourth
of july
and one person said oh i think it's
because that was the end of the civil
war
another said oh wasn't that the boston
tea party
a little closer anyway
there is also a danger which we
sometimes historians sometimes ignore
of knowing too much history
of being obsessed with history to such a
degree
that history dictates
that the
causes people to uh relive the
horrors and grudges and feuds and so on
of the past
cases perhaps in the balkans today
for the battle of kosovo in the 14th
century still rankles in the hearts
of
many people the balkans it's true in
ireland
today true in the middle east today for
a long time it was true in the american
south
where the civil war caused the abiding
bitterness toward
the damn yankees from the north
so i think the knowledge of history is
essential but when the
obsession with the grievances of the
past
can cause great trouble
in in the present
but knowledge of history
apart from the inherent
pleasure and fascination
of intellectual inquiry into the past
knowledge history does
i think create a certain perspective
about the problems of the present
it gives
those who read history
a certain diagnostic skill
to know how seriously
they should take
what the newspapers
present
as some
apocalyptic
challenge
in other words
history makes us it seems to me
much more knowledge of history makes us
much more civilized people
than we would be otherwise
well then let me put a question to
either of the three of you
again i agree
with everything that's been said but
does it matter that
now
so much history is being processed into
document uh docudrama on television or
made into
disneyland versions of the civil war or
is is there because there's a great deal
of interest in in history i think on on
television i mean there's a history
channel there is the success of the ken
burns films
and
if if that is burglarized or
softened into
some sort of hallmark card version of
american history does is that
a danger does that matter is it
something to be concerned about
if i thought the television documents
were believed by the people who saw them
it would be a danger
but fortunately there are so many of
them most of them are so awkward and
unconvincing
and most of them and they present a
confusing picture
of the past that i i don't think i think
people take them with a grain of salt
there are movies that can be more
harmful i think
the oliver stone movie jfk
and with his uh
implication her
his argument uh that
president kennedy was murdered by a high
government conspiracy
including the his successor as president
of the united states
top people in the pentagon the cia and
so on that seemed to me
because of the
skill with which it was presented the
simulation
of what appeared to be newsreel shots
and so on
but that seemed to be a
harmful
kind of thing if anyone believed it and
i feared that some did
on the other hand it's a free country
and
just as oliver stone is free to make
movies so historians are free to
criticize them
and on the whole i think
the disney theme parks so long as they
don't spoil civil war battlefields
might lead people on to a more
uh serious and critical sense of the
past
i wonder about that i'm not a defender
of television uh
television documentaries for a moment
but arthur the first uh
motion picture i think i ever saw was
birth of a nation
have we ever had anything recently on
television as historically
corrupt as that was
i don't see television enough to be
able to answer that with confidence
but i'm sure that television has done
worse than the birth of the nation
i i think the popularization of history
is both a good and a bad thing there's
some very good
historical popularization
many of the serious historical
documentaries of the last decade
uh ken burns are perhaps the most
the best known but there are many others
on public television and elsewhere
are really very good history
they're just as an example there's a
really
superb
portrait of theodore roosevelt airing on
public television this weekend
and i think uh that brings history uh to
more people than the academy uh
ever reaches and
uh and i think that's a of great value
to us
i i'm not terribly concerned about the
the sort of cheap uh and romanticized
versions of history that appear in films
and on television i i don't like them
but i i don't think uh they do great
harm uh i i can think of uh professional
works of scholarship that are just as
corrupt and distorting
as as the worst things on on the disney
channel
but
i i do think
that the
pervasiveness of history in popular
culture is uh
among other things a
a sign of the failure of the historical
profession uh to make its own work
accessible
to people outside it i mean historians
have almost entirely abdicated their
role as
uh contributors to popular discourse uh
and there are certain exceptions uh and
two of them are sitting to my right but
um uh on the whole i think the
historical profession writes for itself
and
uh
has
ceased to play uh any important role in
in the way citizens understand their
history except to the degree that
historians perhaps write textbooks for
uh students and that i think is a loss
both for the society and for the
profession uh and it has left a vacuum
into which all these other uh
uh other institutions and individuals
some of them good some of them not uh
have moved
i might just add that my critical
remarks are addressed to docudramas on
television not to the documentaries and
i agree with alan brinkley that there
have been some very fine
documentaries the documentaries are
more or less
based on history docudramas are based on
fantasy
but i i had to write a document
documentary once arthur and it was a
six-part series
on the history of american foreign
policy in the 20th century
and it's a very difficult form because
you have so few words and i had to
they gave me one set of photographs and
another set of photographs and i had
exactly a minute and 40 seconds to get
from one of those photographs to the
other one and explain the origins of
world war ii
and the
the uh
so that when you actually get down to
writing one of those scripts like maybe
you've done that but it it uh it becomes
of necessity
extremely simplified and uh
again it's
you're under the constant siege of the
of the present i mean we're besieged
with images all the time and by
on television or in the print media
and it's hard to ward them off and get
the
sense of time past and time future
i think i've i mean i saw an editorial a
headline this morning in the times the
lead headline in the new york times this
morning is clinton says talk failed to
resolve issues in mideast
so i mean he had netanyahu and arafat
there for two days and
one lunch and the argument has been
going on for 3000 years and you know it
somehow didn't get resolved yesterday
over lunch at the uh
but it's that sort of an attitude that
is uh you know i think
maybe more pervasive than
than you do
the uh
but let me ask another question what is
the use of history to um
to make the future in other words what
else do we have to build or make or
imagine the future unless it is the past
is that not another
uh
way of
well history never repeats itself in any
accurate ways
the old joke used to go his
history doesn't repeat itself historians
only repeat each other
there are limits to the value of
historical analogy
as mark twain
once said
a cat who jumps on a hot stove will
never jump on a hot stove again the
trouble is he won't never jump on a cold
stove either
nonetheless
there are certain
broad tendencies
visible in the present
which will
project themselves into the future
uh
i mean this
seems to me today that we are going
through a shift
uh as profound as the industrial
revolution two centuries ago
that was a shift from a farm base to a
factory-based economy we're now going
through a shift from a factory base to a
computer-based economy
all this is going to have implications
it will not be precisely
comparable in any sense to the
what happened uh two centuries ago with
the industrial revolution
but the sense of of this kind of change
the impact on
families the impact on urbanization
uh the impact on so many things
all this
uh
does give a certain value
i think
historians are now guarantee
being a phd in history is no guarantee
of
supernatural wisdom and public affairs
after all newt gingrich has a phd in
history
but i see i still think people with a
knowledge of the past
have a better chance to be able to
anticipate some of the problems and
benefits of the future
i'd be much stronger than that arthur
uh
i think
it's been my experience quite seriously
that there is very little in economics
that one can understand without some
knowledge of the history of economic
life
and the history of economists and their
interpretation of it
and there's a lot of that
which informs
the
the present
one
one example
uh going back to
the tulip mania
the 17th century and
uh
in
holland and the
of
john law
in france at the beginning of the 18th
century um
the south sea bubble
and the long period of uh
episodes uh
uh of a speculative sort
in uh the last century
on down for example to 1929
1987
unless one has
examined that
whole run of history one cannot
understand one of the basic features of
modern financial life
which is the commitment to recurrent
insanity
which is extremely important
and maybe somewhat relevant to the
what we see at the present time
a world in which we have far more money
searching for profits in the stock
market
far more money
in mutual funds
than there is intelligence to handle it
uh
and therefore
and that
it only becomes evident pressingly
evident
when one has gone over that history
so while i'm not a professional
historian it's my pride this evening to
be much more strongly committed to
history than you are
i cannot say the same about economics
there was an and for many years at the
kennedy school at harvard and i assume
still is a course
uh called the uses of history uh and it
was taught when i was at harvard by
ernest may and richard neustadt
uh and the premise of that course
was that there are ways to use history
as a practical social science tool
that history could be studied in the by
the case method in the same way that law
and business were studied
and that out of it policy makers could
learn
ways in which to deal with social
problems and public issues
that would be practically useful to them
and i have no doubt that
there are times in which history does
have practical utility in providing
answers to social political and economic
problems i i think professor gabriel is
absolutely right that
in economics in particular uh the
historical behavior of an economy
uh
is
an invaluable if not necessarily always
wisely understood guide to the future
performance of economies
on the other hand i think
there are
many perhaps perhaps most of the
important issues before us for which
history offers no concrete and practical
guide to the future
uh but it does do something else what
would be an example
uh
how to solve uh the problem of race in
america it seems to me is is a
question that our history does not
provide us uh an answer to
um
how to deal with the problems of
urban poverty is not i think an issue
that history gives us a
reliable guide
to understanding both of those
uh
and you know there are many other
problems all over the world for which
history provides no real guide but what
history does do i think uh is provide
something of a caution
uh
gibbon may have been right at least in
part that history is a chronicle of
failure and folly
uh but it's important i think for those
who attempt uh to deal with great
problems and to wield great power
uh to do so with some humility uh and
some sense
uh
that
answers uh
concocted in a few days or months or
even years in policy meetings
might not work
and that's something i think if nothing
else that history teaches us
let me ask you a little question there
alan
the
these two enormous problems race and
particularly the problems of the poor in
the great cities
i agree with you that there's nothing
one can draw on in history
for a solution to those problems
but isn't that partly because there's
not much history
you mean there's not much that much time
has elapsed is that what would you mean
yeah
well there may be not much history uh to
the particular problems of modern any
inner city uh
neighborhoods uh but there is a very
long history of course to the problem of
poverty
and inequality just as there's a very
long history to the problem of racial
injustice and the somewhat shorter but
but not inconsiderable history
of efforts to solve the problems of
racial injustice
i i would not say that history offers
nothing uh to efforts to deal with those
problems but it doesn't offer an answer
um it offers a chronicle of
past efforts that have failed uh
and some that have at least marginally
succeeded
but it also offers i think as i say a
lesson in humility uh how difficult a
lesson in how difficult it is to deal
with the great problems of our time or
any time
uh
and a lesson in the the necessity of of
looking skeptically even at our own most
passionately held beliefs
well in that context let me ask another
question which is
whether history
is more central to the notion of the
american democracy than it might be
in a different society for example
for many years for centuries the world
whether it was rome or
greece or
france under louis xiv was perfectly
happy to accept poverty
slavery and
various forms of inequality whereas the
american premise
tries to
carry forward the adventure of both
equality and liberty which makes us our
story it seems to me
is a very exciting and unique story and
is there any sense in which
the study and knowledge of the of
american history therefore becomes
more important to us
as americans than it might to
were we
british or french or
russian well we
must be sad though so we tolerated
slavery for example much longer than
britain france and the countries of
western europe did
i think the
i think all countries
at least since the emergence of the
nation state
have had a certain commitment to the
beauties and glories of their own
history
we have it perhaps to a special extent
because in the sense we
are a nation whose roots do not go back
into the medieval past we are a nation
which is both settled and settled
diversely so that history
had a kind of special function of
binding people together of transforming
them transforming newcomers into
americans
and that gave it perhaps a special
cogency
the
in the sense
that we could talk without
laughing of a committee on un-american
activities
where the notion of a committee on
unfrench activities or on english
activities or on danish activities would
seem
improbable
so i think that the the history has had
as i say
a
role in giving
our sense of national identity
a
coherence and a depth which countries
which are much more based on
on
ethnic
homogeneity
uh might have
but i think that the the
glorification of the past is something
which to which all peoples
are given
given to makes them feel more important
to give them a sense of belonging to
something i don't think we're notably
worse in that respect
i didn't mean it as a criticism i i
meant it as what was it more fundamental
to us to work out the thread of the
american narrative than it might be
to some other i mean
a
i might say as a personal note
what you said about a
on american activities committee
strongly supports my
uh
experience that history is something to
be enjoyed
some 10 20 years ago
through the
the
freedom of information act
i got my fbi file
which was about that thick
every time i'd been up for some public
post or other
there was an investigation
and i must tell you arthur that history
was the most enjoyable
thing read
and it was it was full of gems
one only that i cite
when i was up for some post in
washington
early in the
back in the new deal years
the fbi
or just after
the fbi went to the chairman of the
department of economics at harvard whose
name will be on i will not use
to ask him about my views
and he said
political views and he said
galbraith he's very radical
but nothing like franklin d roosevelt
that was
well that was one of the more enjoyable
experiences of my life
arthur did you enjoy reading your files
very pardon i was asking arthur whether
he'd enjoyed reading his fbi file i
particularly enjoyed one comment
written in the inimitable
handwriting of j edgar hoover himself
where some of one of his subordinates
had
had
sent to him this was in the early 1950s
a clipping
reporting that i had said something
critical about the fbi
j edgar hoover
wrote and scrawled on the margins of
this report i always thought he wrote
that schleizinger was a stinker
that's history alan falling into that
sorry another comment i want to pursue
this that i particularly enjoyed was
a request
by
a distinguished
uh senator from indiana
who established my loyalty after i had
made some testimony that had brought
down the stock market
and there was an enormous investigation
lasted days
and it came up with the
most disappointing conclusion
that that poor senator could ever had
it said
galbraith is
arrogant but evidently not disloyal
allen is too young to have
probably have a file
if i do i'm sure it's much thinner and
much less interesting than yours
well we
i now think we will turn as is the
custom at the ford
hall forum to turn the
microphone over to the members of the
audience and
ask for questions
and
when you ask the question address it to
whichever member of the panel you wish
to address it to
i hope you're not doing that just to
avoid more personal comments not at all
you can answer all the questions with
personal comment kevin all right
if it's okay all three panelists touched
on it slightly so it's to all three of
them mainly professor brinkley i think
it's easier if you direct it to one of
the okay professor brinkley in
the october issue of the atlantic
monthly conor cruz o'brien argues that
jefferson should be removed from the
pantheon of american statesmen primarily
because
he his
notes on the state of virginia
seriously
bring into question the legitimacy of
the declaration of independence the
phrase all men are queer are created
equal
would you
would you
what is your take on removing jefferson
from the pantheon of american statesmen
i think
argentina can answer that question as
well i mean well i'd like to hear from
you i want to know from the professor
because first all right
history instruction
uh what would you say to your students
at columbia
uh in terms of removing jefferson from
history i did read uh o'brien's article
and in fact i
heard him speak on this subject
one evening a year or so ago
at a dinner
and
much of what he says about jefferson is
certainly true
i think he
does not
he compares jefferson uh first of all to
the standards of our own time rather
than the standards of his
and he also compares jefferson to
a very small group of people who were
his contemporaries
whose relationship to slavery was
different from his own uh the most
frequent comparison he makes is to
george washington who freed his slaves
upon his death and jefferson did not
except for a few of them whom o'brien at
least believes were his children
uh
i don't think jefferson's views on
slavery deserve
uh are are the the basis for his
position in the pantheon of our national
heroes and and they certainly should
should cause us to look at him with some
greater skepticism than perhaps we have
uh i certainly disagree with o'brien
that we should remove jefferson from the
pedestal because he was too radical
and
although
jefferson certainly defended aspects of
the french revolution that
now seemed to us indefensible
uh
it does seem to me that one of the part
of the greatness of jefferson
uh was his understanding of change in
history and the understanding of the
power of change and the importance of
change
um
i think any historical figure can be
knocked off his pedestal if we look too
carefully uh at what he or or she
uh believed on some issues
uh and we should look carefully at that
but we should also recall the things uh
that they did that deserve our respect
uh and jefferson did many so i
um
i i think o'brien's article is a is a
very elegant and intelligent screed but
uh not
a
definitive or persuasive assessment of
jefferson's place in history what
offended me about the o'brien article
was the sense he gave that he was some
great iconoclast
revealing facts that had been suppressed
for for generations
in fact there's nothing in the article
that hasn't been well known he further
fell for this cliche invented by
sociologists about the american civic
religion
which
i thought it was
a i'm no great admirer of jefferson i
think in many respects hamilton
had a much stronger sense about
both the direction of the economy and
the role of government than jefferson
had and as leonard levy and others have
pointed out jefferson in while he was in
theory a great champion of say freedom
of the press
in practice was
proposed to the governor of pennsylvania
on one occasion the federalist papers
should be prosecuted under the law of
seditious libel so as i say i'm no
worshiper of jefferson
but i thought this was a
third-rate piece by a man who doesn't
know much of american history who's well
known for his egotism
yeah all right
next question
hi since since uh you were speaking
about your fbi files and since i gather
the topic tonight has something to do
with democracy
this is a very interesting topic for me
i wonder if any of you gentlemen would
care to comment
on whether or not you are satisfied with
the degree of control that we as a
society
have over agencies like the fbi
and whether or not you think in a in a
genuine democracy
there ought to be entities like the fbi
engaged in
uh investigations of citizens who
have
not aren't being investigated for any
criminal uh possible criminal matter but
investigations which include as
professor galbraith mentioned
one's political beliefs
even and i would i would i would ask
even is it appropriate even in cases
where people are
interested in perhaps a job in the white
house is it appropriate to have the fbi
scrutinizing people simply because uh a
president would like to appoint them to
a position in the white house
um
thank you
ken did you get that whole question the
question is uh is there
i think the
uh
whole episode of the loyalty program
for which we must hold harry truman
whom i otherwise admire somewhat
responsible
was one of the
great aberrations
of the
post-war years
and that uh
this caused
a great deal of sorrow
great deal of uh unhappiness
a great deal of damage to the morale of
our public service
and was
otherwise
inappropriate in a democracy it
shouldn't have been done and it
enormously exaggerated the role of the
conspiracy
in opposition
to
effective
administration
in the in the american public interest
so i think there's no
there's no real defense for it
and
i would
have no hesitation in condemning it
and
that
it was headed
by
uh
an
aged
uh
mentally
uh mellowed
uh inadequate old character like j edgar
hoover
uh
adds to one sense of
[Music]
repugnance
uh i don't want to overstate this uh
but uh
but
the the question ken is is it getting
worse i mean has it become more invasive
the government has the how's the
government
oh no we've moved on from that a lot
uh and we're we're much more sensible
now than we were in the in the period of
the early 40s i don't think this
i don't think the
early 50s i don't think there's any
question about that
if either of my colleagues want to say a
word for j edgar hoover why of course i
i certainly don't want to say a word for
j grew hoover i'm not quite as
sanguine as you are about the present
state
of the fbi and other
investigatory uh agencies i i think
the abuses at least as far as we know
are
certainly less than they were at at
their worst in the the 50s in fact
during much of jail edgar hoover's uh
tenure although
who's to say what what is happening
without her knowledge
um but i i don't think uh that although
even though we do have much more public
oversight of these agencies than we once
did i i don't think we yet have enough
and i'm not sure
how one establishes the kind of public
oversight that one would need to prevent
violations of civil liberties and at the
same time preserve institutions whose
purpose
uh requires a certain level of secrecy
as for your question about fbi
investigations of of people nominated
for public office
i think it is a truly lamentable feature
of our public life that our cynicism
about leaders is such
um that the public in effect demands
uh these kinds of investigations of
anyone appointed to any office
before it becomes politically possible
for them to win
confirmation
and
i'm not sure it's the fault of the fbi
that they're engaged in these
investigations but i i do think in a
healthier democracy uh we would have
some less invasive way of vetting our
public officials
next question thank you
in 1990 yeah further point
we're here in boston
and
i think it's well known
i hope it's well known that
this is a community that
rendered strong support
and deep affection for john f kennedy
which i certainly did
he was a i was
sought to be a loyal friend
i love
kennedy but uh there could have been no
error
of jfk
so great
as on the day after his election or
within the week or so
appointing jade
appointment of j edgar hoover
and alan dulles
uh two of the
most effective figures
in modern public administration
we always had a wonderful expression
[Applause]
we always had a
very accurate expression of the two
dulles brothers dull duller and dullest
uh in 1992 there was a massive
reevaluation of columbus and the spanish
conquest
and
in 2020
there will be uh
the celebration of the arrival of the
mayflower
given
that we know the the spanish as
conquistadors
and not
our
pilgrim forefathers as as such
however
at above that indian's head
and above that clock you have the
disembodied arm with the sword in it
that's the arm of yahweh which
symbolizes the
god given right to conquest i wonder if
you could uh
foresee any uh such massive reevaluation
in 2020
i think that if columbus had known what
was going to be said about him
500 years after his arrival in this
continent he would never have bothered
to discover america
i think there's a lot of
romanticism about the idyllic quality of
life in america allegedly destroyed by
the coming of the white man
we now know of course that the indians
fought each other that they did not
practice
in every case
the best environmental practices
the many people argue contend that the
what happened to in central america to
the great mayan
society it was due to overplowing of
land and other
bad environmental practices the aztecs
used to
demand
a tribute of maidens
each year from
tribes under their domination whom they
then sacrifice and bloody ceremony the
reason why cortez and his small band was
over able to overthrow moctezuma
was because of the support he had
from the other tribes who had been
tyrannized by the aztecs and who
regarded courts
and
so
i think these were violent times they
were violent on the side of the
invader and they were violent in the
sight of the people who were there
and i think you have to
deal with it as something that's
happened
i don't know whether you are suggesting
that the
we should know that the white people
should never come to america or what but
i'm just saying that right now we have
uh in salem uh a fixation on which is it
plymouth plantation uh we have a
fixation on something that's entirely
pacific
um
we have disney squanto
uh i don't think there has been a real
full take on complex take on the
material
well we've got 20 years to work it out
right at least okay thank you then i
suspect the the 2020 anniversary will
not be as
uh
controversial as the uh
1992 just because the
the mayflower did not
wreak the kind of havoc uh at least
immediately that columbus did but i i i
think it's a perfectly legitimate part
of historical inquiry to to understand
not just what we've traditionally
understood about the achievements of
english and other european settlers in
america but also the
uh
the catastrophic results of that
settlement on other peoples
i don't think
either should entirely overshadow the
other but i think they're both a part of
history
and a legitimate part
hi this is for any one of you um
when you look today at how
campaigns are structured and the kind of
rhetoric that goes back and forth does
it sadden you a little bit as historians
is it sad in you that
historians of today documenting
political
life in the 80s and 90s just don't have
the same kind of robust material that
you gentlemen had to work with when
actually when you were working for the
kennedys
in other words does it sadden you in a
way that we've gone from ask not what
your country can do for you to just
don't do it
arthur you written on this subject what
i don't think there was ever a golden
age of american politics
really you really believe that from the
very beginning
political campaigns
dealt in
not only in partisanship but in
reckless accusation counter charges and
counter charges
indeed for the press for example in the
19th century was far more irresponsible
and reckless
than it is today
on the other hand there was
uh
while there were in other words scarily
has been
a constant
characteristic
of american political warfare
on the other hand there was a kind of
counter weight
of
serious
discussion of issues
consider for example the federalist
papers
federalist papers were written by
hamilton and madison with some help from
john jay they were published two or
three times a week
in the new york newspaper they were
printed and reprinted up and down the
whole
through
the newly independent states
they were brought out in book form and
sold an extraordinary number of copies
now
when you compare the federalist paper
with a pap that exists
in the op-ed page of the new york times
to which we were all three of us i fear
contributors
and uh you have a sense of something in
decline no one could get
any
anything of much length of argument
today in the into the into the new york
times unless of course you're the una
bomber
i do think that the that what has
obliterated you in the 19th century
uh the great orators would come in the
first part of the century clay or
webster later people like brian or james
g blaine
theodore roosevelt woodrow wilson people
would drive for miles around to to hear
them they feel cheated if the speech
lasted for less than two hours and you
got in these speeches or rather
considered discussion of issues
uh on a certain intellectual plane
modern communications has
caused a great
change in the attention span of
americans radio came along
and radio
reduced the length of political speeches
first to an hour then to half an hour
television came reduced them to 15
minutes and now they're too much of a 15
seconds of sound bites
and i think that this has
has meant that the offsetting tradition
that is a tradition of serious discourse
which in a way
balanced the traditional scality and
invective of american politics that has
been much enfeebled
by the changes in the system of
communications thank you
yeah
many years ago george steiner wrote an
essay called the archives of eden where
he said that
one of the great paradoxes about the
united states is at the one hand we have
some of the greatest libraries and
archives we put enormous amount of
resources into preserving the past
but we are also in a sense the united
states of amnesia we don't really
care that much about the past at another
level
what i wanted to ask about
american conservatism has led a major
attack on things like the national
endowment for the humanities and i just
got this article this week that says
books 230 000
disintegrating newspaper pages and 100
of archaeological ethnographic and
historical importance will not be
preserved this year because of the
massive cutbacks in the budget and i i
wanted
you you'd maybe comment on on the
[Music]
declining state of preservation in
history and how the american right
thinks about the past because i think
that's something that american
conservatives have often prided
themselves on is this
um
celebration of the past and saving the
past so maybe you could have some
reflections on that and maybe what we
could do to preserve some of these
things that are
literally turning into sawdust
thank you
it's a curious paradox the party that is
claiming to offer us a bridge to the
past is also the party that seems to
have so little interest
in doing anything to preserve the
records of our past as you've suggested
and the
i mean
this is obviously an issue of great
sensitivity to historians but i i think
it should also be some concern to others
uh the the the defunding both by the
government and by private sector
organizations
of uh efforts to preserve the historical
record um
is uh
i i think for scholars at least one of
the great disasters
uh of of recent times uh there are other
worst disasters of course for society at
large but but this is this is not
unimportant
uh
i don't think it's because americans
care less about their past than other
peoples do i think it's partly because
americans are so
susceptible at the moment as they have
often been in our history to
the myth that government can do nothing
right and therefore nothing government
does should be funded
but whatever the reason
there is a
terrible tragedy in progress in many of
the nation's libraries and archives and
historical societies and others
where our historical record is simply
disintegrating into dust
with no money to do anything about it
that's the work of newt gingrich
i assume
i wish it were just newt gingrich
a lot of people have been complicit in
this for a long time yes i have a
comment and then an unrelated question
so they won't come together
i would like to challenge your
i think the overall panel assertion that
the answers to
race prejudice and poverty are not found
in history
if
we
the collective we are not finding those
answers i would assume you're referring
to the american citizens
and i would assume you're including both
the oppressor and the oppressed and in
my experience
african-american teachers lawyers
historians are finding answers
to race prejudice and poverty in our
history if only by the way it's been
told
that's the comment the question
um
when i was living in continental europe
i
recognized an unmatchable
spontaneous passion for history in my
peers and the only place i found it
matched in the united states is in new
york city immigrant cab drivers
the
only
element i could find
different in my the culture of my peers
and the culture of
british youth
french youth italian youth is our lack
of respect for oral history
that our peers tend not to ask the elder
generations what our history is and i'm
wondering if you have any other
possible reasons why i found this
spontaneous passion outside of my
country but not here
the question is
when the young lady was in europe she
came across an excited passionate
interest in history on the part of young
italians young frenchmen young
englishmen
and why is there not an equivalent
excitement
in the united states among her peers
about
history is that fair
yeah that's fair that was that's the
question
why are we as americans young americans
not as
passionately consumed with with the
historical
past as
i'll add i originally
let me challenge slightly the
assumption
on a limited focus at least
i've
over my life
spent much of my time at two
universities
both
uh in the city of cambridge i've been
at harvard
most of my life
i've been
a member of the faculty a fellow of
trinity college in cambridge england
for all so much of my life
i have known both harvard undergraduates
and cambridge undergraduates
and you know i don't want to seem to be
pretentious
but
i would greatly prefer the average
harvard undergraduate
in his or her commitment to
intellectual life in general
in history in particular
to the more frivolous attitudes of
english undergraduates
so
from my limited experience
i'm slightly at odds with your basic
proposition
all right i i i perhaps have not spent
as much time in europe as you have but
i've i've spent a good deal of time
there and i i don't think i have
detected
uh a notably greater passion in everyday
life for history than than one finds
here
certainly european societies
first of all they have more history than
we do to preserve and and the
preservation of that history is uh in
many parts of europe a much higher
priority than it seems to be in our
nation with our
at least until recently sort of heedless
willingness to destroy whatever stands
in the way of the newest development
um
but
as an intellectual proposition i i'm
just
i don't have any evidence of my own that
would support your observation it's not
to say you're wrong but i i can't
i i i haven't i haven't sensed the same
thing
let me say for the record since uh
this goes to a wide audience
that
i have every respect for cambridge
undergraduates too
and i
i don't want this i don't want to seem
to be at odds with students there
thank you and i'm going over next winter
to give some lectures which will go far
to correct the whole situation
okay uh yeah i'd like the panel to uh
address the question of the impact of
the historical profession on uh not the
the
quality but really the substance of
public discourse it's been addressed
sort of glancingly along the way so i'd
like to begin with some words of faint
praise i want to say the american
historical
profession has certainly done a much
better job of that than you know their
colleagues in japan where you know
textbooks still describe the invasion of
china as the advance into china and
where the nanking massacre apparently
didn't exist
but
when i look around at issues that have
become that have become controversial in
the public discourse
it seems to me that disciplines other
than the historical profession have done
a much better job
of speaking with a corporate voice and
saying you know these things are
nonsense and these things we can
actually tell you about uh when the bell
curve came out uh and caused a lot of
controversy the one on the
inheritability of iq and what this
allegedly tells us
i think the top 60 psychometricians came
out with a joint statement which was
published in the wall street journal you
know 16 points what we do
and what we don't know about
intelligence what it is the heritability
whenever a politician comes out with a
new uh
you know sweeping fiscal policy you can
pretty much count on getting some kind
of statement in the elite media by you
know n dozen economists of whom you know
one dozen will be nobel winners saying
you know is this nonsense or is this not
um
in contrast you know i don't see
anything coming out of the historical
profession like that uh during the enola
gay controversy in the smithsonian uh
when you know gingrich is running around
saying you know no government program
has ever worked so just shut it down
what the hell
um
even during the the latest welfare or
immigration bills i haven't seen
any sort of consensus statements by a
panel of historians
um saying you know this is what we know
this is what we don't know this is the
consensus
you know this this really should be sort
of the framework for public discourse
and i guess i'm asking you know
from your point of view why do you think
that is and you know what could be done
within the historical profession to try
to redress what i as a as a political
scientist uh candidate myself see is a
fairly grievous shortcoming
the question is
why
is there no consensus of historians
when a controversial
subject
comes up in the political discourse why
do
why can't we have a
consensus view in the way we might get
from
mathematicians or
uh geologists as to whether
this subject is true or false no i'm not
not saying consensus i'm saying at least
you know a statement by
a group of all right people within the
consensus what we do know and what we
don't but an official statement yeah
history is history is not an exact
science
history
the
does not even aspire to the kind of
objectivity that science
until
at least epistemologically
unsophisticated science thought it was
able to acquire attain
history as the great duchess star and
peter hale said it was an argument
without end
and it's very valuable that it should be
so
i think any official or consensus or
orthodoxy about the past
is
in the main a bad situation
when i think of the way american history
has been revised in my own lifetime
as a consequence of two great
revolutions
the women's rights revolution
and the racial justice revolution
and which has forced us from the forced
historians to look back into the past
and see things that were always there
but was they were not interested in
before
and therefore they've revised rewritten
american history oscar wilde once said
the one duty we owe to history is to
rewrite it
and i would
i would
be very unhappy if the historians
ever became concerned
if there was such a thing as definitive
history anyone who talks about a
definitive history or definitive
biography doesn't understand
in my judgment the historical enterprise
well i wouldn't just take it a step
further arthur
in the past when we have reached
uh
something like a consensus
on the need to
prohibit the sale of alcohol for example
or on the need are on the basic
proposition that women's place was in
the
was in the home
one could cite many other examples of
whether there has been something
approaching a consensus
we have almost invariably found it
disastrous
abolition of slavery is one of them but
on the whole
what kenneth galbraith said is that
is right there's great danger i mean
there are a few issues like slavery and
torture which tr which which so deeply
offend
any any civilized conception of human
rights that there can be unanimity on
the part of historians but anything less
than that unanimity is to be regarded
with suspicion
if i understood the question i i think
it was slightly different from what
we've been talking about
which is why
is it not more frequently the case that
socially or politically committed
historians don't use what they know to
try to influence public discourse in the
way that economists and political
scientists and psychologists and others
often try to do
i think what arthur said is partly an
explanation for that that history uh
doesn't have a sense of itself and maybe
more importantly is not regarded by
others
as having
scientific legitimacy in the way that
economists are at least thought to have
um
and no no offense
uh
and it's very that point too far i won't
uh
but but i i think
part of the reason that there aren't
more full-page ads in the new york times
signed by 60 historians talking about
this or that issue is that
basically there's no market for our
views uh in the same way
uh that there is for economists but i i
i do
there are however historians who do
attempt to play a role in public
discourse and to do attempt to
influence public debate and i think
that's a legitimate role and i've tried
occasionally to play it myself uh
but i i don't think that the historical
profession as a whole
either thinks of itself as or is thought
by others as
having the kind of scientific legitimacy
that makes it possible for other
professions to weigh in so effectively
on some of these issues but isn't that
to some extent
uh on a virtue of history
that
it attempts to take into consideration
a much larger number
of control of variables with a
controlling role or an important role
that history cannot be
narrowly on economics it cannot be
narrowly on sociology it cannot be
narrowly on science
it has to
spread itself
over a large much larger number
of controlling fact forces
and having
that necessity
it is much larger much less likely to
come up
with a
something that can be a
committed belief well i think that's
right history is a much more integrative
discipline than almost any others that
we could think of and it draws from
almost every other discipline in some
way and and it produces a much wider
range of approaches and results there's
no canon in history there's no single
methodology or theory or even any you
know
any group of methodologies and theories
that one could uh list in a
in an evening uh that would encompass
the the different things that historians
do on the other hand
that doesn't seem to me to be a reason
that historians should play no role
in in public life and in public
discourse
i think they should play a role i think
that role will necessarily be different
from the role that economists and
scientists and other and others play
but but there is still a role for
historians i don't think very many of us
play it effectively enough
thank you that was my question
i'm going to ask the other people
waiting to ask questions to be as brief
as possible because we only have about
six minutes left so okay i'll try to um
well this is your response to um this is
a follow-up question actually from the
previous ladies question it's a response
to john kenneth gail galbraith saying
that's very little history about issues
such as race relations and poverty
and i was wondering um do you think this
is because history which according to
alan brinkley is can be used as an
instrument of power
is recorded and inter interpreted by
members of the dominant power structure
who are more interested in high politics
and as such and if so do you think that
this is a serious liability of the
historical profession is it being
addressed and is it also giving us a
narrow outlook on the past
that's an enormous question which i
couldn't even begin to know how to
repeat that one
the question is is
the u is history being used for
political purposes is that your question
my question is um
is it that yeah and also that the people
the historians themselves who are
interpreters of this history they're the
ones who are who are part of the
dominant power structure and that's why
there's very little history on race
relations power poverty etc
are historians agents of imperial power
is that the question kind of
the question is are you as an historian
the agent of imperial power
[Music]
well
i'm simplifying in the interests of time
i mean there's a an old cliche uh that
is still used very often which is
history as written by the winners um
and through most of history that has
been true of the history that has
survived and that we know uh the the
victors write the write the history and
disseminate it and and
the vanquished may write history but
nobody reads it nobody knows it
uh i think that is less true today uh in
the united states and through most of
the world where there is a formal
organized historical profession than it
probably has ever been before
uh and there are more voices uh
alive and active and powerful
in at least the academic telling of
history and i think also in the popular
telling of history than has ever been
true in the past does that mean that all
groups are equally powerful certainly
not
uh but there has been a uh
i mean the great revolution in
historical scholarship of the last
generation uh has been precisely a
reaction to the perception uh that
you've just voiced that history has for
too long been dominated by a ruling
class that tells its own story and no
one else's
thank you
throughout the talk uh
often the gentleman on the podium used
the word history is
and that gave me
or us perhaps an impression that history
was a body
of facts now much of that
you have recently
during the last minutes explained that
history is a very complex thing
and
my
view of history and i'm not sure this is
a question whether you would agree it
really falls into two parts for the
historians
try to be brief we're running out of
time it runs into two parts one is to
what facts to look for in each historian
would look at a different body of facts
another
this or that place and then after he has
selected he or she has selected certain
facts then
the interpretation also kicks in which
may differ if you look at a bunch of
facts you may differ among each other do
you have any uh response to that or is
it too vague
a statement in question
the question is first which how do you
decide which facts are important and do
you
then making the interpretation of those
facts is that an entirely separate
uh procedure
all writing of history involves
selection
out of the chaos of the past selection
implies some criterion conscious or
unconscious of interpretation
and so that all history in that sense is
has a large area of subjectivity in it
historians are not on the whole method
as methodologically self-conscious as
perhaps they should be
so they really approach it
less in the mood of a scientist
conducting experiments and the doctor
making a diagnosis
thank you
yes
according to your definition of
democracy or anyone's definition
the united states
probably hasn't been a
democratic state in
the full sense of the word
and
the only past
model of democracy has been
in athens and i was wondering with the
advent of technology do you think that
we could pos is it feasible to change
our representative system into a
direct democracy
i'm afraid i miss that completely
did you get that
i don't what's the last part of it i
mean there was a democracy in athens
did you get announced okay could we be a
director that's right alan's got it yeah
the question was
uh
a statement first that america has never
been a true democracy and that perhaps
the only example of a true democracy was
ancient athens uh and is there some way
uh that we could
uh build into our society some of the
the features that made it possible for a
democracy to exist in in that way in
athens
well we could reinstate slavery which is
a characteristic of athenian democracy
thank you
i'm not an expert on athenian history
but there were certain defects in that
democracy weren't there
slavery
slavery was i was not entirely a benign
institution
i i think though that probably what was
behind that question was is there a way
to introduce into american life some
feature that is more like the kind of
direct democracy that at least those
privileged to exercise it in athens were
able to exercise
and i think probably not very
effectively uh
i don't know how many citizens there
were in athens but they could fit in a
in a theater
um
and uh
we live in a nation of 250 million
people
uh at the local level yes there are
institutions that allow people a kind of
direct access to to power not enough of
them certainly but some at the national
level i think that would be very
difficult and and i don't think
we will ever and
perhaps should never be
a pure democracy um
we could be more democratic than we are
certainly
thank you
this is specifically for mr gailbraith
i was wondering there's a continuation
and a progression of a mixed economy in
the united states and whether or not you
think that that type of government
intervention
has or will ever interfere with true
democracy
question is can we continue with a mixed
economy in the united states and will
that uh interfere
with our practice of democracy
can we continue with a mixed economy in
the united states and at the same time
preserve and maintain the political
democracy oh sure there's no alternative
we have to have a role for government
for the state
we have to have a role for the uh
market system there's no alternative now
and
there's nothing
i see that as being in no way
inconsistent with democracy
the only important thing is that we
decide the role of the
public services on humane grounds
and not by doctrine that we not be
controlled by ideology rather than by
thought
which we are to some extent now
also i would like to see the democracy
somewhat
more pervasive more comprehensive than
it is at the present time
if the people in our central cities the
people who were poor
were voting
we would have far more politicians
out in this election including perhaps
the presidential candidates
making a case for the impoverished
then is now the case knowing that they
won't vote
bob dole and his staff are now engaged
in a bitter debate i read in the new
york times
over whether they
will campaign in california
there's no debate no none whatever
about their
campaigning in roxbury or the south
bronx
thank you
with heroes
i have
the feeling that one of the good things
that history can do for us
is to provide us
with heroes
and
i don't know that there's been much of
an effort in that direction but by
heroes i mean people who in one way or
another can serve as models for us or
provide some kind of guidance for us
and i wondered
whether each of the panelists might
recommend a particular hero to us
and the reason for that recommendation
well arthur has written books about
several of them so
i think the one
great hero
in american political history is i mean
the greatest is of course abraham
lincoln and lincoln was great because of
his capacity both on the practical level
to fight and win
a bitter civil war and at the same time
to hold
himself in a certain sense above the
battle the battle that he had to fight
in the way of pronouncing moral self
righteous moral judgments on situations
i think
lincoln is the most impressive of our
presidents
when you speak of heroic figures in
american history
how would you compare lincoln and
roosevelt
roosevelt was another
great figure
he
saw the country through the worst
depression in our history and the worst
war in our history
but i think he with all his qualities of
leadership and daring
and eloquence he did not have a sense of
the moral intensity that you find in
lincoln
last question
um yes this is a question for professor
brinkley and professor schlesinger
both of you have written extensively on
reform in america and reform movements
and my question is sort of in our
conservative era do you foresee is it
inevitable that we will have another
reform movement in the future
and through your study of history can
you just give some thoughts on the shape
of a reform movement which sort of may
emerge out of this period of
conservatism
uh the question is that you and i have
both written extensively about reform
and in our present era do we foresee
another age of reform do we think it is
inevitable in what form might it take
uh
arthur has written much more extensively
about this issue than i have but i i'll
just say briefly i don't think anything
is inevitable
in history uh
assuming that our nation survives over
some considerable period of time i have
no doubt
that at some point there will be another
period of reform
i have no idea what form it will take i
i don't see very much evidence at this
moment that that that time is near um
but uh although as much as i would like
to to believe otherwise
the great virtue of democracy
is its capacity for self-correction
sometimes it takes a little while
for the combination
of complacency that has to be overcome
and the leadership to overcome that
complacency
but i think the
nature of the problems that we confront
as a society will determine
will force
a movement toward reform as a means of
solution i still have conflict
confidence in the long run democracy's
capacity for self-correction will remedy
some of our worst troubles
thank you
well with that we'd like to close the
proceedings and i'd like to first of all
thank everybody on the panel i thought
it was marvelous listening to
mr
and as the moderator i'd like to have my
own last defense of history which is a
quotation from g k chesterton
who said that the knowledge of the past
and the study of history is the best
defense
against the small and arrogant oligarchy
of those who merely happen to be walking
around
we at the fort hall would like to thank
you ladies and gentlemen for being with
us tonight
and of course to again thank our
panelists for bringing us this
remarkable program
we would like to invite you to join us
for the rest of the fall season
our next program takes place sunday
october 20th at 7 pm
at blackmon auditorium on the
northeastern campus
rebecca walker co-founder of the third
wave direct action corporation will talk
about the fresh concerns of a new
generation of feminists
the next speaker at faneuil hall will be
ralph reed
speaking on october 24th about the role
of religious conservatives in the
context of american electoral politics
thank you and good night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
saturday ceremonial state opening of the
british parliament see her speech in the
house of lords at nine p m eastern and
pacific
now a discussion on presidential
politics and the media
we'll hear from baltimore mayor kurt
schmoke new york times associate editor
robert semple margaret warner a
political correspondent with the
newshour with jim lehrer and harper's
magazine editor and columnist louis
lapham
the yale club of washington dc hosted
yesterday's event at the u.s capitol
[Music]
good evening everyone my name is weylie
chang and i'm president of the yale club
of washington dc i'd like to welcome all
of you to this very special yale club
roundtable event entitled election 96
politics and the media
i'd also like to extend a very special
welcome to our distinguished group of
roundtable participants
whom you will meet shortly
tonight's event is one as you know in a
series of programs and activities
sponsored by the yale club of washington
dc
we have a number of very interesting and
exciting events coming up and for those
of you who are not yet members we
encourage you to join
at the on the foyer outside we have some
club membership forms if you are
interested
we are very pleased to be here tonight
in the russell senate office building
we are here under the kind and generous
auspices of senator john chafee yale
class of 46.
senator chafee has been most
enthusiastic about this event
unfortunately he has been filled by the
flu and has had to cancel all of his his
entire schedule for the weekend
uh we very much appreciate his support
of the yale club and again we are very
happy to be here
i'd also like to thank peter eisemann
peter is tonight's moderator he's the
yale class of 1971
and he is a freelance journalist and
writer
peter conceived of this event and has
been working very hard with
other members of the yale club and our
panelists to ensure that tonight's
discussion will be stimulating and
delightful
peter is also the recipient of the
overseas press club's hemingway award
and i'd like to turn the time now over
to him and he will introduce our
panelists again thank you for being here
[Music]
let's do a little check here
good evening and welcome to a very
historic venue the russell senate caucus
room and a very distinguished panel we
hope
on my right bob sample who is the
associate editor of the new york times
editorial page
and the recipient this year of the
pulitzer prize for editorial writing
especially for his editorials on the
environment lewis lapham
going into his third decade as editor of
harper's magazine and the author of a
very major forthcoming book on yale
asheville green uh our affirmative
non-yale member tonight although a yale
grandson
um
he is one of the elders
with distinction of the publishing
community vice president and senior
editor of alfred a knopf on my left
the man who ranks us by protocol
both by virtue of his service on the
yale corporation
and
as mayor of baltimore kurt schmoke
joining us shortly later will be uh
margaret warner who is doing similar
discussions right now on the uh the
newshour with jim lehrer
we'd like to begin by a reference to our
topic this evening the picking of the
president
some of you may remember
a title of a book
36 years ago the making of the president
at the time it was written by an
extraordinary man named theodore h white
margaret good evening
um
and
no one at that point had focused on the
process as a matter of fact though he
was very successful all publishers
declined
the notion of the book
who would want to know on july 4th
following the election year who had won
well the rest is uh if not history
publishing
and
since then it seems the or that changed
our view of the political process or
certainly the media's coverage of it
we now seem in a world of all process
sometimes posturing and an awful lot of
spin and
on that note to begin with bob sample
who has covered elections
for at least what six presidential ones
um
how bob does this one seem different to
you
well first let me say peter i'm happy to
be here and happy also to see so many
yale people in one room at the capitol
it gives me a great sense of assurance
about the future of our nation
the
which i don't often feel
the
the present campaign and i'll be brief
is
in my view markedly different
from any that i covered as a reporter
i really did stop covering them in 1972
as an active reporter on a day-to-day
basis but i've taken a number of
bustman's holidays
since then including this year
and
if peter you mean by
uh process
and obsession with poles and obsession
with image
uh an obsession with spin and obsession
with sound bites
uh as opposed to what we used to know as
substance that is to say
a vigorous and muscular discussion of
issues
then
this in this campaign we've almost
reached some kind of apotheosis
of um
a process
or depending
a process over over substance
uh the cam i grew up in
or kind of came of age okay became aware
of politics in the 1950s which dates me
but
unless i am vastly exaggerating my
memories
the campaigns between
eisenhower and stevenson
were notable
for some rather sophisticated debate
about
the role of government
uh in in the life of our nation
uh in its business life and in our
personal lives and they were very very
clear
distinctions and rather clear choices
that
ordinary voters could make
1960 was not unlike the 50s in the sense
that there were substantial differences
between kennedy and nixon on foreign
policy
the the the great clash between uh and
one-sided clash between
goldwater and johnson in 1964 was as
clear and ideological division as i
think any of us can mention
uh even the rather
uh dispiriting campaigns of nixon hump
368 and nixon mcgovern 72
uh
uh
uh significant differences over what had
then become the so-called value issues
in this country with words like
permissiveness and so on cropping up and
uh really really for the first time and
defining a debate over social values
that continued into the reagan era
now in each case
there were there were things that we as
reporters or people as analysts on radio
and television and newspapers could sink
their teeth into
and in this case
i don't think that
is possible in fact if if if i might say
something mildly outrageous
i think um
uh ideological intellectual content
disappeared from this campaign the day
pat buchanan disappeared
i personally think buchanan was on the
wrong side of about nine out of ten
issues
but i remember feeling a great sense of
loss
uh i was down there in south carolina
and i went down to florida again on a
sort of
an editorial rather than a reporting
mission
but i enjoyed going to steve buchanan
because he wasn't running away from
substance he was going headfirst into it
uh whether it was a trade issue or an
issue like abortion or issue like family
values i mean pat buchanan is a stubborn
guy and he said i'm out here
representing this point of view and here
it is take her to leave it
now these two guys are out there now the
president and uh and and the former
majority leader are just at waltzing and
uh the debates i think were were
evidence of that it was two of the worst
debates and most unenlightening
exercises that uh it's it's ever been my
privilege to witness
uh i'll i'll stop right there maybe
maybe my colleagues here can tell me why
this has all come about
but frankly i find it an uninteresting
and dispiriting campaign in part because
i think people are interested in image
and not in substance and in part because
they're absolutely terrified that if
they actually say what they believe it's
going to cost them votes
lewis
has substance been confined to the
margins
to third party margins of martians to
third fourth and martian parties
yes yes
i think substance is confined to the to
the margins uh i'm sure bob would
be rewarded intellectually if you listen
to ralph nader's campaign well if you
listen to ralph later i think it would
be even more interesting than listening
to buchanan but
that is i'll take nader okay well the uh
that aside i think yes it is all spin i
think the election is uh
this doesn't work let's move the mic up
you know the um
am i now close enough to the microphone
thank you
i feel like i'm testifying in front of
some criminal committee
when we get to the questions
all right the uh
i was saying an answer to peter's
question that i do think that the
election is all spin all image i think
it is a
corporate
advertising campaign because i think
that the money that is behind both
candidates is essentially the same
so
i think of it as a
an america is a democracy festival
that's being
played out over a
few months time the the media is
desperate to drum up a crowd very hard
to do
the in san diego the
kemp's
nominating or acceptance speech
carried on on i believe abc and cbs
you added those two
channels together and it didn't match
the audience for a rerun of seinfeld
on nbc
seinfeld was playing a blazer
and that was more interesting to a good
many more people the united states than
the
republican convention
i i think it's a very
light-minded weightless
television
spectacle
but i think that is what our politics
have become i think that over a period
of time
as politics have become
less and less important
in the way the united states
is governed the way it operates
that the
uh meaning is is leeched out of
um
whichever
um
actors are
hired
for the
occasion
louis is it possible that we're the
leeches
that
this year the debates some would say
were maybe not vibrant but
better or less degraded than in previous
years when reporters were asking
questions about
how candidates would respond to their
wives being raped is it the media that
is the leech
no i don't think so i think this is
i think the media is by and large
uh owned and operated by the same um
interests that own and operate the
politicians i mean i i don't make much
of a distinction between the media and
the politicians they are as far as i can
see
part of the same world part of the same
act part of the same troop
so i don't think it's the media i also
am hard pressed to remember i mean
i do not remember the stevenson debates
but i i can remember very little
substance in uh
anything uh reagan ever said that i mean
reagan was reading is a movie actor who
was reading a script
so what you have is uh
seems to me that there's not much
difference between reagan and clinton
in terms of their
the role that they play there's also the
question of what is the role of the
president the role of the president
increasingly has become the role of a
talk show host or the role of a
visiting clergyman one who shows
sympathy
one who cares i mean i don't think
anybody expects clinton to do anything
they certainly don't expect dole to do
anything but i don't think they expected
reagan to do anything either
which i think is perfectly uh
along the lines of
where the american people are at
i mean
what what does one expect uh from
politics one gets one's meaning one's
identity one's
pension from
the corporations i mean a big
corporation today employs more people
and lived in
seven
14th century florence
it's the corporation that will
decide your life
corporations are run as
small merchant states and it's a much
more
coherent um
an effective locus of decision and
intellectual force than the government
so that the government
in my view
essentially collects taxes
for
uh the corporations
and the corporations uh in order to
um entertain the folks you know
run an election every for you so the you
so you see you see the political process
as entertainment before a stock a
shareholders meaning exactly
i do it's the song and dance before the
shareholders meeting
uh ash um
you have a longer memory is there
anything upbeat that's going on in 1996
i'm very upbeat about this by the way i
mean that's not
i don't i don't mean this as a as a
it's not certainly not a criticism yeah
it's not criticism
it uh
it strikes me that this is the third
consecutive election that will be lost
rather than one
governor dukakis was ahead in
1988 president bush was ahead in 1992.
bob dole has never been ahead but he's
had a very vulnerable opponent almost
waiting for a
a plausible reasonable
adversary
i think what this
this campaign really needed was ross
perot
on the same level as he was in 1992 and
i think it's absolutely mindless that
perrault was denied participation in the
debates this is a man who got 19 of the
vote
in 1992 he got almost 30 million dollars
from the federal election commission
it's just crazy that he wasn't allowed
in and i think this might have been a
much more interesting election had he
been there
in those particular venues
what i think is going to happen
is that we may have the lowest
presidential turnout in history i saw my
friend
curtis gans who's the most astute
student of voting in this country that i
know
the other night estimating that
last year in 1992 55
of those eligible voted he said he
thought this year would go down to 52 or
53 i believe it's going to go below 50
for the first time in this century and
perhaps our history
mr mayor
you actually live in the world of
politics day by day uh is this some is
this
so much smoke and mirrors from the land
of the media was that
a play on words yeah that's great um
well i'm i'm just a country lawyer uh
from uh
and a rhodes scholar
but i wanted to um
join in and give a little bit of a
different perspective on this
although i've never run for a national
office i've run at the
state and local level five times
now
for office and participated
in the
campaigns for
our senators our congress people and um
in the
uh uh presidential uh elections as as a
a part of a the truth squad going around
chasing jack kemp um when he says things
about cities uh
we democratic mayors say other things
about cities
it's it's a nice little waltz but uh i
wanted to just to give a slightly
different perspective than what has been
stated so far
i i've
known an awful lot of candidates and a
lot of pollsters
and uh understand this this got me in
trouble when i told the the the
publisher of our local newspaper uh but
it in fact is the truth that we are
taught drummed in our minds as as
candidates that the overwhelming
majority
of the people who will vote for us
get their primary information from
television
not print
not radio but from television that print
is is vitally important because every
morning the
editors at the tv stations read the
newspapers and and cut out what they
think
should go on the news uh during the day
but that uh and so it is important to
try to impact what's happening in the in
the newspapers but as a candidate
what you're thinking all the time is
how is this going to
impact people who see it visually
on on tv which means that you may have a
discussion
about all types of broad policy you can
sit with the editors
of a paper and and wax eloquently on
welfare reform
but by the time you get out on the stump
you're going to
boil it down to something that can go
across the airways uh to uh the
television audience and impact people's
feelings and and decisions uh of that
that way
and
and so you you end up getting i don't
know what came first the um
in this this process but it is very
clear now that uh candidates are uh
tailoring their activities their
comments um uh what they do on a
day-to-day basis to how this image is
going to come out
on on tv
and it frustrates a lot of people now
remember if you well those who did watch
the debate in in san diego
when when jim lehrer
al almost
had to beg the the the people asking
questions the citizens who were asking
questions you remember there was a
moment where he turned to the back and
says does anybody have a question about
foreign policy
and the response was that one person
asked a question about
whether what the candidate's position
was on paying
military personnel who were overseas
very important to remember what what's
on people's
mind
with respect to even a presidential race
i know what's on people's mind when
you're talking about being the mayor i
mean we don't debate a lot of major
issues uh of uh in abstract people want
to know are you gonna you know move the
trash and and get the snow and to make
keep us safe but on the presidential
election um
these candidates are also understanding
it posters love
this one question
they ask a question of of people do you
think that the country
is moving in the right direction or the
wrong direction
and they they they use that a lot and
they they feed that data uh to the print
media they like to write about that when
polls indicate that the country feels
it's moving in the wrong direction with
this candidate or that candidate but the
what to me is the more crucial question
that they ask
uh in in just about all the polls is do
you think that this person whoever this
candidate is do you think that this
person
cares about people like me
and that is that when i see the answer
to that
that to me is is
ultimately in the campaign going to be a
more crucial question
and because people want to know do you
understand my problem what are you going
to do about my problem how are you going
to uh in
in the office affect the things that
affect me on a daily basis ah yes i do
know there is a bosnia but
tomorrow
i know that i'm worried about getting
back and forth to work safely my
children getting back and forth safely
people being educated things of that
nature and so bosnia moves about as far
from my mind as it is geographically
from my house so the candidates then are
trying to relate to what people care
about on a daily basis and again
trying to get it across to the tv now
for good or bad i'll just give you a
quick example
of
what i think is some good sides of that
what bad side when i when i ran for
office in in
in baltimore i noticed that we had this
major change
in in the economy of our city 30 years
ago the largest private employer was the
bethlehem steel corporation sparrows
point plant
baltimore was a a steel producer had a
port it was true blue collar
but when i came ran for office the
largest private employer was the johns
hopkins university and health center
and then looking out it appeared and
it's still true that what our problem
was not that there are no jobs is
there's a skills gap between the type of
jobs that we had and the skills level of
our people
and so the whole idea was to try to
improve levels of literacy and get
everybody up to where they could achieve
of career opportunities now i just took
about a minute and a half to explain
that to you that then that dog doesn't
hunt on tv i mean that
and so what what did i do what did i do
i ran on a platform that i want
baltimore to become the city that reads
that was the the slogan and they would
say what you know mayor's uh you know
candidate out here wants baltimore to
become the city that reads all that that
i just explained to you got boiled down
to that one little uh slogan the city
that reads now it was popular and it
worked for me and it got people asking
me later what do you mean and i could
give them my whole spiel about bethlehem
theo and sparrows and hopkins but if i
had tried to do that it never would have
made it on tv the city that reads that
i'm for that as a city degree now give
me a downside example
uh is is the uh senate uh is is uh bob
dole's um drug policy
he he may have the most well thought out
drug policy
it could be balanced he he may have an
idea of where he wants to go where he
wants to but he ended up because he knew
he had to get it on tv coming out with
this slogan
for a campaign just don't do it
i'm sorry that slogan just didn't do it
uh
and and that's one where it missed it
missed a good opportunity to try to
crash something for the tv but you can
understand what he wasn't trying to
simplify the election or or or appeal to
the uh the worst instincts and people or
or uh ignore the uh uh the intelligence
of people but he knew from his pollsters
that he had to get across the majority
of his voters not not to to everybody
but the majority of his voters are going
to get that the bulk of their news off
tv so he had to boil it down and what it
boiled down to in my view was not a
message that really conveyed a new
direction a sense that his policies were
going to be better than the last 20
years on that particular issue but my
sense is that
wherever it started whether it was the
beginning of tv or whatever but right
now this is where your candidates are
and their advisors and i don't see it
getting any better anytime soon mr mayor
if you ever
weary of the political process with a
campaign
slogan such as the city that reads you
clearly have a future in publishing
okay
margaret who is in from
covering among many other races this
week
uh one that's gotten a great deal of
national attention the carry weld senate
race television has taken a lambasting
both while you've been here and before
can we say anything positive
of course i uh represent we like to
think at the newshour with jim lehrer
that we represent the print version of
television
we are always happy when in fact
recently this week in time magazine we
were compared to the new york times you
know that we felt terrific about that so
i think i can speak both from the print
and the television perspective
i would associate myself with everything
ash lewis and bob said about
the debasement of the public debate in a
campaign
but i think kurt put his finger on
something that is
the reason
people such as all of you in this room
or all of us up here are dismayed is
because the campaign debate used to
always be played out essentially in
print form for people who read and like
to discuss issues like this
i don't think the reason voters voted
for kennedy versus nixon were any
different than the simple question that
kurt put his finger on i i happen to
have a different pollster question i
think a more significant one is are you
better off than you were four years ago
or worse off but it's it's some form of
that and i think it's always been some
form of that it's just that because now
television is this medium of
communication
the politicians have had to change their
rhetoric to speak through that medium
rather than
only speaking to the editorial board of
the new york times but i would be
fascinated to read really in-depth
polling data from the 60 campaign the 48
campaign any campaign that we now look
back on and say oh wasn't that
high-minded and edifying
i think voters by and large unless
they're in a war
um
vote for very pragmatic reasons
and so i think this election yes it's it
feels very superficial there is no doubt
that there's no engagement there's less
engagement on the major issues
even for the print media than there
would be and there's a tremendous
frustration with bob dole everyone is
certainly republicans blame him for not
sort of taking the case to bill clinton
this morning my esteemed colleague david
broder whom i'm sure all of you know who
he is said on the radio this morning in
some frustration
i think bob dole would have lost if he
ran unopposed
that's the level of the frustration
that's out there
but i'll tell you i don't
i think
i don't think that's i don't think that
matters it may be true but it doesn't
matter i think probably bill clinton's
election
uh was almost assured um
months ago
when you started when people majority of
voters started to say they were better
off now than they were four years ago
and when a majority gave him bill
clinton over 50 percent approval it is
interesting to go back to the election
since say 52 and you look at incumbent
presidents trying to get reelected
every time there was a president who had
over 50 percent comfortably in the
months leading into the election it's
only happened three times eisenhower 56
nixon in 72 and reagan in 84.
it didn't matter all the sound and fury
the campaign meant nothing in the end
they won
if you look at presidents who were on
very rocky on very rocky footing in the
months going into the election george
bush
in the 80s excuse me in 92 or jimmy
carter in 80. in the end as tight as it
looked they ended up losing and i think
actually often a person's approval
rating of the president
is just a way of them giving a kind of a
civic gloss to how they really feel
about their own lives andy kohut who is
also a terrific pollster head of the pew
center for people in the press and as a
non-partisan pollster
uh said to me the other day he thinks
people like to justify
their vote for president i mean they
sort of make a decision on a very gut
level and then they say oh well i don't
like bob doler i really like bill
clinton that isn't really it it's really
all about their own lives and um i don't
i'm not saying there was nobody who
could have really forced bill clinton to
respond on these deeper issues of more
or less government i think there are
republican candidates who could have
done that more effectively or at least
challenged it more effectively but um
i'm just not sure in the end it would it
would have made a huge difference
the one thing the five of us seem to
agree on or six of us is yale length
opening statements
um so i'd like to welcome questions from
the audience as we go around you have i
believe no i believe we have note cards
on the chairs
which for our technical format need to
be written on with your question and
passed forward please to our friend
linda burstin
in the front row here but scribble away
and we'll pass them on up to the
panelists
let me turn to bob again to kick this
one off um
bill clinton
extraordinary figure
who nobody trusted somehow or other it's
a runaway why
well i think there's several reasons one
is the
nature
was to start with a negative the nature
of his opponent
dole should not be in this race he
should be in the united states senate
and although people tend to shy away
from the age issue i think it's in
everybody's mind
and
second
i mean that gives him an enormous
advantage for starters
running against
a person who has had a very
distinguished career of public service
but who is not
a
a fully credible presidential candidate
i mean i think that's one reason that
clinton has ignored some of these issues
i was complaining about
uh not least the future of entitlement
programs like medicare and medicaid and
social security i mean they're getting
away with murder out there with
generalities
and these are huge generational issues
but why did why should bill clinton
discuss them when all that's going to do
is bring him trouble in an election he's
got pretty much sewed up anyway
um
on that point by the way i agree with
ash that i kind of miss ross perot
myself
in much the same way that i miss
buchanan but
uh the site the main reason uh that bill
clinton is
there too
one on the character issue of the moral
issue
uh
i i think most americans have gotten
numb to that stuff
uh certainly the the personal
accusations uh people if that that stuff
just doesn't fly the entire story the
paula jones things these kind of things
seem to just
roll off
i don't know if it's reagan he inherited
some reagan teflon or not
or or whether people just don't care
about that stuff as much as they used to
but the fact of the matter it is not
registering in a negative way against
clint but the most important reason to
me is a reason that is vaguely related
to issues
and that was the skillful way in which
clinton i think at the aforementioned
dick morris is prodding
moved briskly to the center
uh
i don't know whether we can take his
state of the union of last of earlier
this year at face value or not or his
acceptance speech at the convention at
face value or what he's been saying in
the the campaign's face valley but if we
can
this is not the rooseveltian figure who
came in here with a giant medical care
program
uh after he was elected in in 1992.
this is a guy who has deliberately
co-opted the center and as a result
every time bob dole turns around there
stands bill clinton
occupying what should normally be
republican ideological territory
i think that and plus what margaret said
the general good feeling about the
economy
makes even republicans say gee i'm not
we're not doing too bad under bill
clinton and furthermore i don't fear
this fellow anymore
uh but i think that
those are the most important
ash with the character issue has it
always been thus i mean we often hear
people remarking about the death of
privacy
the indiscretions of the kennedy era
that were covered up at the same time
going back to the globe grover cleveland
election people were taunting the
president of the streets is this a media
misperception or
no i don't think so um bob was talking
about the eisenhower stevenson campaign
it wasn't quite that true blue because
you had richard nixon
referring to dean atchison as a graduate
of the cowardly college of containment
um
but going back to near the nattering the
bobs of negativity
alliteration in politics um
campaigning in the 19th century was far
tougher and far dirtier than it is today
it may seem hard to believe that but you
go back to the time of andrew jackson's
first run
for the presidency against henry clay
and john quincy adams and people just
said terrible things to each other and
the press then was much tougher
and dirtier than it is now as peter
mentioned there was grover cleveland who
was
accused accurately of having sired an
illegitimate child
you had in the 1896 campaign
people support
factory owners supporting mckinley
saying that if brian were elected don't
come to work on wednesday
this this is part of the american
tradition
and
you can deplore it you want all you want
but it seems to be
endemic in our political process
margaret what republican could have made
a better campaign than dole
i never do what if questions though uh
chuck kelly sitting in the second row
was head of citizens for colin powell so
i'm sure he has an answer
i as i said i really
i don't know i mean certainly we would
have all been happier with someone who
brought a certain if not ideological at
least intellectual energy and clarity to
the race but
you know i'm going to to something bob
said i think that the reason this
campaign seems devoid of ideas was it
was not only the bill clinton on the one
hand
moved from the left to the center but
then the republican congress which is
sorry
um
it's not only that mike on the left it's
not only that um bill clinton moved from
the center from the left to the center
but then the republican congress which
had wanted to present a very clear
choice when their poll numbers started
to go south this spring
suddenly they wanted to make a deal with
bill clinton on all kinds of things
kennedy castlebomb health bill minimum
wage and so on and so where you might
have seen
where a year ago newt gingrich thought
that this election would be really a
referendum on whether people wanted to
move in the direction of the republican
congress or of a leftist bill clinton as
gingrich saw it both of them moved to
the center and so you have this
this debate that has been debased to you
know are you for slashing medicare or
something it's no longer um a vigorous
or
particularly intellectually honest
debate
mr mayor
do you want me to get a candidate for
him yeah oh no since i dodged that one
right
no well i i think that um
some other practitioners
i thought about it um
and my sense was that if
one of the uh governors like if pete
wilson had been the the
uh that uh he would have or even lamar
alexander the reason why i say that is
that a lot of people didn't know
alexander but a lot of debates
campaigns in my view elections are
referendums on the future not
debates about the past and
one of the things that i i think hurts
senator dole is that he doesn't
for many many people project a vigorous
image or symbol of the future
and and that hurts again in this tv uh
era and uh so
some of the other
uh
republican uh
elected officials such as uh pete wilson
or lamar alexander or a weld or someone
like that
with a little projects better an image
of the future might have caused uh
the president a little bit more trouble
but i think that bottom line it was
going to be the economy that that ruled
the day um as as long as we didn't have
americans dying someplace overseas and
uh that uh everybody all of the
well-known republicans would have had
trouble but but
some of these governors i think could
have given him a little bit more trouble
lewis you have written a couple of very
powerful pieces this year both in the
new york times book review and uh in
your own regular space in harpers
uh saying very much how the system is
broken
uh the review you did of the book on the
constitution is it the system or the
people the candidates the media
tell us about your view on the system
that underlies
well
i'm not a politician and i'm not a
constitutional scholar but i'd like to
address the question of television the
uh
and i think you can
the election here is quite simple
because clinton is made for television
and dole is not
and if you read
mcluhan's understanding media he will
tell you that
there was once a world of print where
people where things were thought of in
straight lines and where there was cause
and effect and where words meant
something
in the electronic media this doesn't
happen there is no cause and effect
and uh words do not necessarily mean
anything because there there isn't time
to hear them television is about emotion
and about slogan
and you you it that just happens to be
the form of it and and
clinton is of that form
mcluhan says
we become what we behold
we shape our tools and then our tools
shape us and clinton is shaped by
television and
dole is not dole might as well be
speaking medieval latin it it's it's
meaningless
and the
is a very
wonderful um
perception by russell baker in his
autobiography he taught he was the times
correspondent at the
nixon kennedy debate in 1960 and he
wrote the he covered the debate
and
awarded the debate without question on
points to nixon because understood his
words
nixon
clearly
dominated the debate and after he'd
written a story baker then walked into
the press room and saw the rerun of it
on television
and knew that he was wrong
knew that he'd completely missed the
point
and that his story for the next day was
wrong because he'd written it off
what was said
and not off the the
image that you get off television now
you could i'm not knocking that that
just happens to be i might you might as
well argue with the uh
and say the water is wet that just
happens to be the form of communication
which we know
which is the way we talk to each other
and you can see that when you see little
children talk to television reporters at
the age of 10
they know exactly how to hit this the
the mark of the sound bite you ask it
any anybody on the street uh anywhere in
this country
i didn't quite understand the um your
comment though but words
uh mean something important i mean words
mean a great deal
if you're a candidate on television i
mean you recall when jimmy carter made a
comment about ethnic purity of of
neighborhoods it was
just what you say and
a little slip i think that's what they
look at debates for to see if you slip
with a little word or that's you know
poland's not uh
dominated by no i agree with you i agree
with you it's like it's like the city
that reads right uh you try to find that
the slogan can either make it for you or
it can completely damage right
read my lips destroyed uh bush where's
the beef destroyed i forget who
but
you know but the
so but distinguish that that's the use
of the
that's the use of words in an in an
emotional
that's not argument right that's not
that's interesting you see what i'm
saying
uh ash as someone with a very long
historic uh
view we have an excellent question from
the audience um if the campaign is a
show in quotes or a smoke screen what is
really going on in our nation isn't
there a fundamental change end of the
cold war
info revolution that is historic and
presidents are just trying to keep up
what should the president do
wow
are we picking presidents or telling
what presidents should do
i think that's a
question that one could spend a lot of
time dealing with and i'm not sure in
this
uh
in this area you should
we can deal with it but obviously there
are great changes going on in this
country
and we don't know how to catch up with
them
and
we have a millennium
not only a new century but a millennium
approaching and there are going to be in
the world of books
more books than you care to read about
the implications of what
this new
brave or not so brave new world uh will
bring
things are going around very fast these
days and i'm not sure we can keep up
with them bob one of the things that's
concerned you and a lot of the i'm sorry
one thing that whoever asked that
question actually a lot of voters when i
go out in the field and talk to them
that's kind of what they say unless less
maybe elegant terms that is
i think voters are seeing their
president less and less relevant to
their lives
and i think the end of the cold war has
a lot to do with it and that's why
washington seems less important and less
relevant i was out in a swing district
near cleveland about three weeks ago and
what struck me was even people who were
going to vote for clinton though they
were republican because the economy was
much better they were doing all right
they would always say not that he's had
anything to do with it it's because i
work hard it's because i work for a good
company whatever they just said but
think
since things are stable you know i'll
leave them the way they are but i do
think that americans no longer
i think just they look less and less to
their president as
an all-powerful person whose policies
make a huge difference in their in their
day-to-day lives i also think they look
less and less to the
the public sector pub the word public is
now a dirty word
it means slum it means poor
education it means
corrupt politicians and the word private
means efficient
clear blue trout streams and so forth
and and this is a
very big reversal over the last 40 or 50
years so that all virtue now supposed to
reside in the private sector
and all vice in the public sector and so
that what you now see
is the
the government transferring its assets
to the private sector
we spend in this country in on
on
public law enforcement
roughly 26 billion dollars a year and we
spend twice that some in private law
enforcement
and and this is true left and right i
mean you have the whole republican
congress let's get the government get
out of the business of education get out
of the business of of health care turn
it over to the uh
hmos turn it and so on so the whole
notion of public
of a politics of a
commonwealth is
in disrepute
and therefore the president becomes an
increasingly marginal figure of visiting
clergymen a bedside companion who's
going to make you feel for 10 minutes
that he
cares or knows what you're
concerned about so louis i would say
that the republican congress thought
that was entirely true and if if it had
been they would be riding very high i
think
the public didn't turn out to buy that
totally i mean i think there's a
constant tension you look at the way the
public responded
to deregulation in the environmental
area the govern you know
a majority of americans said wait a
minute i like the fact that there are
clear trout streams and i know it
wouldn't be clear if it was just left to
yeah but the deregulation is going on at
a great pace but not as fast as an
ideologue would want i i just don't like
the americans not as fast as robert bork
would like okay but i mean it's going on
i mean it i mean
uh
clinton isn't fighting that the
democrats are not fighting that
i mean they would say
that's the whole point of what bob is
talking about of moving toward the
center
they've gone along with that and and
again you have the the fundamental
language is that if it's public it's bad
but that's something i know something
about let me make a comment about this
and i have a question for louis
but the republicans just scared people
with the contract because basically they
want to do is dismantle
the fundamental statutory framework that
had done a lot of good for people in the
environmental area i mean and the voters
woke up one morning wait a minute we
didn't vote for that we voted for some
deregulation some smoothing some
tinkering and so on and so forth
but but lewis raised a very challenging
point in part because bill clinton
advertised himself four years ago as
someone who would bring back
a sense of purpose to public life and a
sense of respectability to the to the
notion of
of serving
when at the local level or the state
house or in washington a kind of revival
of the kennedy
idea of in mystique of of 1960 and a lot
of us can remember the enthusiasm that
attended uh his election and
a lot of our colleagues first came to
washington because of of that sense that
there was something
noble to be achieved in this city
now
i think lewis is right
in his description of what's going on
but i'm wondering
whether we can't sharpen the diagnosis
i'd not
the way you left it it makes you sound
like the american people i'm not putting
words in your mind that as a whole
would rather
rather privatize things
and really don't much trust the
mechanisms of government and its
bureaucracy to do good
in the way we might have wanted to trust
them under roosevelt or kennedy and that
clinton having recognized that
is moving briskly in that direction
but to some extent
the people who occupy positions of power
in this city have brought it upon
themselves
i'm always happy to see the blame rest
on politicians yeah
i mean it's i don't think it's the
people out there saying there is a
better way of doing things than the
government way i mean that's part that's
a very important part of it the other
part is just a gradual erosion of
respect
for the process as a whole
brought about process of government of
government brought about by the
increasing influence
of big money and special interest i mean
i think ash was absolutely right the one
the only person out there and he did it
to the press club brilliantly the other
day is we're all talking about that you
don't see dole talking about that you
don't say clinton remember that great
that memorable handshake between
gingrich and um
the president in new hampshire yeah that
day and then and they pledge
this look of mutual sincerity on those
two political faces
we will attack the whole question of
campaign financing and big time
corruption
and the excessive influence of the
special interest and nothing
has happened absolutely nothing
dole has come rather late and lame to
this issue in the campaign and the
president hasn't really talked about it
because he's talking about other things
but i think
this is just
this is this is fundamental
to the the breakdown in trust between
ordinary citizens
and the whole notion
of commonwealth that you were talking
about
okay i mean i i
that's fine i can agree with all that
but thank you mr mayor curt can we all
right i was gonna say can we do anything
about the i mean we've all
seem to be
together on in lamenting the role of
money in demeaning the political process
what are the alternatives
well um
the the the difficulty again
going back to uh
i'm just trying to place myself as a
in in the role of candidate
uh if if i want to get my message across
i want to define myself to voters
then i'm going to have to get into their
homes as much as possible
in the most effective way
to communicate that image
and i know from my friendly pollster
that the way is through tv
which means getting a lot of ads which
and and unfortunately our tv stations
don't take credit they i thought you
were referring to guest shots on
homicide right that's right but
the and the reason for this is that i
think a lot of us are gun shy
of
simply leaving the debate
to
uh the the filter
of of uh editorial boards or
or reporters
um to have them convey what they think
is your message
so
unless we're going to go to public
financing
at a at a reasonable rate
and i don't think that's going to happen
for the reasons that were stated before
that is the public's not going to want
to put their money their tax dollars in
to uh a public uh public financing of
campaigns we're stuck
with this situation of candidates trying
to get their message out the most
effective way and so i don't see um uh
in the near future a major change in um
uh the way we finance unless we're going
to go we have a big scandal and i think
that's probably what would would do it
some major scandal
that would get everybody up in arms and
say we're going to go to public
financing of of elections and try that
for another decade but at this point i
just don't
see us moving uh dramatically away from
yeah if you think if you think the
commercial networks and local television
stations are going to give over
a lot of prime time to political
candidates for free
lots of luck right it's not going to
happen so then you as a candidate are
spending most of your time
raising money and reviewing commercials
and every once in a while you go speak
to an issue
but there again is there's a historical
precedent i mean
right the i mean carlos huntington who
was the
man representing the
southern pacific railroad in washington
in 1880 used to keep a ledger of the
bribes paid to the members of congress
through every session any different it
was a handsome amount of money it was
500 000 a year
distributed to the congress in in the
1880s in order to get the land grants
for the southern pacific railroad and
and the
that 500 000 was worth a good deal in it
more than it is today but he kept a
ledger
and he divided the entire congress into
three kinds of people three c's they
were the clean
these were the politicians that did what
they were told
uh by the big railroad interests uh
without you know did it sort of
as a matter of profound belief
then they were the commercial who
accepted the bribes
and did what they were told and then
there were the communists
and the communists were the people
who didn't take the bribes and didn't do
what they were told but they were
very few as few then as there are now
margaret uh a very good question which i
guess is best directed to you because
we've beating up almost as much on
television as we are on campaign finance
we're not beating up on we're just
saying it's the form the media the
medium all right this is the question
does the nature of tv
prevent substantive campaigning
i i feel as if we've kind of addressed
that that is that that you communicate
in a different way through television so
i
um maybe you have another great question
yes uh well
one that i think is on a lot of months
will the democrats uh take the house or
the senate
who
i i
not only do not like to make predictions
but i genuinely don't know i really i
think that is where the big excitement
and suspense is going to be and um
you've been covering an exciting race in
massachusetts well i have i mean are
people getting more engaged at the state
and local very well debate in
massachusetts people are really engaged
partly it's because massachusetts is
massachusetts that is there they've got
two passions the red sox and politics
anyway but they also have just two
incredible candidates and um that is
they are larger than life they are very
very smart they are clever they are
funny and they are having a real debate
about the role of government
not that they aren't each trimming a
little bit which they are uh you know
weld uh beginning i we with a couple
events with him earlier this week and he
announced to a group of senior citizens
that he actually liked clinton's
medicare plan
um so you know and kerry has done
similar things from the other side but
still
it's satisfying race and they have all
these debates they're going to have
their ninth or tenth one on monday night
on c-span among other things at faneuil
hall
because they're both so articulate and
so they are really able to engage and so
it's it's just a fabulous race from that
perspective didn't they try to put
voluntary limits on their spending they
did and that's a great example 6.9
million dollars a piece would seem
reasonable from july to november seems
like a reasonable amount of money limit
of a half of uh 5 million of that on tv
it's totally busted now for reasons that
are too long to go into but it it shows
that and i really don't have any answer
for this question about
the corrosive influence of money and
politics on every level from
essentially buying
it doesn't buy votes maybe quite as
crudely as uh as the earlier example but
in fact
you know that's the way the public
perceives it and that no doubt buys
access and i i don't see an answer to it
unless this curt says we have an
incredible scandal and then you might
see a turning toward public financing
but there are those
who believe and they may be right that
this whole
the whole impulse to buy access and
influence through money is like you know
i don't the image water i mean if if
it's blocked here it'll just go around
kurt is it possible that the uh the
electorate is somewhat at fault uh we
have an excellent question here does it
seem to you that the presidents are
caught
the candidates are caught in a catch-22
people lamented the mudslinging and lack
of civility in political debate but when
dole and clinton had their quote
friendly debate in hartford americans
tuned out what are they to do to get an
audience
the candidates
well i think the president is is
operating on the uh
the principle that uh my my former high
school football coach once once said to
me uh
he said that uh exciting games uh are
for the fans i prefer a dull slaughter
the whole idea
just you know it went particularly
when you know that you've got this this
important issue here of people's
pocketbooks you don't want to
rock the boat but
yes i think
there is a
real dilemma for candidates because
oftentimes people will say speak to me
about the real issues
but don't tell me anything bad
it speak to tell me that social security
is going to be fine for the next 100
years
but don't make me sacrifice in order to
preserve it
make sure that i can always choose my
family doctor but don't give me the
implications of of a policy that allows
that to occur so i think that at least
during campaigns that the uh the easiest
thing uh for candidates to try to define
a couple of emotional uh
issues stay on that theme and don't
deviate as long as it's working i think
if the numbers uh the president's
numbers for example were
very different or if
that bump after the republican
convention had continued and it was you
might see more of a debate about a very
important issues but
with these uh numbers confirming that
the economy is the key issue
now i think then you get only the the
superficial
bomb if kurt has said that
in some ways the um campaigning
politicians obligation is to stay on
message now
you would perceive the press's uh their
obligation to educate the electorate and
raise some of the national issues of the
day is the media in the middle
what do you mean by in the middle
are they the ones who can sort of pull
the candidates back on
a larger agenda addressing things that
are not
a designed message that's necessary to
communicate
i i don't know i you know
uh what about these kinds of discussions
depressed me a little bit because
i wind up believing as cats the mayor
baltimore pointed out that my main role
in life is to provide
uh
textual material in the morning for the
editors and producers of television
programs
you do it very well
we're very grateful
well if you think you think i'm in
trouble what about you
it's very obscure it's even more obscure
i am i'm consoled by the thought that as
soon as an election is over people do go
back to reading
and there is no objective evidence for
that but it's a very strong feeling i've
always had
now wait
you you do have a question sitting out
there i
uh
it's true but all we can really do is
what i'm doing tonight is fail away a
little bit
and say gee we wish you had a more
substantive debate we wish you talked a
little more we wish the questions were
better and so and so forth and in the
end uh as difficult as it is i come down
on where kurt smoke is and decide where
he is and where lewis is
that or where mcluhan was that but
fundamentally and i don't really think
we've talked it all the way tomorrow
because there is still a larger question
out there about tv's responsibility i
mean if we're going to give it the lead
role in our political process right now
i'd like to know how we make that role
better
and so we find ourselves in print
journalism saying oh my god
look at those terrible attack ads or
wasn't that a lousy debate or couldn't
we do better and so on and so forth
and
it our only our main responses were
terrific at fighting the last war by the
way in our business and most of us are
but and and every year we try to do
better in terms of presenting the
candidate speeches and the substance of
his ideas
and so on and so forth but in the end
kurt is right
uh people are not
sitting on the number four lexington
avenue train reading three pages of the
new york times on where so and so stands
on drug on the drug issue
they're waiting for that minute and a
half
and if we're let my question is if you
and this a whole other discussion but if
we are left with that minute and a half
can't we do better than another half
and and that is almost that's out of my
hands
louis my question is do we really
believe we want a better debate
i mean with who would go to it if
stephen douglas and
lincoln were to rise from the grave and
begin to talk at long lengths who would
care i don't think the united american
people really want a good debate
i don't think they'd go to it if it
shows and kerry seemed to well it's
pretty well done okay okay weld and
carry have i probably that's probably so
but i mean
they i don't see that the the uh
but that has been up to them then to do
it i mean i haven't seen the debate so i
can't
one of one of the things that seems to
be running back and forth here is the
interactive role of different media if
the good gray lady and other morning
newspapers set the agenda for television
ash is it possible that books still set
the agenda
for newspapers
and magazines and magazines
well and do magazines set the agenda for
newspapers the first the columnists and
the pundits the first political book i
know of was the campaign biography of
franklin pierce written by his fellow
new englander nathaniel hawthorne
which must have been a case of the over
the author overwhelming his subject
and there were there were
for a hundred years there were campaign
biographies but it wasn't until teddy
white wrote the making of the president
that you had a book that really delved
into the process and told the story as
it once happened and there of course
have been many clones of teddy white
over the years
there have been uh sort of books on the
margins like joe mcguinness is the
selling of the president tim krause's
the boys on the bus
and most recently richard ben cramer's
what it takes
would you tell us a bit
what you see distinctive about each of
those i mean what was there something
that sort of carved a new path why did
they become well they're all they're all
pretty much exposed facto except this
year bob woodward wrote the choice which
was about
clinton and dole because they had
already been chosen so in a way that
book might have affected some voters in
1960 arthur schlesinger wrote a book
called kennedy or nixon does it make any
difference it was published right at
labor day of 1960 and it theoretically
may have made a difference
among voters who were nervous about
kennedy's catholicism or his father or
other
aspects of his uh persona
louis what about columnist do you feel
they
when we go back to an era in this town
with the allsups and many others who
sort of set the agenda for the daily
newspaper um
they were sort of in elite media we
sometimes refer to bigfoots who were
major major i mean david broder has been
quoted with reverence this evening uh do
columnists make a difference in setting
the agenda
i don't know i mean i i assume bob would
tell you that because most of the big
feet that i know work for newspapers i
don't know many of them write for
magazine but all right bob the questions
for you
what sets the agenda for
what sets the agenda for the agenda
setters
well
i don't know i mean i i read marine dowd
i read bill sapphire
do you read another paper
i read other papers i read
uh joe klein and newsweek i read a lot
of columns
uh most of whom seem to be agreed
on several essential points about bill
clinton
that he moves like a weather vane that
he tailors his principles to the
prevailing winds
that you can't really trust him as to
character or as to issue
and then i look at the polls
and i see that bill clinton has got a
19.5 point lead
that leads me to believe that these
heavyweight columnists aren't making a
dime's worth of difference
uh
well that that would be true because of
the circulation i mean what's the
circulation of the time
about a million
that's a very small fraction very small
of the numbers of people and you know
that with luxurious 250 million but
all i'm saying sure there is some agenda
setting there but they
but it's it really is aimed at a very
specialized audience and part of that
audience is the president himself
the first lady the people that are
elected to congress
and the senior members of the
bureaucracy it is on that audience that
i think the print media has peter some
significant influence
and that influence will pick up again
when this election is over where we
don't have a heck of a lot of influence
either on the first bounce or the second
bounce or the third bounce
is is with the electorate in an election
campaign there
the influence lies in two places with
television as the mayor has said
uh and in the minds of the people and
and and how they're leaning and what
they're thinking and how busy they are
it's it's very simple whether they're
comfortable
with the incumbent or whether they're
uncomfortable i don't think this is not
rocket science
and i because it isn't i don't think
colonists can affect it
yeah i totally agree with bob if people
really wanted
um
as kurt said the voters say talk to me
about the issues well now if people
really wanted good serious journalism
and wanted to spend the time to
understand it
the new york times national edition
circulation would be you know 40 million
a day
and 40 million people would watch the
newshour
they don't
uh and they don't they don't subscribe
to the new york times and
i think the questioner who wrote the
question about
the public and he didn't the questioner
didn't use the phrase but there is a
kind of
if not willful ignorance a kind of
laziness about informing themselves i
mean for people to say they don't know
where the candidates stand on the issues
is just absurd i mean every newspaper
does more than its
dutiful duty
outlining where the candidates are on
the issues but what happens is they
watch the debates hoping there'll be
some incredible moment and when instead
it turns out to be a serious discussion
of issues they tune out and
you know that's that's the reality and
um
i i think to think that
in the minute what you're seeing say on
a local tv station and the mayor knows
more than i do about local tv because he
has to live with it more but
you know local tv stations are going for
ratings i mean the reason we can be um
at the newshour the way we are is that
though we care about people watching us
we aren't advertising driven that's the
bottom line but local tv is so
they're always searching for what's
going to get them the bigger market and
the fact is the bigger market goes to a
um
you know more superficial a different
kind of a product and i don't think
that's going to change i just wanted to
give you a an example
of that that might drive home um
some of what the comments that are just
been made
last year i i ran for re-election
my third term as as mayor of baltimore
so
at the beginning of the campaign
there was a baseball strike
and um
going into the the early part of january
february march so right in april um
there
the election the issues around the
election seem to be dominant i mean i
was impressed i said my god people are
engaged in this campaign they're they're
talking uh
about the issues every time i would go
to a forum it was really substantive and
all of a sudden the baseball strike was
over and
what was the issue is cal gonna break
lou gehrig's record
and
and really it became uh
the the the issue that was on the hot
topic around was was cal was cal ripken
and
it was like all of a sudden this
campaign just dropped off the charts now
fortunately for me i was the incumbent
so
you remember my story about the dull
slaughter i just laid low
but it was striking it was striking uh
to me and and i think this is what
occurs what is it that it's kind of
uppermost on on people's minds you have
to understand it and uh get either get
play around it or or try it in some way
incorporate it that can it can backfire
sometimes but in the bottom line
is that uh with this uh primary medium
out there i think that tv does
actually a pretty good job on some of
these issues i've watched uh i've been
watching tv uh covered welfare reform
and and i thought that the tv did a
pretty good job a lot of stations in
giving you pros and cons i've watched a
lot of reports on tv about these tax
proposals that have come out um
will the 15 percent income tax what are
the pros and cons of that so i don't i
don't want to demonize uh a tv but i do
want to
just keep
emphasizing it's its primacy uh in the
in the campaign process because i agree
that um outside of campaigns uh there
just seems to be some sense and maybe
it's anecdotal that people go back to
spending a little bit more time reading
reading the editorials talking about uh
the issues but once it gets in the
campaigns uh people particularly the
candidates and the pollsters are
crafting the issues they think are going
to sell and that's what's going to be
reported on
kurt let me just do one follow up with
you um
it's a question from the floor and
you're there our practicing politician
do you uh quote do you think clinton is
actually going to stay in the center
once he wins
if if the congress remains
uh republican dominated
i believe that he will stay
in in the center
and
i think that in fact the last two years
of his candidacy really are uh reflect
where his where his heart actually was
in terms of domestic policy um when he
was very involved as you all recall in
the democratic leadership council and
and the dlc was was moving far more
in the moderate the right of of of where
the the activists in the party were
i remember just as as mayor his first
year first few months in office he came
out with a so-called stimulus package
uh that was going to help the cities a
multi-billion dollar package and the
mayor's u.s conference of mayors all of
us were really pressing him to do that
and he took a beating i mean a terrible
beating in congress on on that
then he came back a few years later and
said look we we don't need that kind of
a program it's that's not what urban
policy is all about in the 90s and and
crafted a different kind of agenda which
has a balance of programs in
transportation welfare reform
empowerment zones very different kind of
investments you'd say
more to the center or more to the right
but i think that's where his heart
really is uh as a um
that that's where he'd like to be as as
as a president and so if there is a a
republican congress there
keeping him there that he'll he'll stay
in the center if there is a democratic
congress they may try to push him a
little bit more to the left but i think
he's comfortable where he is
ash how will books forthcoming and
history judge clinton's first term
you get all the weighty ones
well i know of only one book
that is going to cover the campaign
comprehensively and that's the newsweek
book which will be an expansion of the
their special election issue
just to show you how technology has
changed teddy white's books used to come
out in the july
july 4th july 4th after the previous
november's campaign
this
this the newsweek book will be in the
bookstores on inauguration day
technology has actually come to the
publishing world i don't know i don't
think you can really tell what clinton
is going to look like four years from
now eight years from now we're assuming
that he's going to have a second term
and that
whitewater willing he'll fulfill all
four years of it
i do know that second terms are rarely
as good as first terms
and that uh if he can find a way to
improve on his i think mostly positive
record
uh in the next four years i think he'll
have accomplished a feat that
a few presidents have
bob you had something you want to say no
i'm sorry margaret
um
no i didn't really though something um
ash just said about second terms it
certainly is true that
for one thing incumbent most
incumbents especially if they're far
ahead must have all had um kurt's coach
because they tend to campaign that way
and so for instance you would think if
bill clinton were 19 points ahead in the
polls or 20 he would say gee for the
final three weeks i'm going to lay out a
very challenging agenda so that i can
later claim a mandate which he has not
done
so and that ronald reagan did the same
thing in 84 it was just this rosie oh
it's morning in america and when this i
was covering the white house at the time
when that
they went back in in january i mean
there was no mandate for anything and
and it was not as strong as second term
lyndon johnson had his landslide and he
had a lot of trouble yeah
but that may be the nature of the beast
and also of course the president is uh
you know immediately a lame duck as well
politically
i i i had one thing i i absolutely i
think bill clinton absolutely requires a
second term
to define himself
[Laughter]
but why i mean why would you bother
why would i bother no why would no
father why would he bother well he likes
the job i think well sure but but but
his whole the nature of the job is being
undefined
but maybe
but he can run again in 2002.
but i'm just looking at her
from the point of view of the questioner
who asked to ask that question or
actually end up answering that question
if you were a writer
how would you give definition to bill
clinton if as a writer i would find it
virtually impossible to now i covered
nixon from 68
through the burglary
but before the cover-up really started
that is to say
through the election against mcgovern
and i think i could have written
a book
not a best-selling book
maybe a book with a private imprint of
some kind with my own about nixon's
first term that would have given him
some
definition of course the last chapter of
the book would have been a
recommendation to nixon not to have a
second term
but uh there were some very clear
threads to his first four years that
what made a definable four-year
presidency out of it and he in
retrospect he should have quit while he
was ahead
but i couldn't i cannot do this with
bill clinton i mean in a stand do it's
any standard political and analytical
technique yeah but writers can define
people i mean well maybe not in a
newspaper but you can do that in books
and in magazines i mean frankly what's
to find uh clinton in two words the prom
king she called him
and that's really all you have to know
what the prom king the prom king
i went to an all-boys school
if you went to a
public high school you would know what
that meant
it's hard to improve upon
i think but uh
so i think definition is possible
i'm not about to abandon print to that
to that degree a question from the
audience suppose if colin powell had
been the candidate
how might that have affected the
election
well i well
let me uh all speculation but assuming
that he had been nominated by the party
that's the big assumption that he could
have actually obtained the republican
nomination but let's assume that
for a moment
um i think that it would have been an
extremely competitive race because uh
urban america east of the mississippi
the the big cities
it would have been up for grabs then
the
uh the cities form a tremendous
political base uh for uh president
clinton i mean he has got uh you look at
the polling in in the cities it is just
a lock um particularly in the
african-american uh
african-american community if powell had
been the candidate
um
there would have been an emotional tug
there
that at least would have had people uh
and i'm just speaking about black
america now
listening
thinking about an alt alternative to
democratic policies and
with more question marks more uncertain
than um
or undecideds than you currently have so
i think that had he been able to get the
republican nomination uh that it would
have been an extremely competitive race
but that a big assumption on the first
part
of how do you think he would have done
if he had run as an independent
um yeah i i don't think he would have
won
but i i think that
clinton's
uh clinton's hold on the cities would
have been uh weakened and uh thus this
the whole election certainly the
dynamics of the election would be
different i'm not sure if powell would
have would have won the thing because i
i must say i'm still a little skeptical
about how the issue of race plays on a
national
uh election um i've watched a number of
how would you juxtapose that with a
local yeah
well i've watched a number of of
candidates i thought for example that
mayor rice in seattle
had uh was going to
win the democratic nomination for
governor
uh
this year um he he lost
and um
it may be a lot of different reasons
particularly since the the person who
beat him as an asian american uh and uh
so
you know it there may be other uh
reasons out there but the the harvey
gantt election in in north carolina and
doug wilder uh when you see these these
polls people indicating they are going
to vote for the black candidate and then
when they get into the booth
something magical happens and they don't
i'm just a little skeptical that that
we've overcome it but i think if if
anybody could have
if anybody could really
put
almost the final nail on racism
uh in this country as a major factor in
elections in this country i think it was
general powell and um maybe he'll get
his chance in the future
if i could just add one point it also
would have i think blown a complete hole
in what has been bill clinton's strategy
which was to run against the republican
congress in other words he's tried to
turn this election into a referendum on
the republican congress and bob dole as
part of that congress
was
he successfully clinton has successfully
put him in that box
colin powell on the other hand was very
frank about the fact that he didn't
agree with everything that the
republican congress did so i think the
clinton white house would have had to
have a totally different strategy they
might still had a successful one but
strategically would have been a totally
different campaign
bob a very good question that names the
new york times
bob dole is claiming the new york times
the major media never print a negative
story about bill clinton implication the
media have given clinton the election
please comment
well
i has dole said that
uh actually today i don't know that he
named the times but he asked where is
the outrage in america uh in the press
not covering
issues of ethics and character
well
i think he's wrong for my sins i was
assigned to write about white water
and i don't do not know what i did to
deserve about but
the if you if you examine historical
record carefully the new york times
has written zillions and zillions of
words a lot of it of original nature
on
all those long ago and far away scandals
in arkansas
and i've written a number of editorials
on the subject and i wrote a long list
one called why white water matters
and i spoke about the character issue
and i spoke about how the political how
washington's landscape was littered
with the broken bodies of people that
clinton had imported from arkansas
people who have
now returned to their law firms or to
wall street are in jail
or in disgrace somewhere
and
i don't think we've been easy on bill
clinton and i know our columnists have
not been easy on bill clinton i don't
know what dole's talking about now
whether those stories and those
editorials had any impact whatsoever on
the electorate
uh is an entirely different question and
maybe that's what the source of mr
dole's frustration is but i i don't
think we've shown any particular
favoritism of the president uh before we
close i just wanted to go around perhaps
starting with ash back to margaret uh
with where we pointed from here we have
a question which maybe we'll let ash
start with do you think that this is
really a campaign of gore versus kemp
for the year 2000
i don't think i think hardly anyone is
thinking about gore in camp four years
from now okay
i think as i said i think this
this
will be one of the lowest
turnouts
of the century
and uh
i hope that the candidates four years
from now will inspire
a more active electorate but it is
dispiriting to see
uh
that we are the
nation with the lowest voting percentage
of any major nation in this world
lewis
do you see us headed towards the
behavioral sync the political sync
no i
no i mean it and again if i
if i were a practicing politician i
would
hope that as few people came to the
polls as possible i mean my mother
perhaps
and the what i would always want would
be the dull slaughter i i don't see
where the interest is in this country
for a lively political debate i don't
see where the constituency is certainly
it's not among the politicians
so and it's it again would make
margaret's point there's a very small
audience for
the long
serious discussions in magazines like
transaction or policy review or my own
or the newshour or the editorial page of
the uh times
so
and i'm not alarmed by this
i mean i'm not ringing my hands i mean
as again politics has become a
less entertaining perhaps or less
central to people's lives
bob as we look forward beyond uh
november is there any prospect of a a
race in the future with the year 2000 or
beyond whatever the candidates where the
national issues of the day
are brought in a more direct fashion
before the electorate
in a way that isn't mangled
no i'm kind of depressed about that but
i think the only way you're gonna one's
gonna have to be happy yeah
i don't see it i don't see it unless
there are
to go back to
to to louis's point
if
there comes the day when there are
issues that so plainly matter to people
that they then
choose to pay attention
then the candidates are going to have to
pay attention
but unless that happened i mean i i
suppose you had candidates like colin
powell and bill bradley say four years
from now wouldn't that
do you think
inspire a bigger turnout
or more interest in an election powell
and bradley
bradley i think that would be very much
like today's campaign on a slightly more
sophisticated level
uh i don't see any cl clash of
ideologies involving uh
uh
middle of very bright appealing charming
middle of the road people who are
essentially non-ideological but you know
we're complaining about uh some of this
because i hate to say it but but the
system
kind of works
and to a certain extent what happened
over the last two and a half years at
least was that they
the parties reached consensus on a
number of
uh issues that i think would be hot
button issues for the campaign they
worked out disagreements on welfare
reform they worked out uh some
approaches to
you know future issues like social
security and health care and because
they did this that left very few
issues than to really clobber one
another about and uh so
you know i guess if we had a breakdown
and a do-nothing congress and a
do-nothing president maybe we would have
more of a debate but i i do think the
next election with without an incumbent
is going to be more exciting people are
going to have to articulate a a new
clear vision somebody else is going to
come in and challenge that and some of
these generational issues i do believe
are going to come to the the four as
important so i i'm kind of optimistic
about it of course i'm part of the
problem
margaret uh kurt used the the
generational question where do you see
us
yeah i think that's where uh in a way
i'd part company with kurt in terms of
how well the system works i think it had
you you did see a lot of consensus on it
on issues that the public was clamoring
for an answer but on these these real
entitlement issues there has not been a
joining of or even an honesty from
either side and i
i think the one thing that is
unfortunate about our system is that
system is that
things have to reach a crisis before
they're addressed because the political
cost is too high but just back to the
issue about whether this is sort of a
2000 year 2000 campaign you know a
shadow campaign not at all i mean it's
the here and now every election is
and if people aren't thinking about
their own future they're definitely not
thinking about politicians futures
ash do you have anything you want to add
in closing no i was just talking to
louis
when mayor smoke talked about incumbency
i think
68 was the last election in which there
was not an incumbent running
and 2000
will be the first one and it will also
be
a millennial year
and it may cause all sorts of different
attitudes on that uh millennial note i
think we should uh thank c-span thanks
senator chafee the yelp club of
washington national public radio and
particularly our audience for superb
questions thank you very much and good
night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
on today's washington journal our guests
include tamara dean the vice president
of howard university's college democrats
and stephen tulbert chairman of american
universities college republicans
also today on c-span a speech by ross
perrault at the national pres
next historian stephen ambrose
us author and editor
photo
after the lewis and clark
into the america
and was held earlier this
tribute to mr
university new orleans
would you like
[Applause]
one of my
regrets that's
as
brand
him
what arthur this morning referred
the lines
great american
the
column that he wrote magazine
called grotesquely misn
the easy chair it is means and easy
and
and certainly wasn't the hands of
photo
the magazines
in the magazine it's
the oldest
continuously the united states
it founded in 18
and the
easy check
be written
following year in 18
one by a man
write it very long but
yes sir
george
curtis
39
this was a
agitate
he was one of the
republican
pain
strenuously
1960
and had many
causes in much of the same way
had the cause
character sweetly the
tweed
hang
dark and
the end out of
and
himself
the force
of the civil service
had advocated
the easy ch was succeeded
by
howell's
three
famous
american
author
in
letters
fair to say
the century
and
succeeded
in
1935
photo
after do
fisher and
fisher mice what's interesting is that
the practitioner
polls
from the west
magazine was turned toward the west
it's circulation ever since the
as
on the
western side of the alligations whereas
atlantic month magazine that is often
who
stood uh have articulation run along
new york
uh
kingdom hearts
goodbye
editor born in the west of california
from ohio
fisher was from oklahoma and
of course from utah
assumption was
the people
of the west
it was meant to be on
what's going down a river
at night
prairie
from any
war town
was meant to
say to these
roles
and watch
spirit of the country
from the
this is the tradition
that
devoto inherits and
nobly
fulfills i mean he
to read his comment they're about three
thousand words long each
and he always wrote to
fit his copy invariably came in
clean i'm relying on this
testimony on i'm relying for these
remarks on jack fisher
who was
the editor
when
devoto was writing the column and
himself succeeded
devoto in the column but
jack used to say that there was it was
it was a wonder to behold i mean here
would come these
magnificently
shaped beautifully written
manuscripts that didn't need a
have a hair
on their head change they could go
directly to the printer that is
enormously
rare that almost never happens in in
american journalism
devoto took the column very seriously he
said he said it one point to an
introduction of one of the collections
of his columns that
in his private assignments it had
the easy chair has always come first
and he hoped that it would be amusing
informative
or
useful
those were his
ambitions for it and he could change the
tone i mean he sometimes could write uh
with acerbic wit sometimes with
romantic passion sometimes in
indignation or anger
and the sometimes
all three of those tones within the
space of a single
column
he wrote it he said under the pressure
of haste and with
the morose knowledge that i wasn't
writing it well enough
he
brought to it
the full range of his
experience not only of the
western united states but also of
washington and he knew how politics
worked he served for a number of served
a number of presidents or a number of
government agencies in various
capacities
and he
could tell the difference between you
know he knew how
sheep farming worked he knew how
uh the land worked he knew how household
utensils work he always
based his opinions on
fact
and he
once described himself to fisher as a
hack
a
literary department store he said of
himself
but that
that is the way that both balzac and
dickens would have described themselves
they again thought the important thing
was the work and to
get it out at no matter
what
cost
devoto
the subjects that he approached are
extremely
varied he wrote
against censorship he wrote against the
literary
dogma in office in boston in new york in
the in the 30s
he wrote about bad restaurants he wrote
about useless knives
a knife that had too much chromium
didn't couldn't hold an
edge and so it looked very shiny
but it was functionally useless as far
as
devoto was concerned he would compare
the knife of course to
quite a few of the politicians in office
at the time i mean they would be
very shiny but functionally useless
right
and the
he he took the
point of the column to
be that of
as arthur explained this morning
counter cyclical
always questioning the wisdom
in office
if people were too comfortable with a
foreign policy that they nobody had
questioned for ten years
or if they
accepted again without question some
glorious american
tradition
or if they
thought that the political arrangement
which seemed entirely satisfactory to
the people in power
uh
again always the questions and that is
what uh
devoto
thought that he that's what he was doing
writing the column as an american
citizen
a citizen of a of a country that he also
conceived as a republic of letters
and it's um
of all the people that have that have
written the calendar in my mind no
question that uh
devoto is
far
the best
he
makes fun of
uh
the literary world
in new york
i mean edmund wilson once wrote a piece
i guess in the nation or the saturday
review possibly new yorker
very uh
intellectual piece about the detective
story and and trying to bring all the
machinery of
literary criticism to bear
on
writers like daschle hammett and jago
marsh
and devoto
went after him in a very entertaining
way he said
you know it's really just a detective
story
you can't bring in all of this machinery
he said we can it's not proust we can
have charles or we can have story but we
can't have both
that's what he would say to wilson
he also understood democracy as being
highly
partisan
and he welcomed
its partisanship and the the arguments
that would go forward during 19
the year 1940 when the war has begun in
europe but we have not yet been attacked
at pearl harbor
there is a debate going on in the senate
about the arms embargo should we or
should we not send arms weapons to
britain
and
writers of the people like uh dorothy
thompson or walter lippman are saying
we shouldn't leave such important
decisions to the politicians
the politicians are
ignorant fools the politicians don't
know what they're doing they're
bewildered
they're
captured by
private interests we should leave this
to
high-minded
experts
and
devoto argued with that he said no you
that is what democracy is you don't it
is not about
high-minded experts with white gloves
passing policies around on silver trays
it's about passionate argument and and
some of us are not as clever as others
but we are all americans and we all have
something to say and if we're going to
do it right we have to do it within
the democratic
tradition and according to the
democratic rules and he's a
firm believer
in that
thesis he's also
on almost all occasions willing to
grant
to other people
the best that is in them
and he's constantly exhorting them
to live up to their ideals to be
to do
the best that they can
i went back
prior to coming here to see what he
would have said
to read some of his remarks just prior
to
world war
ii and he has a prophetic piece in in
the september 1939
uh
issue of harper's magazine this is a
column this is the war begins on
in on september 1st 1939 this column to
make the september issue because of the
way the magazine was put together would
have would have had to have been written
uh sometime in
early summer
and so he's writing about
he takes for his subject the
pulp science fiction
uh
stories that are very much
then
on the newsstand
the pulp science fiction
the the equivalent of our
movies like let's say
mad max or independence day the movies
that
project the end of the world and are
filled with
despair and everything is is ruined and
the people from mars have either landed
or not landed and
he he
he refers to this as
besotted
nonsense the
the pulp fiction that he's describing
but then he goes on to
connect it to
the
anxiety
in the world the
you can feel the the cloud of war
looming on the horizon and the anxiety
of people in europe
knowing that something
bad was
coming in their direction from nazi
germany
he doesn't have a chance
to write about the
outbreak of war on september 1st until
the december issue
and he writes this column which is
called the oncoming
and
he's at a writer's conference
in
i assume bread loaf he's teaching
young writers and so the
scene is a very where he is
is among uh lovely trees in vermont
and
he then begins to think back
on
what it was like when war broke out
in night when the americans went
to war in 1917
and he can remember
how
romantic
it seemed to him as a young
harvard student in 1917
listening to recruiting officers
telling them that soon
they will have the boys will have to go
to france
and in his mind he plays back the
images that were
current at the time
german
ulands with
spiked helmets in dust gray coats on
horses against a
belgian
twilight
and then he reminds himself that this he
says this he says this time
it will be neither
distant nor romantic even to boys
he sees extremely clearly what they
cost of the war is likely to be
he sees that it the
what the united states will have to do
to its own democracy
to win that war
will
possibly
change the cut the nature of the country
and he also understands the kind of
sacrifice that will be demanded of
the people who fight the war
and thinking about that sacrifice he
says
he's overwhelmed by the what he calls
the suffocating ecstasy
of
patriotism
of
sacrifice and of dedication
and his humanity comes
fully
expressed in the column he says
the what does he ask himself what is the
price of a life the price of any life
is belief in a right and truth
that do not exist
conscription in a war against the
uncomprehended
for reasons never
given
he has an extremely
tough-minded
view of
himself
and of the world and the
and of what his fellow americans are
capable of and i'm sure that this comes
out of his readings of
lewis and clark of his walking of the
santa fe trail and the oregon trail and
of the
courses of the missouri river
and
in line with that
same kind of
idealism
in devoto
i i want to read two passages from
a column he wrote in april of 1944
already looking forward to the end of
the
second world war and being concerned
that
we may
lose something
of the essential american characters so
he
he starts this way he says
you may remember the lost generation
it was primarily a literary phenomenon
an invention of novelists it was a myth
cultivated because it gave fine effects
in prose
the lost generation was supposed to
consist of men whose souls had been so
maimed by the ugliness of war that they
saw quite through life's hallo sham
and women who caught the contagion
presumably as the supreme benignity of
love
the phrase itself the lost generation
was the invention of miss gertrude stein
whose art had no connection whatever
with life or death love or hate
rejoicing or grief success or failure
belief or doubt
or any other emotion of mankind any
experience of anyone or any of the
values that enable people to live
together
an art which floated freely in a medium
of pure caprice
sustained by nothing except its
awareness of its own
inner wondrousness
the
idea he says of the lost generation was
sickly and unclean
because it encouraged people
to self-pity and to make victims of
themselves and
i can just imagine what
uh devoto would have said about today's
literary pretensions in new york
it's
much of the same
criticism can be leveled at a lot of
what now
passes for
our own literature
and he says you know the waste here he
is again the waste or failure of an
individual does not mean that god had it
in for him
and no private pain in the bowels proves
that the world is evil
you can't blame it on
the world you can't blame it on somebody
else
and then he says literature would do
well to clarify its understanding
following the last war
it gave us and gave us worshipfully the
image of a hero
crying into his chin because he had seen
more than he could bear
a hero sneering at fools who tried to
make something of their lives because he
had come to understand that there is no
use in effort
and so forth and so on and he's
particularly uh insulting to ernest
hemingway in this regard who makes of
course of
the the world war one the tragedy of
impotence
and this
angers uh
devoto he can't
bear people who
give up and affect these move
poses of higher
sensibility and so forth and then he
reminds the
you know
always what saves him and brings him
back is his knowledge of american
history because he begins to think
about
the people who are coming back from
world war one and then again the people
coming back from world war ii
and that leads him to think of the
people
coming back from the civil war
so he he goes on of a man he thinks
he's listening to the elegant uh
futility of despair of the of let's say
the new york or boston intellectuals
and then he thinks in his mind of a man
making his way homeward
from appomattox
in a
ragged and stinking shoddy and without
shoes to get the field plowed
the kids fed in the shattered south
rebuilt
or making his way homeward to vermont or
iowa with the best years of his youth
devoured by war no fine thing done no
fine thing possible in a time remaining
both
the northerner and the southerner had
known lice and the fire of dysentery in
the bowels hunger and panic the private
filth and public feculence of war
both were items both had seen friends
blown to buddy bloody shreds beside them
both were items of helplessness victims
of the evil fate which twists the lives
of men
quite irresponsibly
and do they complain about it
no
not in devotees america because these
are the people
that went out and sowed the crops
repaired the bar
begot the children
served on the school board and sat with
their shoes off at the end of a hard day
they broke the prairies dug the mines
occupied the west
built the railroads
manned the industry that remade the
world
tugged the united states to the
forefront of civilization and laid up
the wealth that was later to support
literature while it found all this an
illusion
and
it's this uh
strength in the man that is is uh
really
wonderful for me to behold i mean he
he he says
that
he's always addressing himself
to
people's best ideals
and
the country is never
quite finished
it's a
and he says a number of times i think i
understood what america was once but it
was a brief glimpse of a nation that
never quite existed
it's always
just over the horizon or
it's the pacific ocean
and it's the earth that is going to be
that was poisoned and is going to be
made sweet
and it's it's uh
i i i
i get carried away talking about the
photo
but uh i i just think more people ought
to read
more of his work
he's really a uh a fine and uh
noble writer and it's a pleasure to be
here
[Music]
our next speaker is bill letter
i'm going to talk about benny the wise
benny the tough
benny the very prejudiced
benny the whimsical
and benny
a most lovable person
in 1950
i was a professional naval officer a
commander in the navy
and i became a niemann fellow based upon
having written a great many magazine
pieces at that time
devoto was enraged
he thought this was a terrible sin
because the neiman foundation had been
funded by mrs nieman
as a place for working newspaper
reporters
and i was not that
he squawked all over the place
vigorously complaining that i was a
super
con man
and i had conned my way
in some
manner to become a neiman fellow i
should not have been admitted
and
oh
i got the playback on this from he had
told professor schlesinger this he had
told wally stegner this and two or three
other of the members of the harvard
faculty indeed from conant himself told
me that devoto had complained about me
conning my way
into the demons well
hell i didn't like that
well there was a
a party one night at the curator's home
that was louis lyons
and
devoto started on scolding me there in
front of everybody as a con man
and now i got annoyed myself and i said
look devoto
in the last three years i've produced
three times as much stuff as you have
in first-class magazines
and i'm only a part-time writer
and that i had been reporting
non-fiction
in like the sad evening post in colliers
and so on
and i said now look be reasonable
bear in mind that newspapers are dying
as sources of news that people read
magazines do it much better because you
can research it slowly you can check it
you can interview people
radio is beginning to do a better job
and i said benny just look
tv in a few
years
this was in 1950
will probably be but what most people
are going to watch for news
so so what the hell am i talking about
that the reporters from radio from
television for magazines
should be encouraged to become niemann
so that their maturity what they learn
at harvard in this wonderful year
is return to all of the valuable
media
functions
at this moment
in comes the blessed louis lyons who'd
been hearing this
and said yes
benny
he did not con his way in
here it was hibs of the sad evening post
and colliers
who nominated him to be a neiman fellow
for what he had written
devoto then gave a characteristic thing
that's it's
it's a half smile a half sort of jerking
his head down like that
he put his hand on my shoulder and said
bill how about coming on sunday
afternoon to my house for some martinis
and talk
and i was
at that sunday afternoon
martini and talks every sunday almost
for the next year and it was a source of
great
joy
now then what did he dislike more than
anything else except except con man i
guess
the army corps of engineers
he used to beat his teeth on fat you
know
so
one day he said they have me licked i
can't do anything about it what should
we do
now bear in mind i was in the navy i was
in the pentagon
and i thought well if i'm a con man
let's get something done about this
so i went up to see
the head of the army corps of engineers
and says look
why don't you con devoto
so that he likes you a little bit more
and they said how do we do it
i said what's his interest area
you fly a scheduled plane every other
day from saint louis to fort peck
montana where you have your minor
headquarters
invite him to come along with a friend
and go up the missouri looking down on
it all the way to fort peck
oh they said that's easy
and so
he was invited and so was a b
guthrie
who was his friend and who also knew a
great deal about
the west in the westwood movement
so
and a guy from the corps of engineers a
young
lieutenant who i forced to read devoto's
books heli had never
read anything except a comic strips
before that
and so we all flew up
along the missouri
i remember
pointedly
at one time
betty looked down and said
my god
there is the place where the mormons
wintered
on their trek to utah
where over a third of them were lost by
freezing to death
and tears just began to dribble off of
them
well we got up to fort peck and
what's up there but the corps of
engineers had invited all of the
most of the men's clubs of that area for
you know
a meeting it was to be propaganda
and here arrived devoto and guthrie two
famous authors
and so they asked
those two to make a talk to this four or
five hundred men's group i mean men from
groups all over that area
they said they would
if i would introduce them of course i
could
so i introduced them and explained i was
nothing
in their league all i was was the
baggage boy
and some jerk says
well what does the baggage boy do
i said well
i carry devoto's trunk
he has in it a couple of hundred of his
books
and every time we stop in a village or
he gets on trolley cars and buses and
sells his books
for four bucks he'll sign it
this enraged devoto
he stole that from me and he was from
then on he was telling everybody
on this trip anyway that it was i who
sold the books
my books
all right so we got up to fort peck and
benny mentioned
that
with gratitude that the flight
up north along the missouri was
a wonderful experience
but
we went too quickly for him to really
milk the thing
and one of the engineers
said what do you suggest
and when he looked at
guthrie and guthrie looked at me
and i said why don't we float down the
missouri in a boat
can you supply one
the engineer said of course
and they supplied a big rowboat i mean
maybe about as big from here
to where mark is
with a small outboard motor on it
and some supplies
and we started floating down the
missouri river
oh you should hear these two guys like
oh that's where this happened that's
where that happened
but benny was still annoyed at me
and
nagging me a lot about
uh
this
damn thing of him selling his books and
so i had to sort of try to
pull him out of that mood
and as we're floating down here was a
grazing place along the side with a
couple of hundred
um black cows on it
i said oh benny i heard a buffalo
you are you're a dumb son of a [ __ ]
they're cows
and
so
we would stop at night you know and not
be floating at night
but they would pick where
this indian tribe had this battle here
where this happened there where that
happened there
now
and i took notes on all of this
well
we're about halfway down
and we ran aground
on a sandbar
the little outboard motor
wouldn't help any
and the voters said what are we going to
do
i said what are you going to do
you and guthrie are going to get
overboard and push this thing off
he said what right have you got to order
us why not you i said i'm the goddamn
captain of this ship get overboard
and they went
and they pushed it off now i've got
pictures of all of this stuff that i'm
mentioning
i took hundreds of pictures and maybe a
hundred pages of notes which i lent to
guthrie
for
some
thing he was having up in shoto montana
he's never returned it
well he's dead now and one of the things
i'm going to do
is when i have some time
if
is to go up to choto and if his estate
still has all of this stuff
of benny
trip down the missouri and a couple of
hundred pictures
mark
you'll have them and you can let whoever
would like to have them have them
so then
uh
when we got to the platte river
benny was just still
annoyed
at the luggage story and heaven
having to jump into the river to push
the boat off
and there were a mess of reporters there
to here are our two
famous authors and while they were
taking pictures
benny and guthrie threw me into the
water you know off the dock as their
revenge
now
i had been at bread loaf with betty
many many times
we had some common dislikes
most of them
the most powerful of them is we both
disliked poets
and
the major reason was because all of us
who were on the staff up there
had to lecture
the students
we would spend hours you know making up
a lecture of how to construct this or do
that and or get time
but these poets
their instruction was reading their damn
poems
and this annoyed us well there was one
guy up there
named oscar williams
he was an anthologist and
or may i add that both of us
like john
chiardi
one of the poets up there
but oscar williams was an anthologist
and a minor poet but he had one skill
he was a pied piper of elderly women
[Music]
and he would walk around with a group of
them maybe 15 or 20
then he would sit in the grass with his
legs in the lotus position
[Music]
and read his poems
with the ladies surrounding him
that was none of
our business except
he did this outside the lecture room
at bread loaf and there was only a
screen up because it was in the
summertime
and you could hear them talking and
mumbling
well
benny was lecturing and i was in there
listening because
every time he lectured about how to
construct something it was
a fountain of information for me
and here is
oscar out there
mumbling about 20 feet outside the
screen doors and this
noise was coming in
so benny said would you ask oscar to
move
so i went out there
and i asked him very courteously would
you move back a hundred feet because
you're disturbing the speaker
he wouldn't move
now
oscar was an
extremely religious man
i say he was
uh
never mind i won't say his religion but
he was
extraordinary religious he if he wanted
anything if he wanted a pet he'd say hey
god help me find a pen you know that
kind of a film
so
so benny got angry at me because i was
unable to move him and said do something
about it
i
i hollered out oscar
if you don't move i'm going to ask god
to punish you
and oscar the rude man gave me the
finger
well in the last week of august
in northern vermont where
brutaloff is
the weather is strange and you can have
a
storm move in
you know very easily
and because of the nature of it there is
lightning before the storm
well about two minutes later a bolt of
lightning
struck about 50 feet
from williams and his group
and benny hollowed out that's just a
preliminary
[Applause]
well they moved
and when the lecture was over
benny came to me and said
you're the god damnedest greatest con
man in the world
and thank god that you're one of my good
friends
[Applause]
[Music]
now mark devoto
in 1933 a young woman named catherine
stern wrote a fan letter to bernard
devoto discussing a short story he had
just published in the saturday evening
post
his reply initiated an exchange of
letters that continued until her death
11 years later
as the circumstances of this
correspondence have been well described
in stegner's the uneasy chair
i need do little more than mention a few
details here
kate stern had graduated with honors
from wellesley college in 1929
had worked in new york city as a
designer and as an assistant art critic
on the staff of the new york times
and was now a patient at the s and n
bound sanitarium in poughkeepsie new
york suffering from tuberculosis
in those days before modern antibiotics
and chemotherapy
treatments for tuberculosis often tended
toward the drastic and incapacitating
and kate stern's condition vary between
stable and deteriorating until she
weighed only 80 pounds when she died in
1944 at the age of 35.
not once did stern and devoto ever meet
in person as far as i am able to
determine he never even saw a photograph
of her
when devoto offered on more than one
occasion to visit her in the hospital
she discouraged him from doing so
at such a distance tacitly agreed upon
the conditions were ideal for the
friendship on paper to become all the
more personal and intense
the friendship was a principle
sustenance to kate stern's spirit
and it is no less certain that it was of
profound cathartic importance to devoto
as well
the correspondence proceeded on a
regular basis sometimes involving as
many as two or even three letters a week
with occasion occasional gaps when stern
was too ill to write or when devoto was
traveling
even then stern managed to dictate a
letter occasionally and devoto wrote
short notes from hotel rooms the letters
sometimes catching up only days or even
weeks later
the letters are a remarkable portrait of
the nineteen thirties and forties as
seen through the eyes of two thoroughly
literary people
much of the discussion is about serious
fiction and journalism
and just as much about pot boilers
politics the arts
the harvard scene in general the
cambridge scene in in particular
and especially about the personalities
they knew best
stern had a fine talent for stimulating
devoto to write about himself or indeed
about practically anything
there is evidence that the
correspondence enabled devoto after a
year of frustration that ended in his
abandoning work on a difficult novel
to start fresh on a history that would
quickly become known as one of his best
achievements that was the year of
decision 1846 published in 1943 and
dedicated to kate stern
the energy of the correspondence on both
sides
shows an intellectual and spiritual
vigor that remains undiminished over 11
years and that even today makes these
letters especially good reading
my mother always felt that the letters
should be published someday
when that would be hasn't been decided
but it seems like a good idea at the
very least to make certain that all of
those many who are sharply criticized
not to say vilified in them are no
longer living
but because the letters represent a
significant and particularly vivid
segment of devoto's creativity that has
remained almost unknown i want to share
with you this afternoon a few random
excerpts that should give you an idea of
the flavor of the whole
stern was intensely interested in
devoto's utah background
and at her request he even prepared a
historical outline of his utah boyhood
and of his family of the of the sun and
uh and six daughters on his mother's
side of the family of samuel g dye
who had emigrated from england in 1856
shortly after his conversion to the
mormon faith
devoto told stern that he often had to
remind his new england friends that
although he had been born in utah and
his mother was mormon devoto himself had
been brought up a roman catholic like
his father
here is from his letter of february 8
1934 in which he begins by discussing
his harvard students
whether as a sequel to the apostleship
of elliot
whether as a result of the natural law
which requires the bright people to be
exactly one generation behind bloomsbury
whether the society of jesus is getting
in some good licks or the new crusade
comes with the ending of the holy year
the young are feeling very romish these
days it's all very amusing to a renegade
i receive instruction most sweetly given
in sacraments and symbols of my
childhood
they who were last year quoting piaget
and the year before aristotle and the
year before that freud
are quoting aquinas now
pound yields to gerard manley hopkins
the consulting room to the confessional
yes today's champion of relativity is
now saying that a supernatural
explanation of the historical miracles
must be accepted
one hears viaticum and
transubstantiation where late one heard
transference or it may be conditioned
reflex
it is unquestionably the greatest of all
republics
and my other ancestral religion stirs
and bursts into leaf these are the
latter days
there has been no winter in the wasatch
and a saint has been summoned to
washington to save the nation
he meant mariner eccles
it is all in joseph's prophecies
there are wars and rumors of wars also
and israel has been sore afflicted and
the pestilence rides by night
so israel girds its loins and awaits the
thousand years
but whether moroni or perhaps the
blessed joseph will appear to lead the
saints to jackson county does not appear
and somehow the planet kolob has been
forgotten and if i remember my prophecy
the united order will have first to be
restored which may
cause a little trouble
for the united order is only communism
and god's vice gerund was recently
telling stalin just why antichrist could
not prevail it is i assure you once more
the greatest of republics i'd give a
paycheck to be in utah now
devoto didn't get to utah for six more
years
when he made a motor trip to the
mountain west with arthur schlesinger jr
in the summer of 1940 it was his first
visit since 1924.
when the two of them set out the german
army was overrunning france and the low
countries and devoto's morale was low
writing from jenny lake in grand teton
national park on june 15th he said
this was always the loveliest place in a
beautiful country
the matterhorn of the grand teton is
above my left shoulder and the evening
cold has come down from its snows
cottonwood creek clatters outside my
door and the hills all day long have
been masses of lupine larkspur indian
paintbrush and wild roses
teton pass is far more magnificent even
than i remembered it i took gordon up a
hillside there to play in snow 2 800
feet above the top of mount washington
or exactly level with what they're now
calling mount ogden at my birthplace
from the past down to jackson hall must
be the most spectacular vista in america
far more so than new mexico from raton
pass
i had forgotten this country kate and
now i won't
we stopped ten days ago at muddy gap
wyoming to see if there was word of the
road through south pass
muddy gap is three shacks all filling
stations where two roads cross in the
desert between sweetwater and the
badlands
a woman came out to man the pump
said she hadn't heard any news for three
days and has roosevelt declared war on
them yet
a week before that outside of trinidad
we stopped in the dark to listen to
roosevelt's fireside chat was there ever
an unlikelier name for a war message
some mexicans leaned up against the car
to listen to
when it was over and i started up the
engine one of them said i guess maybe
america declare war pretty soon now
but i put that into the easy chair i
wrote in santa fe
the rancher i talked to in teton basin
this morning said i was in the last one
and i'm ready to get into this one too
the west begins where the dead animals
on the road are not chickens or skunks
but jackrabbits
or when the state highway commission
orders you to slow down to 50 at curves
or where menus dwindle to chicken and
steak both fried
the middle west however as i may have
observed before for your education
begins where the salad is the first
course
at the time stern first wrote to him
devoto was about to begin writing his
fourth novel this had a working title of
second gentleman but it was published in
1934 as we accept with pleasure
and it may be devoto's best work of
fiction
he sent the typescript to stern for her
comments and after she made a few
suggestions he wrote to thank her in
part as follows
i have a horror of cerebralism
i trust that i can underwrite and elude
but i have the heebie-jeebies of being
deliberately obscure
which leads to my being much more
explicit and platitudinous than need be
at friday noon dale valente i'm going to
hit it up toward vermont and spend one
night listening to henderson and one
night drinking with red lewis and then
come home and try to repair my shattered
finances thanks kate
a half dozen people have read or will
read this script but i don't give a good
god damn for what any of them except you
and edith merely's think about it and
your judgment outweighs hers in my in my
sense of the desirable about four point
seven to one
whether you try to defend yourself or
not you get one of the special binding
of four copies on september 21st
thanks and once more thanks let's not
write novels
devoto's friendship and eventual rupture
with the poet robert frost has been well
chronicled by others and i won't
recapitulate it here but shortly after
the quarrel began in 1938 devoto wrote
to stern about it
frost's demon is loosed
and either a genius is breaking up or it
isn't i don't know
i still see reason to hope it isn't but
these are terrible days for people who
reverence him
he breaks down into about equal parts
willful child demanding child jealous
jealous woman and mere devil
eleanor's death has not only accelerated
a process that had already scared hell
out of me but also has removed the only
effective check to it well it can come
out two ways it can find some new
equilibrium infusion that will produce a
great work probably in prose if i read
the signs right
or it can just produce a grotesque
downfall of a great man the greatest
person of our time a mere dissolution
a distillation of envy and jealousy and
quivering ego that will deliver him
forever into the hands of his enemies
and make his friends a defensive circle
ringed around him in a hopeless effort
to keep him covered with fig leaves and
their cloaks
as early as last winter it was apparent
that he couldn't take me on the only
terms anyone will ever get a chance to
take me on or at least couldn't refrain
from trying to make his terms it's
damned funny
i'm on record over my signature with the
declaration in complete sobriety against
the whole background of the age and my
announced standards that frost is not
only the one great poet of his period
but also the finest poet in the whole
sweep of american literature
he knows that my book will be merely a
documentation and development of that
judgment and that isn't enough
he must try to woo me cajole me petition
me threaten me into absolute subjection
i must have no other poets beside him
living or dead but especially living
i must flame with all his million
grievances against the others i must
deliver over to his women control
his absolute control and his slightest
momentary whim my entire faculty of
judgment
he knows i won't and yet he is driven
practically every minute i spend with
him to make me either by thunder or by
pathetics or by personal malice or by
wild threats
so of this recent chaos which began for
me at least when he came through new
york with eleanor's ashes
of the indiscriminous vengefulness and
jealousy and compulsive bitterness i get
especially poisoned share i can take it
but by god what it's going to do to my
basic ideas is something to worry about
for many years before i knew him and
throughout all my relations with him
till now he has been important to me
primarily because his existence proved
that there was such a thing as a sane
genius
there's much more about the frost about
frost in the correspondence and i wish i
had time to read more of it here i
should mention one matter of fact that
did not get into stegner's quite
thorough account of the affair
in the summer of 1955 my father and i
went on a short trip through new
hampshire and vermont
i was 15 years old at the time
we stopped in the village of plymouth
vermont to see the grave of calvin
coolidge
and pop remarked that robert frost lived
not so many miles away do you know him i
asked somewhat amazed and of course
knowing nothing at all about any past
history
so an hour or two later we dropped in on
the farm in ripton and frost was indeed
there
the greetings were entirely friendly and
we visited for about half an hour it was
the last time they met and it wasn't
until years later when lawrence thompson
published some of the letters between
devoto and frost that i began to
appreciate what that visit must have
entailed
frost is also a part of the last segment
i'm going to read today
in 1941 devoto bought the big grey house
at 8 berkeley street in cambridge where
he lived for the rest of his life and
where my mother lived until 1971.
the house had belonged to the writer
william roscoe thayer and shared the
street with many harvard professors as
it still does
devoto remarked in his letter to stern
of september 30th 1941.
if you had any notion that cambridge is
the one place in the new england culture
that descends from the new england fiat
the property is gentility dismiss it
i am now genteel and no one doubts that
in succeeding to the possession of eight
berkeley street i have become one of the
elect
i have been called on by an amateur
cartographer and consulted about the
errors in local benchmarks
i have been
called on by a series and one which
obviously projects into the future as
far as thought can reach a female
fragilities tottering on two canes
oozing reminiscences of john fisk
soliciting my thoughts on the decay of
the clergy and most of them bearing
manuscript essays on the dread utility
of toothache which i will please get
into harpers
i have been called on by a woman who
wants me to devote my leisure hours to
making braille books for the blind poor
by one who converses with the dead
by one who wants me to extinguish the
impudence of modern young women
by one who invites me to take up morris
dancing in a berkeley street group
by one who is cognizant of a popish plot
in the white house
it is assumed god knows why that this
baptized member of the holy roman
catholic church of jesus christ of the
latter day saints belongs to the church
of england
i have been invited to join a shop club
contribute money to a fund for the
alleviation of the hardships of dogs in
england
to end forever the immorality of modern
literature and devote one-fifth to
devote one-fifth of the estate i am
assumed to have somewhere to bundles for
britain
frost has also bought a house in
cambridge
he has always been spacious in the
possession of dirt and gets more so year
by year
but in vermont he walks his boundaries
when he buys and in cambridge as i have
the best reasons to know the property
lines bend dip swoop and turn back upon
themselves one needs a lawyer and a
surveyor as well as a conveyancer
he ordered his cellar filled with coal
it began to be delivered and the truck
had difficulty getting the right angle
for its shoot
so robert ever helpful went out and
chopped down some of his hedge and had
the truck drive down between the hedge
and his neighbor's line
so if verrago was on his doorstep next
day one of the fragilities i complain
about and the lawyer wrote to him
forbidding trespass and pointing out the
law
when he beefed to me i could only tell
him that in my experience good fences
make good neighbors
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i think the three
extraordinarily
entertaining and perceptive papers
have given us all
a renewed sense of
the brilliant variety
and the
unflagging humanity
of bernard devoto
we have a few moments before
the coffee break
and i know the members of the panel will
be happy to entertain any questions
from members of the audience there is a
microphone right there
and who would like to begin
back there
if you talk loudly enough we probably
can hear
you wonder if mr laflin could tell us a
little bit about some of the riders
that if devoto were here today he would
be scoring
the question was can mr lapin tell us
about some of the riders who mr devoto
were here today he would be scorning
well i don't like to put
words in the great man's mouth i really
don't i mean it um
but
there is a kind of
weightlessness to much of
modern
fiction
that i think uh he would have thought
does not
what shares some of the wondrousness
that he assigned to
gertrude stein in other words
extremely
picturesque lovely uh
display of adjectives but
meaningless
except in terms of celebrating the
writer's own uh
magnificence
uh so
a lot of the minimalist fiction i i
think he wouldn't have had much
use for as far as some of the histories
that are being written
uh some of the popular ones uh he would
be
i think
appalled by the
uh self-promotion of the
writer i mean when somebody like an
extreme case somebody like joe mcginnis
uh sets forth to write a book about
teddy kennedy
as if he were teddy kennedy
or the kind of gossip that is uh
writer like dick morris will be paid
a large sum of money to publish in
newsweek and so on that kind of uh
sensational
um
journalism i i think he would have
regretted
and i can imagine him being very uh
scornful of uh
like i can imagine him
uh mocking
books by
bork or books by
gingrich as well as books by morris and
and clinton i mean he wouldn't have
distinguished democrat or or republican
he would have
brought down his uh fury
uh in a nonpartisan way on both sides of
the aisle
because yes he was an equal opportunity
critic
i might ask the panel
in connection with this question
whom do they remember as
those writers whom devoto particularly
admired
as i
recall
one remembers particularly its exercises
and demolition the most famous of which
was thomas wolff
thomas wilford used to deliver his
manuscripts practically in wheelbarrows
to his editor maxwell perkins who would
have to piece them together
and make a book out of them
and devoto wrote a marvelously
destructive essay comparable to mark
twain on fennimore cooper
uh about thomas wolfe which is entitled
genius is not enough
he he admired i think rather seriously i
think he admired james t farrell steve
he admired james gould cousins
now
generally forgotten writer
he admired raymond chandler he admired
g.k chesterton he admired an historian
named
guadala i believe
famously said it takes a stigma to beat
a dogma
he also distinguished between uh good
writing and good prose they didn't
necessarily have to be synonymous you it
was nice if that happened but there was
good writing that wasn't good prose but
if it achieved its purpose
then it was good writing
you see i mean he he was not
an ornate style simply for the sake of
an ornate style was was not something
likely to impress uh
devoto
mark or bill do you have further
thoughts on
whom benny admired
i might mention he uh
he was very fond of uh certain writers
in uh of of
of western fiction uh ernest haycocks
uh
he uh
bob guthrie particularly the big
surprise
right and uh
and of course he he liked stegner's
writing very much
he also edited uh some of the popular
fiction by eugene manlove rhodes uh
which uh that belongs to my father's
earlier years rather than the later ones
i know that he
uh he didn't like norman mailer's uh
the naked and the dead and i think it
was because he he couldn't couldn't get
past uh
the uh the roughness of the language
which of course now is considered uh
very mild compared to uh practically
anything that you can buy today or
compared to what benny himself would say
privately
bill do you have any thoughts on this
i was just remembering him on this guy
oscar
williams and sort of a battle
started between
devoto and me on him and devoto had a
great brainstorm
he wrote an atrocious poem you know just
junk stuff put it on the bulletin board
and said latest by oscar williams
and then underneath it said robert frost
says it is magnificent
literary life in the 1940s
another question
or comment by anyone
if no one has any further thoughts we
can have coffee or tea
we will
let me see we're right on time right on
time
we will meet again at 3 30.
good
very very
the subject will be devoted pioneer
environmentalist
there is no
theme
of benny devoto's life which is more
relevant today
than the one we're going to discuss in
the concluding session thank you
for more discussions with authors join
us this weekend for about books
on the saturday night edition professor
david whalen looks at the historical
relationship between literature and
politics
hong kong's future
and our shared conviction on the
importance of china's adherence to its
commitments under the nineteen eighty
four
agreement
washington journal continues
louis lapham if somebody picks up this
brand new july issue of harper's
magazine what will they read that the
state of the world is in
they'll have a very good time reading
this issue this is an exceptionally
fine issue i think there's a piece
about bird watching which will tell them
how to look at the world and how to put
more of themselves
into the world
and it's although it's about a grieb and
a snipe and an owl
it is really about
how to look at the world and draw
meaning from it
rather than to simply criticize it's an
extraordinarily fine piece of writing
now why would you do this
why would i read this why would i yeah
why did that strike your fancy
the writer's name is uh david duncan and
he happens to be a brilliant writer he
talks about
um
coming across a grieve on a beach in
oregon he lives in oregon and the beach
has been wrecked by a storm and it's
also been wrecked by the logging
industry and
they're birds that are covered with oil
and so on and he finds a greed
who seems to him to be in great shape i
mean it's staring at him out of these
two burning fierce eyes
and his long experience has taught him
that
if the if he's that close to the grief
something's wrong with the grave
so he doesn't do anything about it
except grieve
and
be concerned about what's happening to
the environment what's happening to
oregon what's happening to birds he's a
lifelong
watcher of birds
and then
several months later he hears from a
friend who knows more about birds and he
does that all the grieve needed was to
be taken back to the water all he had to
do was pick it up and walk it a hundred
yards because the greed wouldn't need
the
the uh
the flat surface of the water to get in
the air
and this convinces him that he made a
mistake
so after that
he
he then understands that in order to see
the world properly it's what you you
have inside your own head and he
compares vision to
the surgical procedures where they put
those
scopes
inside your
brain or inside your
lung or something and it's the inner
light that allows the
surgeon to perform the operation
so the next time he comes across a bird
it's in the middle of a highway he's
again in oregon and he sees an owl in
the middle of a highway
and there's a lot of traffic coming and
going it's dark
and he jumps out of his truck
risks his life runs back
and gets the owl and gets it up out of
the traffic and so
he feels that
he's even and he feels a sense of
redemption
and he feels a way of approaching the
world
knowing that
as much
pain as the world
involves so also it involves a great an
equal amount of love and if he can
balance them
uh
he can learn to see more clearly and
it's extraordinary but he writes very
beautifully i'm not doing this justice
because i'm turning this into
mediocre prose but but this man writes
with with great uh
feeling and accuracy and you have a
notebook
here your own here and the first uh name
in the notebook besides richard pryor
who says who you're going to believe me
or your lying eyes
i love that line
why did you use that by the way
well because that's a line uh in a movie
that pryor made and he's in bed with
another woman his wife walks in and in
order to
excuse his presence he says who are you
going to believe me or your lying eyes
and it's
it works for the piece because the piece
is about
false ideas and about believing that
words can substitute for things you
mentioned right away though fuzzy zeller
why was
fuzzy zeller is a professional golfer
and at the masters tournament in april
he made he was trying to make a joke
about tiger woods tiger woods is
probably the most famous golfer in the
world at the moment
part asian part black and and zeller
made a remark about fried chicken and
collard greens which was
uh
he meant it as a joke it was a witless
joke poor taste and so forth and the
next
or two days later
when this
was broadcast on cnn a clip of this
remark
his sponsor kmart
decided that he was no longer fit
company for the lawn mowers and couldn't
be seen standing around in a kmart
anymore and so he was
expelled into the unsponsored wilderness
and
a lot of columnists both in new york and
in washington wrote
small sermons condemning cellar and but
what was curious about all of this was
the way in which the
the word was confused with the deed in
other words because he'd said something
offensive
it was almost as if
he was responsible for the
racial injustice in the united states in
other words it's if we
the idea that if we don't use
uh
certain words then the condition that
those words
describe will vanish
and it's like
saying
over and over and over again we can
balance the budget i mean there's no way
in my lifetime that the
ballot the budget will ever be balanced
nor do i believe that it should be
but it's a kind of magical chant the
sacred budget chant that goes on in
washington or it's like saying that
somehow we're going to be able to
win the drug war
which we will never win because you
can't
suppress the human
desire for
intoxicants drugs happens to be one of
them
nevertheless we will continue to mumble
these
these magic words and and we do tend to
do the same thing with
our political correctness whether on the
left or on the right if we don't use the
word
then all will be well
we're going to go to the phones and we
have our guests here for the next 25
minutes and we were reading some of the
harper's index items earlier and i want
to drop down to a couple of
past the the hong kong ones number of
months before hiring bob dole last may
that a dc law firm represented its first
tobacco company
for
a number of weeks after being hired that
dole announced he would loan new gamers
300 thousand dollars to pay his ethics
fine to
number of u.s law firms involved in
tobacco suits 530 percentage of american
smokers who say that tobacco companies
are to blame for smoke related illnesses
13. percentage of americans who never
smoked who say this 22 uh did you know
that this decision was going to be uh
culminated on the friday this whole
thing
well we assumed i mean one of the
tricks of editing a monthly magazine is
to be able to
guess
because this
a month or six weeks ahead of time what
is likely to show up in the news and we
assumed that by now if not this week
then next
the tobacco settlement would be working
its way into the front page now
george mitchell mitchell is a member of
the same law firm that bob dole is why
didn't you pick on him
i think because dole was more well-known
more re also because we could make the
comp uh the juxtaposition with gingrich
it was not mitchell who lent gingrich
the
money to get himself off the hook louis
lapa editor of harper's magazine born in
san francisco lives in new york city
went to yale and cambridge in great
britain and has a phone call from great
falls virginia good morning
good morning
i would like to know when gene lyons is
going to be appearing in your magazine i
always enjoy his articles and i like to
take note the fact that the new york
times or the washington post
never
reviewed his book fools for scandal and
i was wondering if there's that of guilt
because of so many mistakes that were
made in writing about white water or um
you know just they choose to ignore
you know gene line's book which i
thought was very informative and i
really enjoyed it thanks who is gene
lyons gene lions is a contributing
editor to harper's magazine who lives in
arkansas in little rock and
wrote a first along piece in the
magazine and then a book suggesting that
there was much less to the white water
scandal than
has been supposed in other words
congress has spent
more time in hearings on whitewater than
on than on the combined
watergate in iran contra and yet we
still have no
we still can't prove nobody can yet
prove the
essential charge which is that
clinton prostituted his office as
governor of uh
arkansas to his own cane and
lyons in his book
shows up the new york times and the
washington post for the
maritricious
reporting which pretends to have
discovered
a syllogism but in fact there's no
middle in the syllogism
and when the book came out it was
ignored
by
almost the entire mainstream press there
was a small review in the sunday new
york times book review which
uh dismissed the book as
nonsense and not to be considered
seriously kingsport tennessee go ahead
please yes brian i want to clear
something up that about uh
tiger woods and fuzzy zeller the reason
the only reason that fuzzy said that the
in augusta the winner of the august at
augusta chooses the menu they have a big
dinner the night after the
uh after the match and the winner
chooses the menu and he was teasing they
had swedish italian whoever won their
ethnic they chose an ethnic
uh menu well he didn't think anything
that's a menu from the south and fuzzy
just did not
mean anything but that has never been
brought out
in uh
in anything that i've read or heard i
bring it out in my in in the uh column
to which brian referred i i know that
and i set up the premise of the
essay
on that understanding in other words it
was a
zeller's remark was perfectly within a
convention i mean
the joke was a little heavy-handed but
it was about a menu and the menu was
relevant
to the circumstance marietta georgia
you're next thank you you're on the air
yes sir uh when we call into c-span
a lot of times we're asked if we're
republican or democrat or other
well i'm another and i never hear what
you fellas are the first question i have
to ask you is what party do you hail
from there sir
and the second question is you said that
there is uh more time spent on white
watergate than there was on watergate
uh but don't you attribute some of this
time spent to the actual cooperation
that the clinton administration is not
giving the investigators
as compared to the cooperation that
nixon's group
gave to the investigators if you know
what i mean thanks let me ask you first
though what do you think just give 30
seconds of what you think of bill
clinton before you answer that
just the presidency in general the man
in specifics
well
i think he's he's more like a talk show
host in other words i think he's a man
who seeks to please everybody i mean
like a
there's a certain
bewildered adolescence about clinton and
uh
smiles always wants uh
to be
liked uh at least this is
and and therefore not decisive i don't
think i mean i think he means well
but i also think he hasn't controlled
his uh appetites for
hard women or soft money or
scoundrels of one kind or good or bad
president
i would say uh
average president i don't think he's
particularly bad president i think he's
a particularly good president what about
our caller's point that
the resistance on the part of the
clinton administration is prolonged this
investigation well the resistance of the
reagan administration of the iran contra
was equally
severe
nixon tried to claim executive privilege
i mean we're a little further along
along in time than we were
say 15 or 30 years ago when presidents
could
hold off this kind of investigation more
easily because the office of the
presidency was held in higher regard
one of the things that that clinton has
managed to do is to
he embodies the general sense of
feeling that washington is full of
scoundrels in other words he downgrades
the office of the presidency by his uh i
think by his behavior and by his
presence people
knew this about him when i mean they
knew about his connections to
whitewater and to paula jones and to
various chinese arms dealers when they
elected him last question if you were
out there calling in
would you use the republican the
democrat or the other line
i would have used the other line i voted
i'm 62 years old and i voted for both
democrats and republicans as president
miami beach florida go ahead please good
morning i'd just like to point out to mr
latham that fuzzy zeller did apologize
to tiger woods and they hadn't lunch and
father jealous still has a nationwide
weekly television program on saturday
morning just an outdoor program fishing
and hunting it's a very good program and
one of the sponsors is kmart
okay okay good morning
thank you
i'm glad to hear that i mean
can i go back just a moment before i
take another call to this harper's index
thing uh by the way who does it
charis khan is the name of our editor in
charge of it and we have
various assistants and interns and we
have stringers who send us
numbers and
so forth and so on
i mean i think for example like in the
newspaper the other day we saw a number
that the united states spends 500
million dollars a year on golf balls
to bring back fuzzy zeller and tiger
woods which strikes me as a very large
number so if we
we'll have that number and then we will
try to find some
comparable number
what does it spend on
some government good work and will give
us a balance of the proportions
ratio of californians who vote to
legalize medical marijuana last year to
those who voted for bill clinton 21 to
20.
yeah i mean i think they're more
it's fairly splits fairly even it's
talking about
permissiveness it's a
understanding of
human nature i mean it seems to me that
people who vote for clinton for
president are willing to forgive the
frailties of the flesh percentage chance
since 1990
in minutes of network news devoted to
stories broadcast from foreign bureaus
59
minus that's true i mean minus 15 yeah
the
american
part of that is the costs of maintaining
foreign bureaus because as the big news
media operations
come together
they tend to downsize and cut certain
costs and one of the things to get rid
of is the foreign bureau why are they
spending millions of dollars on the hong
kong story then
it's drama red china it's uh easy to get
to i think americans care
about hong kong yeah probably not that
much harper's uh magazine publishes a
great many
um
letters and stories from abroad there
isn't one in this issue but ordinarily
well yes there is there's there's a
piece about spain
and
very seldom
do these kinds of articles and stories
draw
mail
invitations to appear on television they
don't cause much excitement there's a
there's a sort of
an american sense that everything of
importance is happening here and not
there let's go to uh hackens
hackettstown new jersey good morning
good morning dale how are you wonderful
show thanks uh i'd like to
comment mr lampam you had mentioned
about the buddy zola fiasco whatever you
want to call it you did leave out about
the dinner part that woman beat me to
the punch she pulled up and mentioned
that that's something you did leave out
and i know not in the piece though i
didn't i'm sorry
you didn't you didn't you left it out in
your conversation i don't know if it's
intentional i don't think it was but
that was very important to mention about
the dinners that the individuals have
based on their heritage or what have you
and that was left out and i'm glad the
lady
uh did call on that it's not left out in
the magazine i left in the magazine but
you left it out there on the show
that was very important and when that
woman called up and that's exactly what
i was going to say so it was all in jazz
but that's you know either here or there
but i wish something neil would like to
mention one thing to you mr lam
somebody did call up very irate and i
can't blame them when you have these
politicians on the programs that's why i
like c-span
uh they don't give answers i think an
answer should be demanded from them
otherwise this show just leaves leaves
nothing for me
they go around and around they never
answer the question i think the answer
should be demanded when they're asked a
question
that they answer the question do you
think if you sat if i sat here and said
i demand you answer that question that
would make a difference look i'm not
going to put it in that terms i'm not
saying hey i demand it but would you
please answer the question you know you
haven't answered the question melissa
would like to know the question she
answered please give her an answer
that's all all right let's take a
harper's index what do you think the
chances are that if you did that it
would change anything
well if we don't do anything i mean how
will we know just say i'm not arguing
with you i'm trying to be a little bit
humorous and failing at the moment would
you like to bail me out of this one
well
it seems to me that one of the great
arts of being a politician is not
answering the question it's it's
somewhat like the art of being a lawyer
and you can take it to a certain
um
point and then after that you have to
leave it to the intelligent reader or
the intelligent viewer to know that the
question is not being answered which is
itself a kind of an answer by the way
there's a building being blown up here
on your cover what is that
that is the sands hotel in or what was
the sands hotel in las vegas which was
demolished last
fall
and this is an extraordinarily fine
piece this is another one of the reasons
this magazine this particular issue is
so good because this writer is a man
named david samuels
accompanies the family of uh dynamiters
it's called demon demolitions inc and
it's a it's a family the wazzo family
from maryland
and it is their business to bring down
structures and over the last 40-odd
years they've
blown up seven
thousand buildings or bridges or
former missile sites
every conceivable kind of structure and
how it is done is an art form you to
drop a building
accurately
in the
time allowed and space
allotted
is a very
complicated art and science and
samuel's accompanies the lozo family on
its
mission to destroy the sands hotel which
was a very famous hotel it was
identified with las vegas in the in the
50s let me ask our caller did you happen
to see the sands hotel when it was uh
when it was raised
uh no i didn't but i saw it when it was
blown up
well that's really what i meant i mean
you were there watching this yes sir in
fact i was in three movies that used the
blow-ups of the uh
the three hotels that they blew up
recently what does it feel like to stand
there and watch a hotel that's been
there for how many years you've been in
las vegas i've been here seven years now
yeah that that sans had been there i
mean i think first time i went there
years ago yeah the 50s it was i think
the it was associated with
frank sinatra and jack kennedy and and
the mafia and the very earliest uh
glamour
of the desert what's uh your call about
this morning in las vegas yeah i want to
add another ism to him that he had
earlier like
they'll never win the drug war there'll
never be a balanced budget in my
lifetime
there'll also never be a stop to gaming
here we've got the commission
presidential commission that's looking
at gaming
and it's already under fire here
quite a bit
i don't know if this is so local that i
think it was in the major news though
of the little girl that was killed down
in prim
casino which is on the border of
california nevada when you first come
into nevada
and this uh representative wolf who
helped set up the commission
uh was saying that the father of that
little girl
wouldn't be too willing a vet a witness
on the
hearings
but
they forgot to put in what happened
there in that case
the father gambled all night and the
security people brought the little
daughter to him three different times
to get her out of that arcade that she
was in
where she was eventually killed so
see they don't they don't say that
security was there and doing its job
they make it look like the little girl
got killed because of the gaming all
right thanks
well he's right about gambling i mean
the
again the
hope of suppressing certain human
instincts by law is usually
thwarted
so it would be like prohibition i mean
another thing would be
drinking would be very difficult to
ban
successfully other things in your july
issue here is a painting called bang by
a
gentleman named carrie marshall carrie
james marshall
yeah what's this this painting what does
it mean it says we are one down here
it says happy fourth of july
see three uh children here with an
american flag what's the point
i think it's because the children here
are black and it's a
they are
saying we are one people and
looking in a very traditional way so i'm
guessing
that the intention here is ironic
i'm not sure
i'm not an art critic but it
i assume that that was the
motive of the artist across the page you
have a little box and it says tracy the
essential dick morris the following
summary of the first chapter behind the
oval office by dick morris was generated
by auto summarize a feature of
microsoft's word 97 software
i won't go on but what is the plan it's
very brief i mean show the whole the box
has just one paragraph in it well it's
just a number of times that morris is is
hitching his wagon to clinton's star as
it were in other words it
it's a statistical breakdown of
morris as the remora or pilot fish that
that
swims on the uh
back of of of clinton and and how
uh
abject his uh
dependence was on his presence in the
oval office it's just a
data summary of that
spirit
next friday at this time uh in our
program john o'sullivan of the
national review will be here dayton ohio
your next go ahead please
yes um
brian i have a surprise for you because
i have three good celebrity solutions
to three troublesome issues she said
she'd give me special permission this
time to go ahead my first one is
what exactly did gingrich do
that's a violation of the tax laws is
how the question has been going and you
never get the answer that way you get
the answer by changing the question to
what gingrich did not do he did not
spend a dime or a dollar on the little
children it's a lincoln fund for
children and immediately we see how
the words of gingrich have tricked us
and you knews men haven't picked up with
the fact that it's a violation of law to
have the nation give a tax-exempt fund
and the money go for any good idea
that's in gingrich's head but not a
dollar going to the children's fund
what's next on your list violation of
glories have i made it clear yes thanks
do you agree with her
i don't know about the
children's fund i don't know a specific
issue but i don't think that gingrich
has tricked the press because
seldom have i seen an american in the
recent american political history the
uh rise and fall of a reputation as at
as steep an angle as as gingrich's i
mean two years ago he was the hero of
the people
and uh
now he is
seen as a
prevaricator i would think i don't i
don't think the press has been careless
about that i just got this but uh it's
from phil smith in atlanta georgia
concord coalition member your guest
remarks are shocking if we do not
balance the budget and do not have
entitlement reform our economic future
is grave more deficits mean higher
interest rates and less savings no
entitlement reform endangers the
retirement of generation x and
my future
it's got an article here by alan
fram of the associated press boom could
devour deficits economic optimists
suggest
well i can't think of any government
that's operated for very long with a
balanced budget because any more than
you could operate most businesses or
most families i mean it's uh
to
equate the
revenues of the expenditures is uh
would be extremely i don't think you run
a large corporation that way louis
lapham's time is running out here on
this morning's program let's go to
portland oregon go ahead please
yes i find that
i would like to ask you just a minute
of an animal in the background or
something
go ahead
i what i would like to ask
is what would have happened
had the democrats been honest about
their
presentation of their uh
their brother instead of saying that
everything was being cheated by the for
the agent and the children and if they
had realized that it was there was
always a
just a plus on the republican side
instead of
not the amount that they were saying
thanks
i have to leave that one to you brian i
don't think i unders i fully understand
what the woman was which brings to mind
just one quick question do you follow
what goes on here closely or i mean the
magazine as you know becomes detached
because of the time
lag and all that kind of stuff
i tell you something i watch c-span a
great deal that's not i don't mean that
as a as a flattery i i find it it's the
best way to
get a sense of what is going on here
i find it in and so i i'm something of a
addict
what's the this is from vocations a
series of paintings by stephen scholler
oh this is a wonderful to face it's
american vocations and it comes in the
middle of a piece uh
where it comes toward the end of a piece
by jerry spence
the defense lawyer who's talking about
the profession of being a defense lawyer
in a democracy
and what that entails and how difficult
that sometimes is if the prosecution is
going to
come into court uh telling lies let's
take a final call dallas texas good
morning
good morning uh mr lam mr lammy want to
congratulate you
on the extreme fairness of your programs
thanks we try but uh don't always get
there i think you do
i have one question for mr lapham
and two
comments to you
that mr la lapham uh
related that story by the man from
oregon about putting his life in
jeopardy
in order to rescue now
and that he felt redemption
did it ever occurred to him that he was
endangering every vehicle what was going
on for the taiwan
it occurred to him and and uh but it
occurred to him while he was in the
middle of his uh action
but he acted instinctively
and it did occur to him but by that time
he committed himself to the
race and
against the clock to get the owl out of
the way of the truck so
that was not something you'd do anything
about how's this magazine doing
the magazine's doing well i mean the
circulation is
small by
big-time media standards it's 216 000
but the uh
the renewal rate is high
i mean it uh
the people that like it like it a lot
thanks for coming in this morning thank
you please come back and join us i will
lou lapham harper's magazine editor from
1983 to the present he also had a stint
back there in 1976 to 1981. appreciate
you joining us and appreciate you uh
in the audience calling in and faxing
have a good day
ideas as well as what other traditions
have to say about those questions
washington journal continues
lou lapham's in new york and paul
weirich here in our studios this morning
for the newspaper roundtable and both
our guests picked this story on the
front page of today's new york times tv
stretches limits of taste to little
outcry mr weirich why did you pick that
well i think that
it in fact points up something that is
really happening in the culture
i heard paul harvey the other day
commenting on the fact that jerry
springer had a bigger audience now than
oprah by sizable margin
and he asked the question
is it them or us
and i think the fact that this piece
points out
that
all of the
mores which
used to
inhibit
the television production
uh have been officiated
uh indicates that uh in fact the problem
is with our culture we become more and
more
tolerant
of uh any sort of depiction
of deviancy and as senator moynihan
suggested we are defining deviancy down
mr lampam what's your take on the same
story
well i would agree with that i i
i'm not so sure when we ever had as high
as standard as
paul weirich would hope for but i mean
what he says i think is true what
moynihan says is true the the trouble
the question is
what if anything can you do about it
well there is somebody that wants to do
something about it and in this same
article it says it tomorrow at the
annual convention of the national
association of broadcasters in las vegas
senator joseph i lieberman of
connecticut democrat and william bennett
the conservative republican commentator
and lobbyists plan to speak out as they
did two years ago to condemn sexually
lured talk shows
then there's a quote here the jerry
springer show in particular
they will urge station owners to drop
the jerry springer show in particular
and to adopt a voluntary code of conduct
what's your reaction to that mr well i
think it's the right way to go i don't
think that
we can impose these things by government
that has never worked
but
the industry used to have a certain
standard they themselves had a code
and they had
people who enforce the code
voluntarily and today anybody puts on
anything they want
this same piece says uh and with
interviews with parents around the
country last week uh suggested that many
families are not as acutely distressed
about television vulgarity as mr
lieberman and mr benadar what do you say
about that mr lapham
well i i think more people are
distressed about this than uh
one might think
uh i'm not so sure that's true i think
there are a lot of people that are
distressed about this
so what would you do about it
well you would i i i don't see i agree
with mr warwick i don't see how you can
impose it by government you can only
uh
hope
that the
broadcasters would
try and raise their sights that would
mean of course
cutting into their
profits but
i'm not even sure whether that works i
mean i
c-span has a successful audience it
depends
uh
what reason you're in the uh the
business for by the way the leader of
the national association of broadcasters
is on the cover of broadcasting in
campbell magazine and where he's holding
up a sign that says that the industry
tab for public service is 6.8 billion
dollars they figured out some way to add
it all up and that's how much they give
back to the society
well uh
that's only a small amount of money
compared to the gross national product
if you will of the television industry
but
that isn't really the issue
the issue is
what do we tolerate
in our homes
and uh i'm not so sure
that uh mr lapham is correct that more
people are concerned about this
uh i wish they were but i think that uh
if the clinton scandal has taught us
anything
it's that uh as long as the country is
prosperous
the public will tolerate almost any
behavior
mr lapin we've got your harper's
magazine here for april and there's an
article by orville shell
uh there's a story about hitler's couch
and unapproved minutes a story by tom
payne what's that about
that's a story about a town meeting it's
it's fiction it's a short story about a
town meeting in
new england where
the discussion is
about a lawsuit
against a power company that has
perhaps
caused because of its the radiation
emanating from its tower has caused
cancer in the town it's an entertaining
um
fiction
about some of the problems of democracy
mister what else did you look at in the
papers this morning well there's a lead
editorial on the washington post
which suggests that newt gingrich's idea
of having a commission
which would go into every congressional
district and talk about the different
options for social security is not a
good idea
that in fact we should just
stick with the status quo and do what
the the president
is recommending i disagree with this
i'm not so sure that the speaker's idea
is necessarily the only way to go
because there are a number
of options that have been introduced in
legislation now which could be acted
upon but in any case
it is correct that we need a national
dialogue on this for example the latest
data shows that in the black community
black males really get ripped off by
social security because they pay in over
a long period of time those that are
employed
and
they die at a much earlier age than
other members of society we need to take
a look at
at least partial privatization of social
security the president doesn't want to
touch that speaker gingrich wants to
move in that direction i think the
speaker is ultimately correct
we're going to take some calls and our
guest louis lapham is at our
50 rock 50 rockefeller
the
studio up there in new york city this
morning and paul weirich is here in our
studios normally mr wiry can be seen
every evening on this program called
direct line and is that still six
o'clock five o'clock five o'clock in the
afternoon east coast time repeat it to
11. on america's voice which can be seen
on the satellite and some cable systems
around the united states let's go to
parkersburg west virginia first up go
ahead please you're on the air on our
democratic line
well yes i wanted to discuss this
article in the parkersburg news nazi
propaganda final
find home in u.s media
it was written by thomas soule i think
it is
and he said if the lie is big enough and
told often enough and loud enough is
believed by most people and this was a
tactic used by hitler and globally
during the second world war
and it seems to me that since i've been
watching the smiths about the president
that some of the republican pundits
have been using a little if
a little alleged and they gone into a
spill about
all the charges that the president is
charged with and as if it was fact not
that it's alleged but when they're
called on it they say well i started my
paragraph with if or it's alleged that
he done these things what do you think
mr laflin about that
well i think that the
clinton has been pursued for a long time
by people trying to
assign to him
crimes and misdemeanors that have yet to
be proved so
whether it's i nazi propaganda is coming
at a little strong i think but the uh
there certainly has been an element of
attempting to
cast clinton
in a way that is convenient to his
enemies
here is a spread in time magazine this
week um and it's called day of
deliverance this is the opening spread
and the reason i show that is because
the i want to read this paragraph to
both of you who watch the media this is
by peter baker in today's
washington post he said that clinton
took the opportunity of a time interview
to deliver his message came as no
surprise to white house observers
clinton and the white house have been
furious that the magazine's main
competitor newsweek for its aggressive
coverage of the jones case and have
signaled they intended to retaliate is
this a good retaliation where they have
a
exclusive interview that they gave uh
time magazine mr warwick well other
public officials have tried it
the
reagan white house had a policy of
giving stories for example to the
washington times before it
gave them to the washington post
the nixon white house had a similar
policy
um you know that's uh their prerogative
as far as i'm concerned they can deal
with whom they wish
and mr lam what do you think of our
caller's point about uh nazi propaganda
in the thomas soul column
well i think it's so extreme but there
um
that there have been attempts to
manipulate the public opinion on both
sides i mean there are a lot of what
passes for our
journalism particularly our political
journalism on both the left and the
right
it could be defined as propaganda well
it
i think the point the caller was trying
to make
uh is is really not valid the fact is
that mr clinton's behavior
has caused these problems i mean not all
of these people invented these things
maybe somebody was out to target him
i can't say one way or the other but
where there is smoke there is some fire
and clearly over a long period of time
mr clinton has had
difficulties due to his own behavior not
some political opponents trying to make
something of him because were that the
case then uh political opponents would
have done the same thing with reagan or
bush or other people we'll come back to
mr lappm in just a moment atlanta
georgia go ahead please good morning hi
you had a call earlier this morning my
blood pressure is about 10 million over
19 million a woman from los angeles
called about a new york times article
saturday by jeff durf
and it was apparently in 1996
china set up a satellite missile or
tried to and exploded
and two american companies loral
and hughes aircraft sent over man of
material and technology to make sure
this didn't happen again
there are two grand juries and panel to
see if
nuclear secrets weren't transferred you
know on purpose or not on purpose
and somehow bill clinton got a hold of
it and
it's a very long article but it's it's a
deeply offensive to me and this is this
was on thanks for calling because it was
uh totally confused by the time we got
through with the whole thing because she
didn't have the article in front of her
uh and why why is it offensive to you
well i mean
it apparently the transfer of
information would make a quote satellite
missile into a nuclear missile and that
means it could go to brentwood
and the loral is
chief executive officer is a guy named
mr schwartz and he's give a million
dollars or so to the democrat national
committee in the last year and a half
he's the biggest contributor that got my
attention thanks mr latman you follow
this i didn't follow the story but there
is an international market in technology
that can be
weapons satellites various kinds of
materials i mean these these substances
are traded
there are markets for them i didn't read
the jeff girth story in the times on
saturday this uh administration has bent
over backwards
to accommodate china they ignore the
human rights abuses there they ignore
other problems they ignore the fact
that china may well have the capacity to
be our number one problem in the coming
century
and
whatever is good for
business particularly businesses that
have been favorable to this
administration
is permitted there and i don't think
that we can as a nation afford to ignore
china as a
coming a potential enemy lewis lampam
and paul weirich our guest erlinger
kentucky go ahead please uh yes my
question concerns this article on the
cincinnati inquirer about the spelling
says security mess and i would have
liked gotten in on your last segment but
i didn't make it but i'd like to hear
what each of these gentlemen got to say
the number one myths are
the fact that no one born in the united
states is required to have a social
security number
or participate if they have one and how
come this has never put out the public
mr lapham a view on social security
i don't i don't have a view on certain
security and i i tend to think the
system is is not as
badly damaged as
some other people think
we have a
piece coming up in the
magazine in a month's time by robert
reich who is the former
uh
clinton official and a
fellow at harvard who is arguing that
the
social security fund is is
more uh is we are better off than we are
sometimes led to believe
thanks let me ask before we take our
next call mr weirich about the article
we talked about here a couple weeks ago
it was on the front page of a monday
morning new york times i think it was it
was all about a meeting that you all had
over at your office just a couple blocks
from here
to uh what possibly started a third
party or to no back a candidate no there
was no uh
no sentiment for a third party
what uh
there was sentiment four was the
creation
of an independent political force
the social
issue conservatives pro-family people
have operated within the republican
party and there is a real sense that
we have become
the uh sort of
blacks of the of the democratic party uh
trotted out at election time but uh not
really taken seriously
when people try to govern
and
so the effort is going to be made to
put people together so that they can
operate with one voice
and make themselves felt and
i suspect that
we will attempt to
support certain candidates and oppose
other candidates
as individuals but nevertheless trying
to speak with one voice there's a piece
in the today's new york times drama
errors which talks about the number of
times people have already been to iowa
top of the list is
robert c smith of new hampshire 21 times
he's been to iowa senator uh republican
is he the kind of guy you could support
oh sure i could support him uh i don't
know that uh
ultimately he will be a serious
candidate he is talking though about
becoming a favorite son in new hampshire
this is something that has never been
done up there
and he is sort of violating new
hampshire protocol by
trying to put himself
on the ballot
because traditionally
new hampshire has has not
done that and so we'll see where he goes
austell georgia we'll throw this one up
to lou lapham go ahead please hi brian
how are you morning
i haven't talked to you for a long long
time remember i used to call you from
long island new york sounds like a
familiar voice what's on your mind this
morning well i have a couple of things
uh first of all in my paper here in
arsdell
it's uh there's an editorial that says
that what
what they need to do what the government
needs to do is rewrite
the sexual harassment laws okay there
are loads and loads of people who are
very upset
that this
court case was thrown out
and they don't totally understand or
agree with the way
[Music]
the law applies itself to sexual
harassment in the workplace first of all
paula paula jones wasn't harassed in her
workplace she came up to a hotel room
which i don't know what she was doing
there but anyway she went up to his
hotel room and supposedly he made a pass
at her which
doesn't meet the the smell test for
sexual harassment under the two
standards that's the one thing the
second thing is um all of these women
coming out of the woodwork
alleging that he did or did not have sex
kiss them groped them molested them or
whatever it is he can't defend himself
against all these women
some of it may be true and some of it
may not be true
um
when when you have a president who is
muzzled by the law until these people
bring a case against him what is he
going to do thanks mr lampam
well i think that's an interesting
question and it attaches to a couple of
other things in the conversation where
we started with the the question of
taste and what you can put on television
and then mr weyrich's uh
political party that presumably i at
least as i remember the article is his
the one voice that he's talking about is
a
moral voice or a voice that is trying to
imp put or
imbue politics with some sort of ethical
or possibly religious component so
there's a it seems to me there's a
confusion in all of these three
instances as to what
politics can do and what
morality can do and where is the
connection between
cultural behavior and political
action i don't think there um
the sexual harassment laws are very good
laws i think you're trying to
the impulse is to try to make
law
serve a
cultural
or ethical cause that it can't be made
to serve
and
similar variation to that same
difficulty is the one as to
how do you get broadcasters to
put
shows on the air that are intelligent
and in good taste
or in mr weyrich's case i assume how do
you get
politicians to
promote
ethical
or religious principles in a
secular context or environment paul
weirich your reaction
well i think the the questions that
he raises are exactly the right ones
the fact of the matter is that we often
confuse what is legal and what is moral
just because bill clinton may have acted
legally in all of these cases doesn't
mean that he acted morally what i think
we are looking for is moral leadership
people who in fact
although we are all sinners
at least want to hold themselves and the
rest of the country to a higher standard
rather than trying to
get to the lowest possible common
denominator that's tolerable
as far as
what can be done in law it is very
difficult
to
impose
legal sanctions
on moral behavior
but
we had in this country a good deal of of
moral behavior because individuals
themselves believed in it
and through their own associations
through their churches through their
schools through other mediating
institutions enforced it upon themselves
it was enforced in in the neighborhood
when i grew up
uh you know
people looked out
for what kind of behavior there was on
the part of of neighbors and so on and
you know today of course
people are lucky if they know anybody
that lives in their neighborhood
chairman of black entertainment
television bob johnson who went on the
africa trip with the president will be
with us in about 15 minutes grenada
hills california you're on with paul
weirich and lou lapham what's on your
mind i have the
article from the paper on this china
missile probe and the first two
paragraphs of this article explain
exactly what the two people that called
in before
were trying to get across please read it
a federal grand jury is investigating
whether two u.s companies
illegally gave china space expertise
that significantly advanced beijing's
ballistic missile program according to
clinton administration assist officials
but the officials said the criminal
inquiry was built a serious blow two
months ago when president clinton
quietly approved the export to china of
similar know-how by one of the companies
under investigation
the decision was
opposed by the justice department
officials who argued that it would be
much more difficult to prosecute the
companies if the government gave its
blessings to the deal why did this story
get your attention
because it infuriated me so to think
that he would quietly do this on the
side when a government agency is already
investigating tell me uh who wrote that
piece so we can be clear from the
washington times from the washington
times in
uh our saturday uh daily news los
angeles daily newspaper is there a
byline on it no okay thanks any reaction
to either of our guests from either of
our guests mr lapham well
one could have our american policy tends
to favor
um
business deals and
and or
uh authoritarian regimes i mean we were
selling advanced weaponry to iraq under
during the bush administration we were
it's both republican and democrat the
carter administration was selling
advanced weaponry to iran and to
dictators of various
uh degrees of authority
not very nice people
so
and it's hard for the justice department
to
restrict uh trade
again on
grounds of what are perceived to be
national interests i mean you're
this is a
part of what is called the global
economy
well but
at some point or another
this country has to
look at national security
this administration has no view on
national security
and uh you know we had for a long time
the soviet empire there were great
restrictions on it
it is our contention
that china is a potential enemy and you
know we're not making this up out of
whole cloth their military people talk
about a conflict with the united states
in 2005. i mean it's right out of their
military journals so you know at some
point we have to take a look at whether
or not we are arming them
and making them capable of defeating us
clarksburg west virginia go ahead please
yes i have a question for the two
gentlemen
um
since president clinton and the
vice president gore get on there and
every time they're in a tight spot
they start quoting scripture
and since they are mixed up in the new
age movement i don't really feel that
they know that much about the bible if
they did
the united states would recognize
jerusalem as the capital of israel
and when i see them on their talking
about like i saw al gore on c-span
speaking to a jewish group
claiming what friends the white house
was of israel well if you're friends
with israel you do not
urge them to give up land that was given
to them by god
so i would like to know why the news
media that's including the television
and the newspapers and the magazines
do not inform the american people
that everything global importance is
what israel is right now
the scripture plainly states
those nations that bless israel will be
blessed those that don't
uh will be cursed so this is going to
put the united states right down the
tubes thanks mr lapham what's your
reaction to this
well the media television newspapers
magazines and so on are secular
institutions by and large and
tend to be skeptical about
god's
foreign policy decisions vis-a-vis
whether it's
israel or
iraq or iran or the soviet union or
china mr weirich
well uh some of us would contend that
that is not a proper interpretation
of the scriptures because
uh the israel that is referred to in the
scriptures the new israel
is in fact a reference to christianity
not to the state of israel which
you know is a
created through a political act
so
many of the fundamentalist protestants
interpret scripture that way
as a greek catholic i interpret it a
different way and therefore i do not
feel
the obligation
to
recognize uh jerusalem as the capital of
israel on scriptural grounds there may
be other reasons to do that but
certainly not on scriptural grounds but
as to the point originally made
i think that mr clinton and mr gore
would do well
to take a scriptural study course
because
i have
found a number of instances where they
have outright misquoted the scriptures
now it's one thing to have one
interpretation you know and you have a
different interpretation fine but you
know at least
get the quotes correct and uh they don't
do that on c-span's washington journal
rochester new york for little apple and
paul weirich you're next
yes i just wanted to respond to a
previous comment probably about five ten
minutes ago regarding uh the moral
leadership and and that sort of thing
what i find most frightening about this
comment is just showing this whole
concept
that
our leaders need to uh it almost sounds
like mr mr royce's comment is is our
morality needs to be legislated for us
and that's something i find very
frightening and i know i do this too
thinking back oh the good old days and
we knew our neighbors and that sort of
thing
you know there's that's really a
double-edged sword i grew up in a small
town and in some ways you can say your
neighbors look out for you but then
i i think it can be you can have
artificial boundaries put on you mr
wyrick what do you think of that well uh
the point is that legislation follows
consensus in the country not the other
way around if we try to legislate
morality and there isn't morality in the
country it wouldn't work even if you
could get it past the legislature the
point that i'm trying to make is that we
need
people in public life who themselves
have standards who will uphold those
standards and will commend them to the
rest of the country and we don't have
that right now by the way mr lapham on
the in the usa today they have a story
about a guy named keith olbermann who
hosts the program on msnbc called
the big show
and it says that he's kicked his ratings
up over this whole lewinsky clinton
story from 80 000 a night to 219 000 a
night and somewhere i noticed i thought
i noticed that your circulation for
harpers was 9 219 000. that's right are
we right on target there yeah that's
right so what does this all say to both
of you that uh
the msnbc audience has 219 000 at night
at 8 o'clock
and a magazine like harper says 219 000
and i don't know what you're do you have
ratings paul weirich at your operation
well i mean
i'm sorry go ahead well we we have an
individual cities we don't have a
national rating go ahead mr lapin
well we assume that the
overman's ratings will go back down
after the lewinsky uh
proceedings are over with i mean you
can't a magazine like harper's magazine
it doesn't compete with
the mass media i mean we don't we don't
go that way we we
go the way that mr
weyrich would uh approve of which is
not to hustle the latest
supermarket scandal and and there there
is a real audience in the united states
for
that kind of
thought that kind of writing that kind
of approach just as there is a real
audience for c-span i mean
yes you can always attract a crowd with
a spectacle people will stop and look at
automobile accidents but the
um that that is not uh
particular i don't
so what would be my reaction to the uh
ratings coming up on the uh for the man
on msnbc mr warwick uh what have you
been talking about on your show what i
mean have you talked much about the
clinton scandals or the alleged clinton
scandals uh we have but mainly in the
context of how it affects public policy
in other words
what
how does this translate to
inaction by the congress or the
paralysis at the white house on certain
matters because they are preoccupied
with with these things uh you know we
don't get into the lurid aspects of it
columbia south carolina go ahead please
good morning all right i have a copy of
a tape to train and james trafficking
made concerning this uh missiles to
china
and he said that about three years ago
china sent things i mean
consent
information to china with the promises
they wouldn't sell it to iran but they
did anyway two years uh the next year
they did the same thing with the promise
he wouldn't sell it to
iran but they still sold it this year he
wants to send nuclear
technology to
china and he's sure they mean it this
time they won't
send the information to iran and yet he
won't let us build defense
of
things to protect us
from any missiles they sent over here
now the lady has a very good point
this administration
has opposed a very minimal and
inexpensive
missile system which would
protect us from
the kind of rogue states which now have
missile technology
it wouldn't protect us from you know a
huge attack from
russia or china or someplace like that
but if iraq
fired off some sort of missile
we would be protected we're not
protected right now most americans think
we are we're not
the congress has advanced minimal
proposals in this regard the
administration opposes them next calls
for you go ahead miss lapin well i still
i i don't see where the missile attacks
are coming from i mean the best of my
knowledge neither china nor the soviet
union or iraq nor any
so-called rogue state has the
capacity to send
the kind of
missiles that we were concerned with
during the
long night of the cold war i would be
much more concerned about
weapons being brought in in suitcases or
biological weapons i'd be more concerned
about
the sale of the occasional nuclear
weapon on the part of let us say the
soviets who still have many
thousands of warheads
to
a terrorist organization or to a
a country that would be capable of
delivering the weapon in a truck rather
than an intercontinental ballistic
missile
i would also be much more i would not
want to press the
nato alliance up against
the soviet union i would
think that would be a
i think that is a
foolishness on the part of the clinton
administration that is
potentially more destructive than
its
trade with china chicago we agree on
that point chicago you're next
yes good morning
um i want to refer back to a couple of
articles i've read
that i tried to get in on one was
about
president clinton's pastor at the church
in
washington
and he discussed the problem of
clinton's morality or the conception of
it and said that there is more to
morality than sexual morality you're on
you're calling on the democratic line is
that right yes
and
the other article i want to refer to is
the one
that was in the um
newsweek last week by
samuelson
who said
that he thinks mr clinton
is hanging in there because
the people don't want to be disturbed
i think there's another aspect i think
they recognize overkill when they see it
and i think they are rejecting
this series of things that have come up
since the first day
of his administration when that dirty
old republican
goldwater said why don't they get off
this president's back and let this young
man do what he was elected to go back to
your comment about the minister and do
you agree with that that uh
that there's more to
morals and sexual relationships indeed i
do i think caring for the welfare of
other people i think the idea that you
don't bear false witness against your
neighbor and i think there are many
aspects of morality that have been
overlooked in previous administrations
thanks mr mark well of course there's
more to morality than sexual morality
but uh i think one would be hard-pressed
to make the case that
on any level this president has been a
moral leader
mr lapin
uh i would agree with that i think i
mean he he's to me more like a uh
an entertainer
rather than a
he i've never thought of him as a
particularly admirable fellow i mean as
or or a setting of an example that would
be
one that i would wish to
either follow or encourage in
in somebody else we go go back to the
woman who was wondering
about legislating
morality and
i i think it's done by
example not by
precept and i
mr clinton's example has not been one of
uh
in my view of especially uh
admirable
figure let me go ask you about a couple
of photographs in today's magazines
here's time magazine's diana walker a
photograph of the president
uh can you see that little apple yeah
and then there's another photograph that
comes out of the gory island visit right
here if we can get a closer shot of it
what uh what's your reaction to that mr
wirk these shots of the president is in
the first lady
well you know
who is to judge
there are many who believe that this is
a marriage of convenience and that they
pose for such pictures i have talked to
some
former secret service agents who guarded
these people who say that in private
they are
very vicious with one another you know i
don't know
uh if
she is able to show him affection under
these circumstances i suppose that in
some ways it's admirable mr lampam well
i don't know either i mean it's uh
but again i think it's awesome
it's off the point i mean the uh
politics is in in many ways a
presentation of a set of images and
any
all kinds of images can be presented i i
and i very hard not knowing
the individuals or not knowing the
circumstances to make a judgment on the
basis simply of an image
port deposit maryland you're next on the
republican line good morning brian
morning
i'm calling uh to speak to mr wyrick
he's right here
and uh
i had three points to make
the first one is that
if if there's a enemies list like nixon
had you'd be in the top ten
because you you mix uh you you have uh
logic
and common sense you mix truths together
which will never work in dc
and
i see you smiling but it's true
and the other thing is
when you talk about china you're right
there's a there's an unloaded gun
pointing at us
and we're giving them bullets
and on social security you're also right
do you you you and brian and uh forget
the other man's name i'm sorry mr lapham
mr lapham okay
you know when you're in your 20s and uh
if the social security wasn't taken out
of your paycheck and it was in your hand
you're not going to put it the bank
and that's what scares me today because
when the money's in your hand you're not
going to save it when you were 20 years
old i'm 55. when you were when i was 20
years old
you saved 10 of your income that was
rule of thumb
try it now you can't do it
so if you if you trust the the
the working people to save the money
they're not going to save it mr lam well
go ahead mr mark well i i think that uh
any privatization
scheme
for social security would have to
presume
that the government would mandate the
savings on the part of the individual i
mean if it were purely voluntary which
you know in the
ultimate scheme of things i would prefer
but if it were purely voluntary
the gentleman's quite right people
wouldn't do it so i think uh whatever
kind of formula is finally agreed upon
will have to presume that the government
tells the individual that so much of
your paycheck is going to be put aside
uh but instead of just putting it into
the government treasury
it would be put into a sort of
individual retirement account lou lappam
in new york why did this story on the
front page of the new york times excuse
me by sarah rimer
about
a a up in residence for older people out
in california called sunset hall
get your attention the headline is
leftist causes keep an old age home
active and they talk about a library
that has books on marxism trotsky mao
and the rosenberg's trial as well the
complete works of shakespeare there is a
framed certificate from the american
civil liberties union honoring sunset
hall's tradition of activism on a wall
and a picture of paul robeson on another
and on a shelf a bust of linen
well i wasn't so interested in the in
the in the political overtones as i was
in the
notion that as one gets older
ideas become more interesting history
becomes more interesting the uh
the
curve that we were talking about and
again it's the
that story was placed right next to the
one about
cultural taste on television on page one
of the times and in one instance we're
talking about people in their teens
which is where the
uh
the stuff that
that both paul iraq and i
object to on television
the south park shows and so on
are aimed at people in their late teens
and very early twenties
and
as people get older their their uh
i think their intelligence tends to
improve
rather than deteriorate and
they get more and the older we get the
more you agree with that right yeah
it's a self-serving point of view i
admit it but i mean it also seems to me
to be
so from what i can tell of an audience
for books or for history
uh
ideas i mean a lot of what we see on
television becomes
unbearable because it's not very uh
it's boring
as one gets older and one's judgment and
knowledge improves and so i was just
matching those two stories on the
front page of the times and in terms of
the
ages of the
uh
the audiences in both instances blue
lapham paul wyrick we go to west palm
beach florida good morning
good morning perhaps i can clear up the
uh
subject on the uh
on the laurel
missile deal it harkens back to both the
main thing that the new york times
article was that
the
pentagon had had said that the this deal
should not go through and it was under
investigation in the justice department
and the the point they were making was
that the president laurel is the largest
or has been in the last two election
cycles the largest single personal donor
to the democratic party now it harkens
back to a incident which happened just
after
clinton's election in 92 i believe it
was 93 94.
a deal was made with the chinese to buy
an entire airline
airplane production line from mcdonnell
douglas in st louis
part of the deal was the
uh production line which was a huge
thing they had to take it off and two
railroad trains
included
a device called a number of devices
called a five-headed milling machine
which is a computer-operated very
sophisticated milling machine which
makes these very
precise military parts
essentially
essential to making nose cones and high
technology aircraft parts this is sold
to the chinese against
against the
recommendation of the pentagon
ostensibly to be a
militar to be a civilian
airline production line
located in shanghai
unfortunately when it got to china it
didn't go to shanghai it went to a
military
aircraft plant someplace in central
china the chinese immediately said oh no
there's been a mistake here we won't use
this to make military parts we're going
to we're going to convert that airline
assembly point to making uh civilian
airliners and so forth and so on well
there's been no indication whatsoever
and it's come up once or twice in the
past
the pentagon through spies or satellites
one thing another is saying that you
know the production line is still at
this military complex in central china
and they're still making military planes
uh and the chinese continue to insist no
no we're gonna make we're going to make
civilian airliners and so forth and so
on and again there's been no indication
whatsoever and i guess it goes back to
the dictum you know if you don't learn
the lessons of history you're doomed to
make them
again and it appears that the we're
going to do the same thing again or may
already have done it in selling
the the missile components or the
the guidance components on this this new
deal with laurel thanks um
for the comment well i think the
gentleman is right on the money mr
lapham
again i
i don't see that the danger
coming
as as imminent from china as
some other people do and i remember that
in 1986 or 87 after the challenger
our
space
shuttle blew up
that
both gte and att had we're sending
satellites into space and the
we had no rockets going and so they had
to
put those satellites on a on a soviet
rocket we still had the evil empire
at that point the cold war was still in
progress
and the
people from ge or att came down to talk
before the senate foreign relations
committee which was very upset with them
for violating national security
and the two companies said well look
it's
we're sorry about national security but
this is uh
business and unless
this is about money this is real and
unless we put the satellites on the
russian rocket we will lose the business
to the french who have their own rocket
going and so on so
again you're
addressing
a problem of
that
that is like many of the questions we've
been talking about today which is how to
uh
run
politics with some sort of
moral element might be interesting for
the eyes you often wonder how this show
works this whole story on china was
brought up by caller the sixth caller of
the morning back in the seven to seven
thirty hour and we've just watched the
audience all through the last two hours
bring it up bring more to the table read
the article find the articles in the
other newspapers and that's a
good indication this morning uh you may
not like the story particularly but how
the whole program is supposed to work
and then we go to boston you're next oh
brian i've been trying to get through to
you for the last three months
and i'm very shocked that i'm getting
true i live in boston massachusetts
and i am very very upset that they
balance the budget on the backs of the
taxpayers
why don't they if they want to balance
the budget why don't they
cut foreign aid by two percent
and raise the the the the
food and closing electrical appliances
come from other countries
and raise the taxes by uh
transportation by five percent
that the the goods that have come to
this country and putting millions and
millions of people out of work out of
this country no
even if the tired [ __ ] and shoes you are
wearing a probably coming from china or
korea well why don't we stop the st
raise the taxes by five percent the
foreign foreign goods that have come to
this country all right caller thanks mr
it's interesting
the perception out there is that foreign
aid is a huge percentage of the budget
in point of fact it is about 14 billion
dollars out of a 1.7 trillion dollar
budget so if we cut foreign aid by 2 we
wouldn't be cutting very much
the
question of tariffs
is one which is very interesting
politically because it joins together
uh certain elements of the
conservative community
that favor high tariffs pat buchanan
being a splendid example
with labor unions which generally favor
high tariffs and opposing
high tariffs are certain conservatives
free free-market conservatives as well
as certain liberals so it that that
issue has cross-currents in both
political parties this is a total
non-sequitur i want to show you some
videotape from saturday night because
the program is almost to an end and we
want to have you get a chance to see a
different kind of a moment in one of our
guest lives let's roll
mr lapham why did you participate in
that
uh it's an entertaining sketch
i thought did they pay you
uh yeah
lots of money no
no not lots of money and i i i
agreed to do it before i even knew that
i was going to get paid
lexington kentucky for lou lappam and
paul wiry go ahead please yes good
morning brian hi um i uh have i believe
a solution to the um
things that are on television that are
so
uh
well just so uh
immoral um if there were a number to the
sponsor you would believe how hard it is
to fund the sponsors numbers if they had
a number directly to sponsor and someone
called buick or chevy or ford and said
i'll never buy your product again if you
have these
uh immoral programs of these uh
homosexual
agendas on there i believe it could be
cleaned up very quickly the other thing
i would like let me just ask you though
why not just not buy the product
well that does not send the message
always to the sponsor if they know
that's why you are
um
not buying the product then that's a
different thing you don't think they
know every
every time those
those cars don't sell as much why
they're not selling as much no they they
i don't believe they do but i believe if
if we call and tell them then they will
know the other thing is i wonder why we
haven't heard anything about
the 400 000 united nations troops in our
national parks i have read it a year ago
in a kentucky paper i have heard it uh
from an article from california 400 000
troops yes uh the first article uh was
in kentucky said three hundred thousand
the second one and one of the people who
said it was our head of all u.s military
chaplains at the time colonel ammerman i
don't know if he is that now do you
really think there are 300 000 or 400
000 troops in our national park sorry i
do because i've heard things a different
um art and that we are not a lot that's
because why the uh
national parks some of them were closed
in some of our military bases there are
only about 350 of those sites in the
country that'd be about a thousand
to help me on my my math a thousand uh
troops in each park where they hiding
them in these parks
sir i know that that if colonel ammerman
uh states this he is really probably
sticking his neck out to begin with and
uh i have seen two uh people or her two
people say in different parts of the
country totally about the massive
equipment like say tanks and all coming
through with no u.s insignia on them now
i realize we may be just buying some of
those but this thing about the troops
has been going around for some time and
yet national television isn't saying
anything about it mr weirich i think has
an answer for you well they're not
saying a thing about it because it isn't
true
it is true that we are training
lots of troops around the country from
different nations and some of them are
u.n troops and some people confuse that
with uh with with this sort of thing but
uh
members of the
both the senate and house armed services
committees now national security
committee
have
queried
the
federal authorities at the pentagon
about these reports
and uh there there simply is no truth
uh to that but there is truth to the
idea that we are training lots and lots
of people
from uh different nations and whether or
not that's a good idea i think is uh is
open to question mr lapland 400 000
troops in those national parks do you
believe it no i don't believe that i
think that's a
paranoid fantasy and but the
the other point is that we have always
been training uh troops from abroad i
mean the american military's i can
remember
uh writing a long piece about the
american military establishment in the
60s
and we have a program of training troops
from at various
bases and in various disciplines we've
been doing that for a long time here's a
picture of bob johnson in this week's
newsweek he's the black entertainment
television's chairman he's just back
from africa with president clinton and
he will be here with us in about 10
minutes chicago illinois for paul
weirich and lou lapham go ahead please
i just want to make a quick comment um
just say that i for one really getting
tired of hearing about the clinton
sexual excapades i'm not a huge clinton
supporter but um
i'm just kind of tired of it and sick of
it yes he's the president there are some
moral standards but
i think it's a bit hypocritical to
suggest that prior presidents
haven't had sexual um encounters in the
white house and that we as americans you
know are perfect and there's this moral
rule thanks caller mr mark how long do
you think this will go on
well i think it'll go on so long as bill
clinton provides ammunition i mean if
his behavior would be modified i don't
think that you'd have much of a story mr
latman how about you
i i agree with that i also think the
story
i would hope the story would die
as quickly as possible but i mean
and i think there are a lot of people in
the country would like it to great falls
virginia you're next yes uh mr weirich i
was watching your program i kind of
monitor it once in a while for some of
the fallacies that you put on your
program and you and your co-host last
week a caller called in with regard to a
the driver of the car
that found documents in the tr in the uh
the trunk of the car
and you intimated and i think falsely as
proven by a article in today's
washington post that the man did die of
an accident you and your co-host
intimated that the president had him
done in you've done that a number of
times if it wasn't for the president it
was an ordinary person they could sue
you for liable and your broadcasting
station so sir you should be very
cautious about what you say because
you're not supposed to be a judge of
everybody judge yourself sir and that's
immoral thanks
well i simply pointed out that
uh that gentleman makes like
29 people
that in some way or another were able to
testify
against bill clinton in one aspect of
the
uh whitewater case or other aspects of
the investigations have been going on
who have turned up dead i'd made no
allegation that the president was
responsible for this but it is a fact
and it is unusual because
there have been other cases against
other presidents for example nobody can
point to
people turning up dead in the watergate
case against nixon and yet he had an
enemies list and everything else so i
was simply pointing that out and it
happens to be a demonstrable fact mr
lapham any comment on this
no i haven't been following this
story because
but if it comes out of the white water
investigations
to me there
can a star found nothing of interest in
in a series of hearings that lasted
longer
than the watergate
and iran-contra hearings combined
so if you cast the net broadly enough as
mr star apparently did into
sectors of experienced behavior alleged
fraud and so on where there is no
evidence that
anything was
amiss then
i guess you can
find a number of
uh people who have died leesville
louisiana last call for paul weirich and
lou lapham go ahead sir yes mr norman
believes you i have two short questions
i'd like to ask them one of them is was
this case with paula jones was that a
federal case yes
okay then why did the judge use a
state statute for throwing it out
i don't know i haven't read the legal
opinion but she's a federal judge
excuse me the the case was
filed
under a civil rights statute because the
sexual harassment
statute which is a state statute
had expired in terms of
the the limitation on when the case
could be filed and so when they ended up
filing it they filed it under federal
uh civil rights uh statutes until happen
any final comment on all this
pleasure talking to you brian
what's the leads article in your in your
may issue of harpers
it's a conversation by
uh william greider and a man named
gartner who is the
uh
president or the
the head of the yale school of
management
on the question of the global economy
and on
how does the
uh
how does that market work
and what are its dangers and what are
its uh benefits and lou lapham is a
graduate of yale back in 1952 i got that
you're right there uh 56 56 well
somebody's about to get you here in the
little document i've got and paul
weirich is here in our studios he's a
native of racing wisconsin and has been
president of the free congress research
and education foundation since 1977 has
his own program every night at five
o'clock on america's voice which you can
find on satellite and on cable systems
around the country thank you both for
joining us thank you and as we said
earlier here's the
here's the newsweek piece in which it
says in business as in politics it helps
to have friends in the in the right
places when uh hillary clinton
introduced bob johnson to the first lady
of ghana during bill clinton's recent
trip to africa the ceo of black
entertainment television was ready with
his pitch quote i figured i would tell
her about the economy and why i had come
to africa with the president says mr
johnson we'll talk to him about this in
just a moment
[Music]
two created by the cable television
industry
offered you as a public service by your
local cable television operator
the year 2000 marks the 150th
anniversary of harper's magazine to
commemorate the event harper's published
the anthology an american album
it's comprised of past articles from the
magazine written by such individuals as
pearl buck theodore roosevelt and leon
trotsky
up next the magazine's editor louis
lapham talks about the history of the
magazine and the evolution of american
writers the event is an hour and fifteen
minutes
good evening
thank you for coming out tonight my name
is samantha hamlin
and on behalf of ellie bay book company
and the washington center for the book
i'd like to thank you for coming to see
louis lapham tonight
he is here with his book an american
album 150 years of harper's magazine
a magazine for which he has been the
editor for almost 20 almost 25 years now
before he um takes any questions we will
have richard gray he's a local actor
here he's going to read a short story by
mark twain for us
after which
lewis lapin will give us some history on
the magazine
and take any questions you have if you
do have questions if you can please go
to the back of the room
and come up the side aisle to the
microphone so that we can all hear the
question
and after that at the back of the room
we will be selling lewis's books and
he'll be signing and talking to you so
please join me in giving a warm welcome
to lewis lapin thank you
[Music]
well i'm not lewis lapham
uh
this is extracts from adam's diary
translated from the original by mark
twain harper's magazine 1901.
monday
this new creature with the long hair is
a good deal in the way
it's always hanging around and following
me about i don't like this i am not used
to company i wish it would stay with the
other animals
tuesday
been examining the great waterfall
it is the finest thing on the estate i
think
the new creature calls it niagara falls
why i'm sure i do not know says it looks
like niagara falls
that is not a reason it is mere
waywardness and imbecility
i get no chance to name anything myself
the new creature names everything that
comes along before i can get in a
protest and always that same pretext is
offered it looks like the thing
there is the dodo for instance
says the moment one looks at it one sees
at a glance that it looks like a dodo
you will have to keep that name no doubt
dodo it looks no more like a dodo than i
do
wednesday
built me a shelter against the rain
but could not have it to myself in peace
the new creature intruded
when i tried to put it out it shed water
out of the holes it looks with and wiped
it away with the back of its paws and
made a noise such as some of the other
animals make when they are in distress
i wish it would not talk
it's always talking
friday
the naming goes recklessly on in spite
of anything i can do i had a very good
name for the estate and it was musical
and pretty
garden of eden
privately i continue to call it that
but not any longer publicly the new
creature says it is all woods and rocks
and scenery and therefore has no
resemblance to a garden says it looks
like a park
and does not look like anything but a
park consequently without consulting me
it has been new named niagara falls park
and already there is a sign up keep off
the grass
my life is not as happy as it was
monday
the new creature says its name is eve
that's all right i have no objections
say it is to call it eve when i want it
to come and it says it is not an it it
is a she
this is probably doubtful yet it is all
one to me what she is were nothing to me
if she would but go by herself and not
talk
she told me she was made out of a rib
taken from my body
this is at least doubtful if not more
than that
i have not missed a rib
tuesday
she is taken up with a snake now
the other animals are glad for she was
always experimenting with them and
bothering them
i am glad because the snake talks and
this enables me to get a rest
friday
she says the snake advises her to try
the fruit of that tree and says the
result will be a great and fine and
noble education
i told her there would be another result
too
it would introduce death into the world
i advised her to keep away from the tree
she said she wouldn't
i foresee trouble
wednesday
i escaped that friday night and rode a
horse all night as fast as he could go
hoping to get clear out of the park and
hide in some other country before the
trouble should begin
but it was not to be
about an hour after sunup i was riding
through a flowery plain where thousands
of animals were grazing slumbering or
playing with each other
all of a sudden they broke into a
tempest of frightful noises and in one
moment the plane was in a frantic
commotion and every beast was destroying
his neighbor
i knew what it meant
eve had eaten that fruit
and death was come into the world
the tigers ate my horse and they would
have eaten me if i had stayed which i
didn't but went away in much haste
i found this place outside the park and
was fairly comfortable for a few days
but she has found me out
found me out and has named the place
tonawanda
says it looks like that
in fact i was not sorry she came for
there are but meager pickings here and
she brought some of those apples i was
obliged to eat them i was so hungry it
was against my principles but i find
that principles have no real force
except when one is well-fed
she came curtained in boughs and bunches
of leaves and when i asked her what she
meant by such nonsense and snatched them
away and threw them down she tittered
and blushed
i'd never seen a person titter and blush
before and
to me it seemed unbecoming and idiotic
she said i would soon know how it was
myself
this was correct
hungry as i was i laid down the apple
half-eaten and we crept down to where
the wild beast battle had been and
collected some skins and i made her
patch together a couple of suits proper
for public occasions
they are uncomfortable it is true but
stylish and that is the main point about
clothes
i find she is a good deal of a companion
i see i should be lonesome and depressed
without her now that i have lost my
property
next year
we have named it kane
she caught it while i was up country
trapping on the north shore of the erie
it resembles us in some ways and may be
a relation that's what she thinks but
this is an error in my judgment
the difference in size warrants the
conclusion that it is a different and
new kind of animal a fish perhaps
though when i put it in the water to see
it sank and she plunged in and snatched
it out before there was opportunity for
the experiment to determine the matter
i still think it's a fish
sometimes she carries the fish in her
arms half the night when it complains
at such times the water comes out of the
places in her face that she looks out of
and she pats the fish on the back and
makes soft sounds with her mouth to
soothe it
and betrays sorrow and solicitude
in a hundred ways
i have never seen her do like this with
any other fish and it troubles me
greatly
wednesday
it isn't a fish
[Applause]
twain is a
truly wonderful writer that that in my
view the best and greatest of the
american writers
and that
piece that richard read so well comes
out of this
album the
the anthology of harper's magazine over
the last
150 years
and it is
it's paired there's a diary first
written in the voice of adam and then
comes the diary written in the voice of
eve
and the two of them together are a
grand lesson in the
different points of view between the two
genders the um
twain was a constant contributor to the
magazine in the late 19th and early
20th century
he was a great friend of
william dean howells who
in between 1900 and 1920
was the dean of american
literature
great critic also
the inventor of the realistic form of
the american novel
and wrote for the magazine
the
column that was then called the easy
chair for
the 20 years between 1900 and 1920
twain also appeared
a year or so before this piece
was published which was 1901
in a debate in um
madison square garden
the spanish-american war
had been fought in 1898 the americans
were occupying the philippine
islands and
twain was the
president or the chairman of what was
called the
anti-imperialist league
and was very much against the american
occupation of the philippines
and many of his arguments were
not only similar to but identical with
the arguments against the vietnam war in
the 1960s
and he at this point in his life he's
close to 80 years old
and the debate in madison square garden
is with the
champion of
imperialism
who was then
the author of the book that was the
best-selling book in the united states
in 1900
and that was winston churchill who was
then
22 years old
and the book was about his adventures in
the boer war
in south africa
and i
i
know that this debate existed and i i
know it
took place and i've
i'm still trying to find a complete
transcript because i like the idea
of twain
at one end of his life churchill at
what end of his life and between the two
of them you can get all the way from the
1850s
on the
mississippi river to the battle of
britain in
1904
and i get much the same
feeling of
connection when i read back through the
back issues of harper's magazine i got
it's like a lesson in
american history it's also a lesson in
continuity
the
same kinds of themes
keep coming up in different tones of
voice different
forms of prose style
but the
american
quarrel with providence
is
played it's a theme and variations
this the magazine is the oldest
uh of the national american magazines
it was founded in 1850
by
four
brothers the harper brothers
they were irishmen
who had rode
across the east river
in 1819
and founded a publishing house called
harper
brothers
the first book they published was
the letters of
the roman philosopher and playwright
seneca and they published it in latin
by 1850 their publishing house was the
largest publishing house in the world
bigger than anything in
england or france or
germany
and they started the magazine
to take up downtime
on the presses
and also
to
attract
new writers
and all and to
serialize and promote and advertise
their forthcoming
books it was a
they had nothing literary in mind it was
a
commercial
venture
and for their first editor they
appointed a man named henry
raymond
and i
in
putting together this this
anthology
i not only read around in the back
issues of the
magazine but i
researched the life of henry raymond who
has got to be one of the most
extraordinary
figures in the history of american
journalism he was
30
years old in 1850
and he had already
in the 1840s
been the assistant editor to horace
greeley greeley founded the new york
tribune in 1941.
i'm sorry 1841 but raymond wrote most of
them of the tribune really
was a man who liked to make speeches and
advance various causes he was something
of an eccentric
raymond was the man who
edited and wrote the paper
in 1850 he becomes the editor of
harper's magazine
in 1851 he
found
the new york times he's the first
editor of the new york times and he was
the first owner of the new york times
so
and he is editing
the
the times the newspaper at the same time
that he is editing the magazine
and then in 1853
he's elected to the assembly
in albany
and becomes the
speaker of the
the house in albany
and the
magazine is
sending manuscripts
up the hudson river by steamboat to be
edited by
candlelight after raymond has finished
with the day's
political
sleight of hand
and
so
now we have him in albany we have him
editing both the paper and the magazine
and then in 1850
he
gave up the magazine devoted more of his
time to the paper
but in 1856
rights the
founding document of the republican
party
the republican party
is invented in 1856 in pittsburgh
and this first candidate is john charles
fremont
known as the great pathfinder the man
who had
come west with kit carson in the 1840s
and wrote the
book about the oregon trail that
prompted um
much of the westward
migration in the united states in the
late 1840s and early 50s
and the
slogan of the party in 1856 was
free men free soil
fremont
and
raymond
was the man who
wrote the
new principles of the republican party
and also
wrote much of the campaign
rhetoric for fremont
in the 1860s
raymond becomes
he's very friendly with lincoln and all
through the
war
the new york times is the
only one of the eastern papers that
stays
with lincoln
throughout the whole
civil war and there is a
voluminous correspondence between
raymond
and
lincoln which is
i haven't
had
a chance to read
very much of it but
what i've seen is a
very
candid and
direct conversation between the two men
they liked each other
and had
many of the same views with regard to
slavery and and the union
raymond was also a fine reporter
and found himself in
he'd gone down to washington
early in the ward to see
what was the shape of the
union
cause
and by accident he he was there on the
day of the
the battle of the first bull run
and
ends up in a carriage
in the middle of the battle
and writes a 10 000 word
account of that battle for the times
writes it with a pen
in about three hours and uh
it's again it's it's it's a brilliant
this find a piece of journalism as i've
ever come across
so
raymond died in 1870
presumably in the arms of an actress in
new york a very famous actress his wife
and four children were in paris
he was last seen on his way to
i can't remember the name of the
restaurant or hotel but the
the most
upscale
restaurant
bistro new york at the time
and his
body was brought home by two men and
cloaks at two o'clock in the morning
without comment so
but it was a
short
happy and extraordinarily productive
life
harper's magazine then
comes
in 1869
the
editor
is a man named henry mills alden
alden
was direct descendant of the john alden
speak for yourself
john miles standish
that
alden
and he he was the editor of the magazine
from 18 1869
the
first year of the grant administration
until 1919
the last year of the wilson found
administration so that's an
extraordinary
50 years alden was interested in
fiction
the magazine in the late part of the
19th century was publishing the
short story the american short story
which was beginning to become
a
dominant form
stories by edith warden by henry james
by stephen crane
and
olin was a poet
and a classical scholar
very courteous man by all accounts
and
didn't
believe in
bringing too many
unpleasantnesses
to the attention of the readers of
harvest magazine so that in
world war one breaks out in 1914 but the
readers of harper's magazine wouldn't
know that until
1915 it was a year before the
alden could bring himself to
concede at least in print that there was
a war going on in europe
in the
alden died in 1919 and he was succeeded
by a man named wells
who
completely changed the
tone of the magazine
much less fiction
more
essay
writings by
argument
by
will durant bertrand russell people of
that
turn of mind
and whereas the magazine up until the
up through alden's
term had been heavily illustrated with
drawings or paintings by frederick
remington and winslow homer
after
1920 it becomes all
print becomes
about
argument a political
turn of mind
and in the 30s
it falls into the the editor of the
famous editor in the 30s a man named
frederick lewis allen
who said that the magazine was
interested
in the
kind of reader and the kind of writer
who was
to use his words
unrecognized
unor
unorganized unorthodox and unterrified
and he had
he liked the the first person singular
he didn't like to publish
pieces by
public relations people of any kind or
journalists
or public relations people masquerading
as journalists
or
policy positions from high government
officials but he he liked and trusted
the
singular narrative voice the voice of
the
writer who could say
what he or she had
seen thought felt
heard
an existential
point of view
the
writer of the easy chair at the the
magazine's leading column
in the 30s was a man named bernard
devoto who's a great friend of allen's
devoto in my view is an extraordinarily
fine
american writer who's not
well enough remembered today i don't
think but i i i read his he wrote the
column for 20 years between 1935 and
1955
and they're truly um
extraordinary i think the devoto was a
westerner he came from
utah
and
wrote
a book but
to my mind his most famous book is one
called 1846
year of decision which is about the
westward movement across the
plains he also wrote several other books
of western history including the course
of empire
he
rediscovered
mark twain
in the
late 20s early 30s when twain had fallen
completely out of favor with new york
literary opinion
devoto published
twain's posthumous
writings
which took him about 15 years to argue
out of the control of twain's daughter
twain in the latter part of his life
became increasingly acerbic
and melancholy and his writing became
very
dark
and his
daughter didn't want this
side of of her father to be seen in
in print
devoto recovered
those manuscripts which some of which
are extraordinarily fine
and then wrote a life of twain an
appreciation of twain
devoto was always at odds with the best
literary opinion in new york
so
he was
had a continuing argument with the
literary establishment which shows up
in his his columns over a period of 20
years they're a joy to read
he was also a
fervent
environmentalist he was a man of the
west who knew a great deal about
water about
grass animals
how
the workings of nature
and wrote
eloquently on that subject
well ahead of
the point in time when those
issues became
fashionable and he often
testified before congress
on
western questions of western land
western water cattle grazing
forests so forth
wrote all the environmental speeches for
hadley stevenson
in the 1952 presidential campaign
and was in my view a thoroughly
admirable man the the excitement of
editing harpers magazine is is one goes
back through the the years how many um
admirable people there are
associated with it whether it's devoto
or
alden or raymond
there
most of the editors most of the
leading writers from the magazine come
curiously enough from the west the uh i
myself
devoto was from utah
alan was from missouri
jack fisher was from oklahoma
willie morris who's the editor of the
magazine in the
in the late 60s was from mississippi i'm
from california
the bias
has always been
the magazine has always been edited for
people on the western side of the hudson
river
the point
it's very unlike the atlantic monthly
the atlantic monthly is a magazine that
was founded in 1857 and that
it's its
editorial accesses so it has run
boston new york washington and it's been
a magazine for the
insiders we
we happy few
the
harper's magazine has always been edited
from the point of view of
the the people
in ohio or california
washington
and its
us has been what are the rascals up to
here
here in washington or or in new york you
know how are they
doing us in
on the uh
the
all of this is
more or less you get a sense of it if
you look through this
volume
and i'm i'm just proud to be uh
associated uh not only with all the
editors and and uh they're only been 11
editors in the magazine in 150 years
and they are by and large people of
similar
temperament
i mean i read the
works of
devoto or of allen or of a man who wrote
the easy chair column in the most of the
19th century named george william curtis
and that's
as if i'm
coming across
better versions of myself
but also the
the writers that have been associated
with it are extraordinary i mean it is
as i've said it's not only james and
warden
but it's also people like eb white
and thornton wilder and
john kenneth galbraith and
morris and mailer and halberstam and tom
wolf and so forth you get a
real sense of the
progress and change in american
letters as well as the
sense of continuity
so
that is my pitch for this this this
particular book
which
together with ellen rosenbush is my
managing editor she and i
picked pieces for this it took us
well over two years because we didn't
have we had to take time out from
editing the magazine and there's
in an immense
number of manuscripts to read
and
it was very hard to reduce
even on this
possibly large and heavy book but it was
believe me it would have been much
easier to make a book
three or four times as
heavy as and as long
but i'm here to say that i'm i'm glad to
be in seattle the the
magazine has
many readers
from
this part of the world if not
seattle proper than
nearby
i know this because i
get a lot of letters and and usually
answer them and so i have correspondence
over a period of years
but i'm happy to answer any any question
that you care to ask either about the
new york literary scene or
the future of
the written word
the political
situation in washington
the global economy
[Music]
bill gates i i whatever you care to ask
i'm be happy to to talk about it
i'm told we're supposed to use these
mics okay i'm really curious about
your relationship with harper's magazine
as a reader
i'd be real curious about your first
encounters with the magazine
memorable
pieces
before you became editor
i think the the
i became aware of the magazine
when
i was
in college
which was in the 50s
and i can remember reading
not only galbraith but also
devoto
i can remember finding demo i never did
get to meet the photo but i i read him
early and was
impressed by him also by e.b white who
used to write a column for harper's
magazine before
he went to the new yorker
and some of the early stories of philip
roth also appeared in the magazine
and so i was aware of it in college and
then i drifted off into the into the
newspaper business after
after college and lost touch with it
until
until i got
really until i in almost until i became
a writer for it myself which was in
1970.
since then of course i've read almost
everything that's been published in the
magazine
you know with what you've shared with us
already here and what i live with too
because i came into town 20 years ago on
a freight train
and i've stayed
so i guess my question is from the point
of view and with all the voices you've
seen
see
voices voices yeah
what would the idea of frontier have
become would you say we're not new york
city anymore where the other side of the
continent
where 200 years later this is seattle
but we're our own voices what is the
frontier does it still exist
well you mean
where is the frontier is that the
question you're asking me the
frontier is probably
well that's an interesting question
because the in the in the
in the 19th century say between the
years
1850 and 1900
harper's magazine is
all about
describing the frontier
there it
they're expeditions there are pieces of
people go to alaska people go to
california they describe the gold fields
they describe
the new industries in
in the east the industry how does a
steel mill work uh
correspondents are
going to the
arctic and the antarctic and so forth so
there really is this sense of
expedition
exploration what's over the next range
of mountains how does this work
what is it
who are these people
all those kinds of of questions in the
sense of
always the sense of possibility
that
somehow we can
sow the
soil of the american experience with the
dream of a
cash crop
or a
grand hotel or a new religion or a new
fortune and so on
and it is
the hazards of new fortune
lately
in the last 20 odd years i think the
questions seem to have become more
um
existential and instead of what is it
the question is
what does it mean
or
how do i
how do i perceive it um
i mean there still is a frontier which i
assume is in the um
in the in the technological world i mean
there would be
it's not only the internet and the
computer and silicon valley and redmond
and gates and
and that
kind of the the fortunes that are being
made in in the uh
in the um
internet world or in the technology
world
are
comparable in fact much greater than the
fortunes that were being made in the
gold mines or the
copper mines or cattle
california which is a state i know
something about is is uh
is a whole series of new fortunes it
begins with
gold and then you have
cattle land railroads
electronics
movies
defense industries
aerospace
so forth and now it's
silicon chips
and
so there is the frontier in that sense
but there's also there there are
frontiers in
medicine
in the
i mean i would assume that uh
50 or 100 years from now people will
look back on our
forms of medicine and as barbaric i mean
in the way that we would look back on
at the 18th century
where
patients were still being
bled to death and treated with leeches
and so forth but i mean if you can if
you can
use
biology genes
to
cure disease so on that's a whole new
approach to that so there's a
there's a frontier there
there
i don't know what the frontier is going
to be with
the forms of communication
i don't think we've yet adequate i don't
even developed a
full dress language yet for
either for television or the computer or
the internet i mean
it's
the technology usually comes
well ahead of the artists that know how
to
use it printing is is developed in
the end of the 14th century but it's a
hundred years later
or it's developed the end of the 15th
century but it's a hundred years later
before you get to
montane and cervantes and shakespeare i
mean it takes so i don't think we found
the
the art forms that go with the
with the the computer and the television
and the film
but i i
i think there's a frontier
almost anywhere you turn i mean the next
day is is a blank page right and and uh
you you don't
in order to understand life you have to
construct it
and
you construct it out of the
lumber of of the past but the point is
because that's the only lumber you've
got
and the uh
which is the use of history
but you have to make something new with
it and
i give occasional
commencement addresses to
both
high school kids and college kids and
i mean they're looking straight into the
face of a frontier
most of them
which which is an excitement
so i would say uh the frontier is
with us and uh
always with us and and it's it's the
great uh
the great american talent is is is to be
able to live with uh
change
i mean that's been our
great talent i think over the whole
300 years of the american
experiment
i i'm a friend of the frontier that said
maybe no indians but
other
obstacles
actually my question is a follow-up uh
doctor on um precisely this theme of
one
to
thank harpers
you as this representative for being one
of the first east coast magazines to
recognize the existence of seattle
yes going back to the 1880s by pre-gold
rush
in exploring the history of seattle and
there there are two or three harper
articles that always
pop up and you know this is eight we're
real harpers wrote about us right and
had a big uh etching spread
be a photo spread today but it was an
etching spread right yeah uh so thank
you for that okay um
in this same auditorium uh just a year
ago um
bill gates i think with his fingers
crossed behind his back said that
the future of the book was safe and
computers and the internet and whatever
were not going to replace books
um
just a week ago or even less than that
um uh jeff bezos
announced to the
the
booksellers association that
e-books were probably going to eat
independent bookstores i'm concerned
about harper's
i appreciate your concern where harbors
is going to be in in the internet
um
ebook e-mag
uh revolution and what form will harpers
take 50 years from now
50 years from now i can't possibly tell
you i mean the magazine has been
redesigned
six times
redrafted to meet the changing
circumstances the last 150 years
i
it's conceivable that 50 years from now
it'll be
an ebook or be something you read in a
pom
computer
on the other hand
i i have yet
i can't read a
a computer screen with the same
degree of pleasure that i can read a
printed page the uh
[Applause]
if i have to uh
look at a computer i i do but i i use it
for uh
i think of it as
data rather than as
literature
and there are things you can do with
writing that
you can't do with
film i mean
that i do know because i've
i've made television documentaries and
um
it
the thing that strikes me is how
slow
most
film is as compared to
a simple phrase or a sentence you can do
something
in about six words that will take you a
thousand
film you know images to set up take you
20 minutes to do it in a in a movie or
in a documentary
and i
one of the documentaries that i made
once was the history of american foreign
policy in the
20th century
six parts
an hour each which for television is
considered extremely
long i mean
they give you six hours they think
they've given you uh
i mean
amazingly long time on television but
the
but
when you're doing that kind of history
what happens is that i had
i had
i can't remember whether it was 73
seconds and 49 words
or 49 seconds and 73 words but it was
one of the other and i had to explain
the origins of world war ii
and
and i had to get from
at the same within that
frame
i had to get from photographs
film of the
munich
conference september 1938
to the german
dive bombers
bombing warsaw in september 1939
and
you simply cannot do in that kind of
form what you can do
with the written word so i don't have a
i have no
qualms about saying that the
book or
will
be displaced by film or by
television
whether or not the
contents of the book get get transferred
to
the screen form or not
i can't say with any certainty i i can
say
that
the people that
use the computers will have to learn to
write
a good deal better than they do now
because now it's it's it's most of it at
least that my experience of it is not
worth reading i mean the people are not
taking the time with the
shaping of the language or the revision
i mean i i have to write
everything that i write i write at least
five times
in order to get
it right and
i also find thank you
but i i also find that this is true of
most of the
better writers that i've i've had
experience with there's some
some people who don't have to do that
who are
as fluent as
mozart john updike i think is is that
kind of writer you can do it in the
first draft but
most most of the ones that i know
certainly myself
we're lucky to get there in the fifth or
sixth draft
and i i don't
the
the whole
nature of the
computer screen doesn't
encourage that kind of
effort
also it's very hard with a computer
screen lease for me to go back i mean i
i if i read a page of a book i mean i
like to read it so
it's
i read it slowly
a big i mean it's a good writer because
i i see what what's going on and i i may
have to look back
a page to
see the beginning of the sequence and i
i don't know how to do that with a
somehow scrolling up that doesn't
do that for me i mean i also
think of it as a
i have an aesthetic
relation to
ink and to paper and to
into books
that i have yet to
find
in
in a computer
and i also can see
i see it in terms of the young people
that come to work for the magazine we
have interns every year
we can take 12
interns over the course of a year we
take we take four
and four and four but the
these are kids coming out of
universities all over the country i mean
from
washington and california as well as
from
princeton and yale and so on and they um
i mean they're just as crazy about books
as i am
and they're a lot younger
so
and and they're also very fluent in in
the uh in the computer and film
languages in a way that i'm not so but
they have the same uh
feeling about words and about
paper and about
books and so
maybe it's not a
a mass
market
but it never really was i mean i don't
think i mean
harper's magazine addresses we have a
circulation of 220 000
it's designed and edited for people who
like to read
that number hasn't
changed that much over
the last 100 odd years the
um
you're losing market share
well there are more people
and there are more magazines and there
are more books and there there we we
don't compete against uh
other magazines or
what we compete for is people's time
i mean and and that means
any other magazine on the newsstand any
book in the bookstore trip to europe
tennis
cyber sex i mean you know
we're up against the whole uh
the whole canvas of a
human endeavor right now the early
readers of harper's magazine stranded on
the planes with no television no
telephone
they had
little other recourse except the
harper's magazine
i don't have that same
advantage but uh
it is still it's edited for people who
take pleasure in in
reading and
i i don't see that that uh race dying
out
better not it's right it's my hope
[Applause]
thanks for coming
i read your our column every month
slowly oh i write it slowly okay
uh this past sunday i noticed something
in the paper where uh
george w bush and the i believe the
governor of new mexico were discussing
uh the fact that neither of them really
understood what was going on and were
relatively proud about it
yet are
there they have no trouble
getting
access to the
most important thing to get elected
large amounts of money
right
where does
i'm sure that's nothing that hasn't
happened in the past but
the degree
and the size of these the money it takes
to get elected to an office in this
country have grown astronomically
where do you see that leaving democracy
for us in the future
well i i think democracy is
in trouble for for a number of reasons
that being
one of them because there are
only about
um
i've seen this number somewhere but i
think that
the number of people who give more than
a hundred dollars to political campaigns
in any given year about is about two
hundred thousand
it's in other words a very small
group
and sometimes referred to as the
donor
class
and this concludes wealthy individuals
as well as
corporations
and special interests
unions are very
the the it says
so you could say that the democracy is
is that 200 000 people
because unless you if you're a candidate
unless you
can
convince
that
the money to
back your campaign
you don't
go anywhere i mean you you don't get to
a microphone so there's
that's the
that's the element that's working
against
democracy it's limiting the the numbers
of people that
can
afford to pay the costs of
of a campaign
and then
democracy is also
it's a face-to-face uh
form of government and
in in the classical sense of course it
it takes place among
relatively
small numbers of people athens was uh
small
the
united states
at the end of the 18th century i think
the population of the entire
country in 1800 is no more than 5
million
and
many of those people i mean women at
that point did not have a vote certainly
the
blacks didn't have a vote so you were
talking about again about a relatively
small number of people
whether it can work and a
country that we
now have which
however 100
million people
there are
and where
people increasingly tend
one of the
consequences of the of the electronic
technology
is to
isolate people i mean there there is the
tendency to bring people together but
there's also the
same at the same time there's the
tendency to isolate
us from one another i mean i'm here with
my clicker
and i can afford to just look at the
world that i choose to that reflects
what i want the world to be i only have
to look at the stations that agree with
me or
the ball teams that i like i really
don't and if i have a
if i live in a gated community and if i
have a sufficiently large
suv
i
maybe don't have to ever come across
anybody
who's not
like myself
the the technology
allows that
that's not
democratic in in the small d
sense of the word and the also in the
schools
as far as i can see we're not teaching
um
the democratic
idea i mean i know that's
you see more and more
the channel one
type
or zap me type the television that's
being given to
public schools in return for which the
children
are obliged to watch
two minutes of commercials every day and
with some of the systems
they're also obliged to
go home at least twice a week
and try to sell their parents one of the
products that's sponsored by the
the
the school television system
the
literacy illiteracy rate is very high
i came across
the other day i came across an
examination that was given to the
eighth grade students in selena kansas
in 1895. it was about
the principles of grammar
the history of the united states
geography
and mathematics
and i don't think there's a single
graduate of harvard that could pass that
test
today
um
i went to yale i know there's no
graduate
of
yale if you pass that test
i know that for a certainty but the
but the
we don't we don't uh
so
you
you you hear the
i mean democracy depends upon literacy
and we've now got something like 70
million people in the united states that
are that are deemed
illiterate
i don't know i don't think democracy
works without
books and reading
certainly it doesn't work without a
sense of history
the
electronic media are not very good at
the
history you can never
remember anything you see on television
i mean at least i can
it's the so it's the world of the
eternal now there's no
memory in it
it's also a language that you can't
broadcast discourse is
truly
truncated i mean again if you read back
in in the history of harper's magazine
the number of words that we've lost i
mean my
my vocabulary compared to the vocabulary
of people writing in this magazine in
the 1930s 1920s 1870s
my vocabulary is is very small
then i'm considered
you know an elitist who uses
overly long words and
you
if you write for television you you find
out that you have you can't
you can't back into sentences it has to
go
uh subject
verb objects and uh
no dependent clauses i mean that doesn't
it won't work in the time allowed and
you uh
irony is something that television
cannot
accommodate
and it's
they're
lots of things it's a very uh
primitive
form of of speech
and democracy
at least as we
conceived it
in
philadelphia in 1787
depends on a fairly high degree of of
literacy
so
maybe we will
redefine it as as as something else but
in its its classical form
or in the form that we
or at least that i like to think of it
i i think it's an endangered species
like one of those
tiny owls that you've got out here
i have a real specific question compared
to the ones that have been asked so far
but i was wondering um
in the 300th anniversary of harper's
what 150th no no no no
no no oh i see okay
when the three when the 300th arrives i
see um what do you think how do you
think people will look back at um really
like i said really specific the the uh
this month's issue with tom wolf on the
cover next to mark twain and that
specific
uh
article that he wrote and the kind of i
think the the implied comparison between
the two and um what do you think people
are going to look back at that article
and say
you mean what you mean at will's article
well it's a that's a difficult question
i mean
um
let us say that tom and i have different
uh views
in terms of
we have different
our politics are quite different
i mean
the uh
the magazine
as i've said before publishes
pieces that i don't have to agree with
the
on the other hand it's a
rhetorically and
it's a
it's a fine
polemic
it succeeds on its
own terms
okay the
do you want me to go on or are you
no that's reaffirmed
something yes
i'm totally nervous
i hope i can formulate this right i have
maybe i could put two questions and you
could answer whichever one sounded
better okay
whichever one's easier is the wow
well this is a really big question but
has human society made progress over the
last few centuries i mean obviously
economically we're a lot better off in
general just ordinary people like me are
a lot better off i mean in terms of
ideas have we made progress have we
evolved in an upward way that would be
one question
because i come in contact with a lot of
people who seem to think we have not and
you know you're such a historian
my second question you could choose
instead or do both at once would be
what's the driving force behind progress
is it economics that's what a historian
friend of mine says that it's purely
economics and the ideas come after that
or are the ideas first or do they work
together
well okay
i'm not enough of an historian to answer
that that question i
certainly
human society has improved in the in in
all of its material
aspects we live longer
um
the
if we were living in the palace of
versailles we would be horrified to go
back to uh france in in in the
uh 17th century
very few people
kept their teeth or their hair past the
age of 30. their plumbing was
what we would consider
appalling none of the comforts of the
modern world would be
present despite the loveliness of the
gardens and the architecture and so on
so that in terms of
all of the the
the daily living
longevity
transportation
um
housing plumbing
and so on
yes we have made
substantial progress
in the realm of ideas i
i don't think so
the
i
you know as we still read
whether you're reading the greek
playwrights or whether you're reading
shakespeare or
the letters of seneca or the essays of
montane
whether if you consider music ideas
whether you're listening to the music of
mozart or bach
beethoven
i don't see that
we've we've
advanced
in it
we have different tastes
styles change
but
i think the advancement over the it
depends it in what uh
what attracts the
the intellect in any one period i mean
people say well there are not enough
ideas and not enough intellectuals and
their philosophers and so on but
that changes over time i mean in the
17th century the the
the
intellect tended
to gravitate toward
religion in the church
the 18th century toward
politics
i i don't think we've improved on the
the political ideas of
hamilton or jefferson or madison
i don't think we
i mean it's been
no american politician that i know of
has
written their own speeches since about
1920 certainly no american president has
the american college presidents don't
even write their own speeches anymore
the
when i went to yale in the 50s
griswold who was the president used to
write his own speeches wrong wonderful
essays giamatti
did too in the 80s but
not now
and
it's
our
creative energy intellectual energy is
drawn to the sciences
i mean
the inventions that are taking
place in the
again in the technological
fields or
physics
i mean that's what's attracting our
mathematics
that's what seems to be attracting the
the
best minds of the of the um 20th century
there are so
i i think that might change i i i don't
i don't we the world today seems to be
somewhat confused as to how to
govern itself i don't know how you solve
if there really is an environmental
crisis of the proportions that i
read about in terms of the
global warming in terms of the poisoning
of rivers and oceans and the
disappearance of species burning down a
forest and so forth
if these if these
facts are true
then
we will need some kind of
new idea or some large idea whether it's
a religious idea or philosophical idea
to to
address that
dilemma i mean that's not something that
a corporation knows how to fix or that
an applied scientist knows how to fix i
will take some kind of
existential
idea that
is sufficiently and exciting
enough to
large numbers of people
so
progress
is uneven i mean it it
goes in some directions and not others i
mean the byzantine empire
has existed for a thousand years one of
the longest living empires after the
egyptian that i know of
and
to the best of my knowledge never
produced a single uh
writer of any
note i mean the uh
it was famous
for
dress design
and
ornamental mosaic
and
political assassination
those are the three
great talents the visiting empire
over a period of a thousand years
and is left
very little
behind as far as i can see
but the advancements in science and are
so uh and in the comforts of ordinary
life are so appealing
um
that
as is
you know the
the financial world i mean it takes
a good deal of
imagination and creativity to construct
uh
leveraged buyout or
you know make a
work of fraud through
six languages
five currencies and four tiers of
taxation
that's a
a form of
game of japanese go but it's played with
uh
with very real rewards at the end of it
i have great faith in the uh over time
in the in the uh
in the creativity and the
resourcefulness of
people and if ideas
once again become
exciting and necessary
i think we will
come up with them
the moment we seem to be in a period
where
it's it's
as i say the emphasis is going in other
directions
the 20s in the united states is an
extraordinarily
uh
rich period in literature
i mean you read harpers magazine or you
read
the early versions of the early editions
of the new yorker the american mercury
the dial
it's it's it's wonderful stuff
but
now it's almost as if we have a museum
kind of culture we keep repackaging the
past we make coffee table books i mean
there it is right
but but that's what we do with uh
you know that's that's our cultural
studies i mean it's as if all the good
ideas have already been uh
um
figured out we just have to figure out
how to collect them and package them and
so on
but that's what a lot of the media is
it's what a lot of
education is at the
moment but i haven't lost hope
we're just in a slow period
okay
thank you very much for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
lewis lapham is the editor of harper's
magazine
franklin square press published an
american album 150 years of harper's
magazine
[Music]
48 hours of non-fiction books on tv
you're watching book tv
on c-span 2.
coming up john lott on his body morning
on book tv
the business of books how the
international conglomerates took over
publishing and changed the way we read
is a new book by andre shifrin
recently mr schifrin director of the new
press discussed his book and ideas with
lewis lapham editor of harper's magazine
colin robinson managing editor of burso
books and william strachan press
director of columbia university
it's a little over an hour
okay
good evening i'd like to welcome you to
deutsche's house at new york university
and um
i'd like to before we start tell you
there will be a reception at postman
books store right across the street
and you can also buy
andre schifrin's book here out front or
over at postman's bookstore also
and
the moderator of this panel is colin
robinson and he is managing director of
verso books and i'll welcome him
[Applause]
well i'm sorry it's so crowded in here
it's typical of uh
independent radical publishing not to
realize um that you can sometimes get a
bigger audience than you anticipate and
um but it's very i'm very pleased that
so many people have turned up we're here
to um mark the publication of a book
that i'm incredibly proud to be
publishing at verso andre schifrin's the
business of books
um
and um
i want to just say a few words by way of
an introduction to perhaps some of the
things we're going to be talking about
this evening
um
and basically i i
should admit straight away that um any
facts coming out of what i'm about to
say have derived entirely from andre's
book and i would urge you to read it
it's very informative
but we're in a situation in book
publishing at the moment
where
five companies
five large conglomerates are controlling
about eighty percent
of the books that are sold in the trade
and there are practically no
medium-sized publishers left
in american british publishing
um i mean really
you could count them on the fingers of
one hand
there are a lot of tiny little
publishers which i count ourselves as
one
according to andre
the library of congress registers 50 000
entities that are recognized as
publishers
and there are
70 000 books a year being published into
the american trade
so you might say in that situation does
it really matter that there's this
conglomeration surely that's enough
books to
suit every conceivable
interest and taste
um and i think um i would answer uh
that question with a definitive yes it
it it does matter that this
conglomeration is occurring because the
interesting uh figures are not the
number of books that are being published
or the number of publishers that are
putting them out there but what the
distribution of reading across those
books are
and figures for that are harder to come
by
but it was noticeable um just the other
week in fact i think it was earlier this
week that
tom clancy was paid 23 million dollars
for a two-book deal by his publishers
now to get that uh to get that back uh
requires uh an enormous sales effort on
their part and i think it's symptomatic
of the industry at the moment
symptomatic in the sense that my belief
is that more and more people are reading
the same books and we are heading
towards a culture this is occurring not
just in book publishing but in other
areas of the media as well in in cinema
and in music
where more and more people are
sharing the same cultural experiences
and diversity is being narrowed and we
have an increasingly bland and
homogeneous society as a result
and i would argue that
cultural diversity is important it's
important for the same reasons i think
that environmentalists argue that
um
biodiversity is important you can't tell
whether what is seemingly insignificant
at the moment is going to be of
importance in the future
you can't tell by removing something
which doesn't really seem of any great
import if that's going to affect things
which are sitting next to it be it in a
rainforest or in a bookstore
so i think cultural diversity is worth
defending worth fighting for
i remember when uh a
a long time ago when i was at faber
longer than i'd care to specify when i
was working in favor and faber the
chairman of faber um
told me that he had signed william
golding's
the business
the lord of the flies
um
for the for the faber list
and that when he signed that book
faber was the 13th publisher that
william golding had approached before he
could get anyone to take it on
now if william golding was hawking that
book around london today
he would have run out of publishers
significant publishers before he got to
number 13 and that book perhaps would
never have appeared
so i think that is a problem
um
so i think maybe these are that that's
enough for me to kick off the the some
of the themes that we could talk about
in this discussion tonight
and i'm very pleased to have with me
um a distinguished panel two of whom i'm
pleased to say are
verso authors um
on my immediate right is andre schifrin
uh the author of
the business of books
um
to his right um is louis lapham the
editor of harper's magazine
um
who has uh published three books with
verso
uh and at the far right is bill strachan
the
uh director of columbia university press
who hasn't yet published with us but if
he's thinking of writing a book i'd
certainly be very interested in
having a look at the manuscript
um
and i think the best thing is that
perhaps if andre kicks off and we take
about
10 minutes each um
to say what we want and then we could
take some questions from the floor
so
andre okay well thank you it's it's a
pleasure to be here and to have a
discussion with you which i hope after
we speak you'll all partake in trying to
look at not only what has happened but
why has it happened uh the purpose of my
book was to look back on close to 50
years in publishing i had my first
publishing job as it were when i was 15
working at the old 8th street bookstore
down the street
and to see how these changes have taken
place and as colin says why they matter
and when i first started at pantheon
which was then
part of random house um i remember
bennett surf talking about the day that
he and alfred knuff agreed to join
forces and the story made the front page
of the new york times uh and the next
morning the uh the attorney general's
office was on the phone saying what
percentage of the market you control et
cetera et cetera and bennett told them
that the deal of the three houses
pantheon
and random was worth 15 million dollars
and the attorney general's office was
very
angry at having been troubled by this
this false rumor of an important merger
having taken place
but the other day when uh time warner
aol
uh decided to merge and that was 165
billion deal
uh 10 000 times the value of the random
house merger uh no one was on the phone
and i saw in today's paper that the
european common market anti-trust
commission that had thought of doing
something
was willing to give up if only they
didn't have a total monopoly on recorded
music they were willing to let them have
a monopoly and everything else
um so i think part of what we're talking
about is the change that's taken place
because the antitrust acts have not been
enforced and i think i've grown to have
a great respect for the antitrust act i
think was a very intelligent piece of
legislation and as you know if murdoch
wants to buy a radio station and a
newspaper in a given town he has to do
very heavy bribing to get that he has to
persuade thatcher or whichever other
government uh he can persuade that it's
worth
lifting all the restrictions to let him
do that but when bertelsmann controls 40
of the american trade and books um no
one no one has really complained about
this in in terms of antitrust
legislation and so i people always ask
me what can we do about this this is the
major factor this is the major decision
and the major need and we can talk about
that in in great detail we've just
published in paperback a marvelous book
by uh by bob mcchesney called rich media
poor nation which goes over the whole
history of conglomeration and monopoly
and all the media not just book
publishing and it's a fascinating and
harrowing tale
as as colin says does this really matter
our publishers not going to do the same
kind of stuff whoever owns them and i'm
afraid the answer is that it's a totally
different story when you have a
conglomerate control and what i try to
explain in the book is how this control
establishes itself and what differences
it makes the first thing is a totally
different profit expectation
uh publishing over the years in america
never made more than four percent
average profit per annum and that's
merging everybody from new directions to
crown i mean the people who were trying
very hard to make money those who didn't
care so much about money nonetheless
averaged all together four percent the
conglomerates reasonably enough say if
we've bothered to buy you then you must
be as profitable as the television and
newspaper and other holdings that we
have who make between 15 and 20
and therefore the changes that we've
seen in all these corporations has been
the result of having to completely
change what they publish in order to to
meet these profit expectations uh and
part of this of course is changing the
nature of the books part of it is
changing the nature of the structure of
the company i'm told by friends at
random house that they have been told by
their
new bosses that the new building that's
being built in midtown has 40 percent
fewer offices
uh than the current one that means one
of every other person will be fired in
time which is a great shame for the
people involved obviously but it's also
a great shame for the culture because it
means that all these diverse firms that
were bought up and that's the point of
the antitrust act will be merged into
non-competitive entities that where one
person will say yes this is a dell
paperback this is abandoned paperback
this is a valentine paperback and so on
uh and the competition that would have
come had they been forced to divest
themselves of these holdings or
otherwise uh follow the ruling of an
antitrust decision is not there
and just to give you an example there
was an interesting article in the nation
the other day about sea right mills
which recall that in the early 60s c
wright mills had written a book called
listen yankee which came out as a
valentine paperback ian valentine who i
knew and liked was a crazy radical kind
of guy who decided to publish a book in
defense of castro's cuba
before the time in america was
threatening to invade it and they sold
400 000 copies
uh no i don't think they were 400 000
people at the time who were in favor of
castro but there were at least 400 000
americans who were willing to plug down
50 cents to see what the case was
and that's the kind of publishing that
has totally disappeared both for
political and for commercial reasons
i have in the book a long and sad
chapter comparing the catalogues of the
major firms of looking at what they
publish in 1950 6070 and 2000 and you
you wouldn't recognize them as the same
firms indeed they are not the same firms
um but harper collins for instance which
was the pillar of the establishment and
and published very
serious uh all usually pro-governmental
books and so on nonetheless we're was
publishing 60 70 serious works of
history sociology
you name it in 1950 and 60 todd gitlin's
first study of of chicago for instance
appeared as a harper book mcavoy's
classic study of vietnam i can list
endless titles
last year harper decided instead that
they would launch harper entertainment
which had 136 titles scheduled for the
first year
of which the star was the jerry springer
picture book
so you have this this a total
transformation into publishing as part
of the entertainment industry and indeed
i saw in the times yesterday my former
colleague charles harris referring
saying
publishing is the only part of the
entertainment industry that has
neglected the black audience etc etc uh
so people now accept that even people
within publishing accept that concept
when of course
uh there was supposed to be another role
to publishing and what we've seen now is
that the phrase the marketplace of ideas
has really become a question of how much
is is each idea worth how much money can
you make from an idea and if you can't
make money from an idea it's not going
to get published so the large firms
increasingly will have a minimal number
of 20 or so thousand uh copies before
they'll take on a book so that that book
can make enough of a contribution to the
overhead and to the profit that's
required of each volume
well i could go on in in detail on this
kind of thing but the changes are
enormous they're enormous in terms of
the quality of the books they're also
enormous in terms of the politics of the
companies
murdoch newhouse and others who have
very conservative politics have not
hesitated to use their firms to further
those politics and also
we've had the phenomenon and again i
could go into detail that if publishing
is part of an entity that owns all sorts
of other things radio broadcasting and
others the books become tools towards
the profitability of the other parts
murdock is willing to make any sacrifice
in terms of his books in order to get
sky broadcasting into china he'll censor
books by chris patton and others who are
critical of the chinese government just
as he censors the bbc on sky when it's
broadcasting to china and i i joke in
the book that if uh murdoch was trying
to get uh broadcasting rights in 1930s
germany uh he would have given hitler a
30 city tour from mein kampf uh this is
the the kind of ftse that we see being
played on a global scale and one that is
very dangerous um my german publisher of
saint closing is more dramatic than i
and and perhaps more accurate when he
says without books there is no democracy
without the debate that you need to have
without the discussion without the
availability of counter-cyclical ideas
whether they're in fiction poetry or or
non-fiction doesn't matter without these
we cannot
have a truly functioning democracy that
publishing is the only medium that
doesn't need a vast amount of money it's
the only one that doesn't need a mass
audience it's the only one that doesn't
need to be driven by advertisers it's
the only one which traditionally has
brought forth new ideas and it is now i
think severely uh at risk
lewis
i'm i'm not as gloomy the um
yeah if i walk across the street and
walk in the poslan bookstore if i walk
him even into a
big independent bookstore even barnes
and noble i find a great deal to read
and of all
kinds of quality i'm
there's more there to read than i
kind of have time to read
so i'm not as concerned as the
as andre the the um
and i think that it follows from a
larger
change which is that i'm of an age where
i began
life
reading books i mean i'm old enough to
be before
television
in 1945 the average written vocabulary
of a
14 year
of an american school child between the
year between the ages of 6 and 14 was 25
000 words
today the written vocabulary is
10 000 words
so
we don't have a literary culture we i
don't think we ever really did in the
united states from what i can read of
the country's history we have a
literate society although less literate
than it was but but not a literary one
the
the audience for
the kinds of books that uh
i'm interested in that andre's
interested in i think and and that
colin's interested in is small
and always has been small if you
go back and look at the bestseller lists
in the 1850s the
1900 1950
it's as bad as tom clancy by and large
the there are a few exceptions as there
are a few exceptions today
reading and writing is is is a it's an
active
uh engagement
the the
the writer needs the reader the reader
needs the writer but the it's an act of
an imagination to
read
at least profitably
and that's always a minority i mean the
i
a
class
five years ago in writing at yale
university
to juniors and seniors and
i had 12 students in the class
three of them knew how to read the other
nine did not uh
they had
they knew a great deal about television
they they could quote commercials they
could quote dialogue out of movies with
uh
gwyneth paltrow or bill murray but they
they didn't read anything
um
that's
so where i mean my point is that the
audience is always a small one the
people that care about
democracy or a small number
um
so the subtitle of this
this conversation is how international
conglomerates took over publishing and
change the way we read the question is
who's the we
if you mean the
broad
american audience
it
as far as i can see was never there
and the the
minority the active minority
still reads
and the
small publishers the verso
the new press
have taken up
the
function
of the
mid-list or of the the better books that
were being published by the
big publishing houses
in the 50s
i mean i don't i mean i i don't even
bother with with with most of what goes
on to uh
uh
network television network television is
a waste of time and and its audiences is
dwindling
so
i'm not as concerned about that nor am i
as concerned
i guess about the notion of
democracy because
in my view it's already gone i mean
that's a that's that's an old story as
far as i could say i don't think we have
a democracy anymore in this country
but
i'm just glad that we have uh
andre and colin but i mean i think the
kind of things that they do and the kind
of thing i do is always against the odds
it always has been against the odds if
you read balzac's description of the
literary scene in paris in the 1830s
description of the literary scene in
paris in the 1880s it's
it's very grim
i mean the the fools the knaves uh
are in charge
as they are now
and the uh
it's the same thing in the united states
senator the uh
henry james goes to europe edith wharton
goes to europe albert not goes to europe
uh mark twain doesn't publish
for you know the last 10 or 15 years of
his life he doesn't publish it it isn't
published
until 30 years after his death
so this is a
an old argument as as far as i'm
concerned it takes different forms in
different periods
but the status quo is never particularly
interested in cultural diversity
never has been i mean
they're interested in selling as much
of the same stuff to as many of the same
people
as possible and that would have been
true of the
roman empire would have been true of
18th century france
voltaire was in exile
so i don't
entirely sympathetic
i
uh flee from brutal smith now and so on
but uh but i'm i'm i just accept it as a
natural
condition
well i feel strongly both ways right no
no
no um much of this will sound the same
following on the heels but i think to
try to amplify in one thing i think
the conglomerates have changed
publishing and i think it will change
not only what i see is amplifying what
lewis is saying is not only what
we read um
it'll change first how we can publish
books and that will change how we read i
lament the fact that the book publishing
industry in america seems to be affected
by the deregulation of the 80s and the
commercialism of the 90s
there was a time when at least lip
service was paid to the idea that we
aren't all in it just for the money um
in publishing that was that was standard
even in the largest commercial houses
um and when i started in publishing i
started working at double date which was
then an independent family run
company but did produce 600 titles a
year so but that the attention to the
diversity of the list and to uh
something other than commerce was was at
least
champion in the halls
um
i think that's no longer the case in the
conglomerates the pressure for profit is
is absolutely enormous
and it's led to only bigger publishers
it's bigger bookstores and chains bigger
printing companies and bigger media
conglomerates that have squeezed out the
daily review mechanism we um went
looking for a review file of an author
we had published in the past recently
and you could see that this person had
about 50 different reviews from their
book within the across the country in
local newspapers and the like um and you
couldn't find 50 outlets right now and i
think that that whole pressure it's not
it's not just conglomerates and books
it's a conglomerates across the country
um
i think what andrea said and others have
said about this leading to finding books
with greater sales to support this
overhead means there's been a fierce
competition um
to provide books for suitable for mass
consumption books that everyone wants um
maybe lewis is right this has always
been the case but i think it's more
prevalent than ever before in the in the
commercial publishers
um it's led to situations where editors
at the big air houses are led to be
judged by what they acquire rather than
what they publish and i think that's
changing the nature of what they look
for in
in what they
publish and it's also led to a change
and i think this is absolutely
fundamental change in all the publishing
where the profitability of a publisher
is balanced on the back of every book
rather than on the entirety of the list
i mean you knew
um when i got into publishing that you
were going to lose money on many books
and you just said well that's fine these
will pay for them and i don't think
that's the case anymore people say
every one of these books has to make a
profit and that change is fundamentally
what you publish
um
the diversity as lewis says is is still
there the end the
barriers to entry and book publishing um
are very few and that's why there are so
many publishers there are thousands of
them um and these conglomerates have i
think one thing that's changed book
publishing and that's given them
resources to do things and develop
systems and expertise that are are the
envy certainly of smaller publishers
and led to better publishing in many
cases but i think there's a problem
there
and that is that in
exercising this expertise if you will
um it's increasingly difficult for the
smaller publishers to gain access to the
marketplace and compete on an equal
basis in some cases in many independents
uh simply don't have direct access to
booksellers or bookseller chains like
borders like barnes and noble
and access to an alarmingly as i
mentioned a reduced number of review
media and i think ultimately that means
that we won't be able to compete as
smaller independent publishers to reach
the consumers with the same
effectiveness as we have been in the
past
i think this conspires against
maximizing the sales of what we publish
as small and independent publishers and
i fear this is going to lead to and if
it hasn't already
we mentioned a two-tier publishing
system and maybe that's not so bad maybe
the small publishers can present the
works um
for us all and keep that debate going
but what i worry increasingly is in this
two-tier system the smaller publishers
won't even be heard and i think that's
one of the big effects on uh the change
in publishing and i appear that it may
have a greater effect on what we read
before we go to questions i think andre
just wants to say a word about lewis
rather gloomy prognosis
i i think andre was gleaming in the
sense that he said things had got bad
and you were gloomy in the sense that
you said well they always were there
right which is an important difference
and i just wanted to say if you if
anyone has a chance to look in the book
there's several chapters on the history
of publishing especially in this country
uh which shows the degree to which there
was a mass audience for serious books uh
particularly serious political books i
mean edward bellamy's looking backwards
started a whole movement and so the
equivalent of millions of today's in
today's books uncle tom's cabin was so
popular that that coal miners in the
california gold miners in the california
gold rush would be rented tonight
well that doesn't mean that's as bad as
clancy well what do you say no well it
hadn't get no argument well the argument
is that i don't know if you don't like
bellamy or you don't like
the other one but in any case these are
books that started national debates and
i think as such they're valuable uh and
i think they were they were essential
and and you know you can go into the
into the time when you and i were not
looking at television uh in in the 40s
and so on when you know a book by
wendell wilkie on on on the future of
american politics and so on would sell a
million copies and paperback and so on
and so forth so they're
all all of publishing was engaged
whether it was the large commercial
firms or the small ones in publishing
books that that were bringing new ideas
to an audience and i'm not as much in
this respect and elitist as lewis as i
think this was this brought about a
debate which was an important part of
america and still could be i think the
disappearance of these books is is
something that's that we can document
and talk about and it's very important
of course when you go into a store like
possum which is a very good story you
see a very good choice of books you
don't see the books that aren't being
published
and what you don't see for instance are
practically any translations of european
non-fiction which is something that the
new press has tried to to do a lot of
there are all sorts of major books being
published throughout the world that no
longer are being translated none of the
large houses will do european fiction
for that matter i mean we've reached the
past where the university of nebraska is
the leading publisher of french and
german fiction in this country which
tells you something about knowledge and
for our strauss and all sorts of other
companies so it's it's the dogs that
aren't barking that i think are as
important as anything in that by looking
at unless you look very critically and
compare with what was done in the past
uh it's easy to say yes of course there
are more books than any of us can read
there are more books published before
our lifetime than any of us should be
reading and want to read in our and for
the rest of our lives
but the current debate the books that
set off the newspaper and other articles
the books that say here's an issue you
know look at this election year look at
the farcical uh
election we have and
who is publishing tom buchanan a paper
cannon not one of the large houses it's
henry regnary who has published a
collection of nader it's again a very
small house seven stories so i think
that's the abdication of the center
from producing these ideas and think an
important thing and we can go on as to
how important our publishing houses are
of course we're saving american
civilization that's taken for granted uh
but but you know we published 70 books
last year which is one tenth of one
percent of the total output of the
country we can't kid ourselves into
saying this is going to be the
difference that bertelsmann and the
others can make
um thanks andre i mean i i would like to
just before we throw it in to try and
send a more upbeat note about um
the prospects for independent publishing
because um
it's true that we're very small but it's
also true i think that both the new
press and verso and seven stories for
that match in the last couple of years
have got books onto the bestseller lists
and i think andre says in his book that
um they were in the happy position at
pantheon um when he first started there
in the 60s of wanting book to take on
books that no one else seemed to be in
the slightest bit interested in in
publishing and i certainly feel that
about the commissioning that we're doing
at verso at the moment i mean you can
get
really really great authors uh you know
terrific pieces of work
uh which you know 10 15 years ago there
would have been fierce competition from
the big houses for and and we're now
able to sign them up and i think if you
can bring a bit you know the the thing
about these huge beer moths that are
running the industry now is that they
are very cautious and they're very
inflexible and if you can show a bit of
imagination a bit of creativity in the
way that you present these books to the
public you can get results you can make
breakthroughs i'm not saying
that we're going to change the world but
we can
shake things up a little bit and i think
the the new press
um uh has shown you know by growing into
a significant small publisher from
scratch seven years ago what can be done
in that regard
so uh i mean i generally on these panels
that end up being the sort of token
optimist but i it's a role that needs to
be played i think
so let's um
let's take some questions there's a
gentleman here
let's
um
i don't mean to pile on but um
while it is true louis that um my voice
is awfully loud isn't it
well it's true louis that um
the united states never had a
considerable literary culture
and that um this
i've heard it said that five percent of
the american population has always been
the percentage
that that comprise the serious readers
and that has never really never changed
nevertheless i think you have to grant
that that some things
have
changed demonstrably
there's a there's a there's been a huge
ideological and psychological shift
among the people in publishing for
example
pocket books in 1939 and then ballentine
books 19
or bantum sorry bantam books in 1945 the
first two paperback houses
in this country were were started very
idealistically with the purpose of
exposing a mass readership to the plays
of shakespeare
to um you know the grapes of wrath and
also to raphael sabatini but i mean
there were there weren't any diet books
in that mix or anything like that so so
something has changed you mentioned
double day you know nelson doubleday on
his death
was praised by edna ferber as a man who
was a genius at getting books into the
hands of the unbookish
that attitude is absolutely
gone from uh the top-tier corporate
management you could even say that
something comparable to that has
happened in hollywood because for all
their legendary crudeness and and
reactionism even some of the hollywood
moguls had a certain idealism when it
came to the movies
that's my piling on i know i agree with
you but that's a cultural change that's
kind of nothing but publishing
we can't we can't i don't think we can
make a very tidy distinction between
these two developments because they
reinforce one another
what i wanted to ask about now is is a
couple more of the objective
uh
developments that have contributed to
the trend because good books are being
written louis you know that you've
written some of them right i said that
but there are there are reasons why we
don't know about them one has to do with
the fact that the people who's the we
well certain number of people do know
about them that's a certain number
it's not it's not a large enough number
why
because
good books that have something to tell
people i'll give you an example all
right
we've discussed this i think but i'm
going to talk to everybody about it
the book by carolyn eisenberg was
published by cambridge university press
drawing the line came out four years ago
it's an amazing
uh historical study of how germany was
partitioned and it makes the case
absolutely uh solidly that it was an
american decision
and this book was you know it got
stellar reviews throughout the academic
press and in the tls
uh it was reviewed in the nation
but other than the nation and a
mentioned by gore vidal and vanity fair
it got reviewed in no newspaper or
magazine in this country and and one of
the main things about it that the
academic reviewers praised was that it
calls everything into question about the
cold war that's the kind of book that
should have a mass audience that book
was reviewed
not at all
by the new york times by the washington
post by time by newsweek two years later
they reviewed james chase's book
atchison
which is um
not a good book you know it's based on a
few secondary sources it's a hagiography
and it doesn't mention
the book by eisenberg at all but that
book gets reviewed in the times in the
post glowingly at length in both the
weekday and the weekend editions and
it's and it's recognized it exists the
other book does not exist
so what i'm what i'm i'm trying to say
is that the the narrowing of the
reviewing field which you spoke about
and the fact that book stores also
have succumbed to the same process that
you've talked about so that only the
really big publishers get books piled up
near the entrances and the rest have
what the shelf space of of yogurt i mean
shelf life they they they're gone very
quickly
i was you know i was wondering if you
talk about reviewing and if you would
talk about bookstores to sort of make
this argument a little stronger
should we take it some more questions
or contributions i was asking if andre
would like to address the problem of
bookstores
being uh corporatized
as
should we take a few more questions
first okay
yes gentlemen um well just i mean i'm
just sort of responding what you're
saying
i mean i'm
a little confused and since it seems to
me that the culture itself
is fragmented so it's not really
possible to have that sort of
audience or
you know for that book that you're
talking about that was so wonderful i
mean
i would love to believe that more people
would be reading that sort of thing but
we were i mean 30 40 years ago it was
primarily a white male culture
and therefore you had you had much more
of a notion of
of reading public that would agree if
you like
and that situation has changed
drastically
um you know in the last 30 or 40 years
so one camera when simply cannot expect
it the intelligent reading public
which at one time looked very similar
which is now originally composed of all
different sorts of people
um to have the same interest so i'm i'm
basically in louis's camp um in terms of
optimism i mean you know things could be
better but
perhaps
if this book doesn't get a hearing in
the mainstream press it's because people
used to be white males i don't follow
the
argument um
there's no ideological uh pressure there
i think we should let some other people
come in on this
possibly some women
[Music]
i would like to ask you know any and all
about uh the effect of the web um i
recently got something um
just through email about this new
publisher
that is is buying books from author and
bypassing barnes and noble all together
and they're selling directly the
they're distributing themselves as well
as
uh
[Music]
signing up the authors not wondering you
know
what you all think of
you know that particular development of
you know getting books to two people and
you know
i mean i rare and i've got buy a lot of
books over the web and you know i can go
to amazon and
i asked a friend from new zealand you
know to give me lists of native writers
from new zealand i go to amazon and
click and there's you know gazillion so
you know maybe that is optimistic but i
mean you see a lot of things happening
now where you know
there is a lot of potential for
democracy through this new technology
and we there is a hope of that it will
topple this sort of big corporate
structures
that we've had
anyone else
yes
well i'm just thinking about jacob
epstein's article in the new york
youtube of books in
last april in which he seemed to have a
kind of optimism coming from 50 years of
editing and having a kind of optimism
which is partly because of the new
technologies but also because he felt
that the conglomerates uh weren't long
for this world in some way that they
weren't making their profits they
couldn't make their profits they were
they got into the wrong businesses and i
thought that was a really interesting
point and i wonder if i agree with that
completely i think that collapsed
because
the paralysis is too big too stupid too
scary
all right are we going to see them
we're seeing it happen to the television
network and i assume we'll see it happen
to the uh big brothers
i think some of those big publishing
companies are now driving the technology
i think that's where they've got the
resources to take care of them um and
that's what i know
three years ago when people talked about
ebooks or books on that and everything
it was the techno
technology that was driving the change
what's driving the change now into
ebooks other corporations who realize
they need to control this
um this sort of material okay they don't
want to let it just slide
free um and that's what's going to drive
it and that's why i don't think they're
going to fall apart if they're
increasingly they're going to morph us
into something else but that's what's
going on
um i think the problem which jason
doesn't address is is that of ownership
uh and and control uh the question is
who has this machinery who's the ebook
people also can do all sorts of
marvelous things when they come to us
they say what are your best sellers
they're replicating the same the same
process and i think that's that's the
danger that all of the new technologies
will fall into the trap of who has the
biggest advertising budget who's going
to be able to reach you most
convincingly as amazon does by spending
tens of millions of dollars in putting
out of business uh you know
hundreds of bookstores uh so the the
question
really this is a countless society and
we're seeing the the cultural
detritus that results from from
unbridled capitalism and i think we
should talk about it in in those terms
uh the the bookstores as was asked
before uh the chains
uh have been incredibly powerful they
have
now
the independent book stores in this
country have only 17 percent of the
sales
they're they're on their last legs
they're in great difficulty uh the
chains have been able to get from the
major publishers vast amounts of
publishing money
to feature the best sellers and not to
spend their time wasting their time on
on the books that are put in the back of
the store if you go to an a p and you
see a stack of ritz crackers you don't
think it's it's a staff pick
but if you go
in into barnes and noble you know you
will see the large stacks of books that
publishers have have paid them to place
there so money determines what you see
increasingly and what worries me about
it is how all pervasive this is uh
oxford university press which is after a
university press
insists that its editors sign up at
least a million dollars worth of books a
year now how are you going to get new
scholarship how are you going to get the
new eisenbergs at the university presses
if they are suffering from the same kind
of pressure which comes and turned from
the university and we've seen
all of you who work in universities have
seen the increasing profit pressures
there
so it is a homogeneous thing it is part
of a whole parcel which i've tried to
describe in detail in the book so you
can see how one affects the other but
the difference is that the ethos has
changed completely publishing used to be
one in which
simon and schuster might publish uh
crossword puzzle books but they
published bertrand russell on the
dangers of the arms race and the atomic
war and so on simon schuster does not
publish bertrand russell anymore and if
a new burton russell came up he would
certainly not find a publisher among the
conglomerates those are the changes
among the gatekeepers now we can
certainly reach a large audience and we
have on all sorts of books that people
said no there's no large audience here
and we have published relatively
esoteric things we published the other
year a book of the transcripts and
recordings of the major cases be before
the supreme court it was a set that
called 75 everybody all of our sales
people said you can't sell that to
anyone except a law school professor we
sold 75 000 the first year there's a
much greater interest in the public
in books that deal with real issues that
deal with the society in which they live
but the the entertainment industry is
saying that's not what we want we now
have an orwellian set of media who are
interested in pandering to the largest
possible audience and who will not take
the risks they used to take and we can
document that we can show what were the
books that were published before as
opposed to the books that now appear
it's a it's a 180 degree change
i think one point i'd like to add here
is i mean people have been
saying you know
what come on do with this situation you
know it's the culture
and i mean clearly
i think for
publishing sophisticated ideas the
culture is less favorable but i think
what andre raises in this book very
effectively is
the question do publishers have
responsibility to try and do something
about that
and i think the answer to that is yes i
mean
you know there's a there's a
what comes with putting out books of
course shareholders will not agree with
this but i don't think shareholders
should be making these decisions what
comes with putting out books is a
responsibility to try and inform and to
educate and to raise new ideas that's
that goes with the job just as
the
job of a doctor is to make
a patient healthy that's what a
publisher is and publishers should take
that responsibility and i think it's
very sad that the people who are working
in the large corporations running the
large corporation seems to have
completely lost the threat as far as
that's concerned
and i don't think that
when it comes to the internet and what
the internet does is it allows you to
distribute
much more efficiently than previously
and obviously it saves you on production
because you don't have to you don't have
to print but it does leave open two
areas that you still have to pay for one
is you have to acquire rights and the
other is that you have to market and i
think with the culture as it is at the
moment where there's so much noise with
all of the diversity which is created by
this very very open distribution
marketing becomes more important than it
ever was before i mean you really have
to in order to raise above rise above
this
hubbub of so many different options you
really have to put resources into saying
no this is the thing you should be
reading and it's very difficult for
small companies like us to find the
resources to do that so i don't think
that the internet in itself is uh going
to democratize
uh the free flow of ideas at all we're
in a situation now where these
corporations who are running publishing
individually have bigger sales than all
because they're they have interest in
other areas then the entire u.s book
industry that gives them you know
enormous weight and i'm sure they're
going to use that in terms of the new
media just as they did in in the
traditional media
anyone yes there's a lady there
yeah you
no just uh just sit yeah
well i first want to congratulate andrea
i think it's splendid
and uh
i'm very sympathetic to his views
um a question i want to raise
is about the possibility of a three-tier
publishing situation rather than a
two-tier publishing situation that third
tier being of course the academic
presses
which are by the way represented on your
table but have not been
discussed very much and i mean one has
seen of course you know gradually over
the years
many of the books that
might have been done by major houses 20
years ago
kind of find their their home in the
academic presses even andre when he was
at pantheon
with the best will in the world could
not
could not really
publish everything that he wanted to and
one or two things that had been proposed
to him and more than that probably uh
found their way finally into the
academic uh press
and so i wonder i'm what i'm interested
in at the moment is how
you conceive and i address this question
to
say both well to any of you really but
principally to andre and i'm sorry i
don't know your name
strongs
yes andrew bill strong how you conceived
the
relation between
trade publishing and academic publishing
and
what what what you can anticipate for
the future
um
i think the mission of the university
press is to publish scholarship that's
it's almost by definition and what you
see i think increasingly is that the
scholarship that was often published by
the trade houses in the past um they're
no longer interested in doing that not
exclusively at all um but yes you're
right certain things have fallen into
our laps if you will are taking up a
mission
beyond that there is the other question
of we have to survive as publishers too
and i mentioned that
part of being a publisher is not just
reaching the audience for a book but
it's some way it's creating that
audience and i think what we're going to
have to do in the future and the
challenges in publishing scholarship
help to create
an audience for that material and for
that scholarship and this is where i
said earlier i worry that it's not a
level playing field anymore and that
we're going to have obstacles to doing
that um that will will impact on our
future to survive um
the university press world is is very
vital at the moment um andre cook coral
some of what we do because i think in
the book as he points out that we're
abandoning our mission going toward the
same if you will commercial pressures uh
some of that is is um is true um and i
think a lot of that is just economic
darwinism we have to publish a certain
type of book at this point in order to
make enough money to publish all the
others
but that's where it's still balanced i
think we're an older fashion publishing
industry than than not
right but you have also the question of
a structural support i mean libraries
used to have money to spend on books
uh in england in the u.s and in europe
they have much much less and so many of
our books and many of the university
press books will end up selling a tiny
number i think the number of the average
number of university press book is in
the hundreds now for sale and the
universities themselves are no longer
supporting them to the degree that they
should so that i think has been that's
been my my critique and i think it's an
important change in in the universities
that the university of chicago i'm told
by colleagues there now considers every
department to be a profit center
whether it's the linguistics department
or the university press and the
accountants actually go around like in a
large corporation every quarter and say
have you met your budget now once you
have a university that's working that
way you're going to stop teaching the
classics you're going to stop teaching
all sorts of things you're going to stop
publishing all sorts of books
so that i find it very worrisome that
oxford university press it makes a 16
million dollar profit every year is an
effect saying to its all its editors we
do not want new scholarship in effect
coming from from from your choices we
want books that are going to sell at
least a hundred thousand thousand
dollars worth of books or whatever
uh so that is i think the overall
critique i'm trying to suggest in the
book
and i've had this from my classmates and
and
and friends from who are in other
professions that the changes that have
taken place in medicine and law and
teaching are the same that have taken
place in in publishing the values that
matter now is making the most amount of
money even if you're a million dollar
partner in a wall street law firm you're
at risk if you don't bring in the amount
of money that the firm requires once you
start doing that to ideas which is
what's happening then you are in real
trouble
is it possible that the
inherent elitism of the publishing
industry has possibly resulted in the
consolidation that we have now we talk
we're talking here about the
dissemination of information of ideas
and specifically through the medium of
books
and we're talking about a specific kind
of production but i wonder if
there there's low barriers for producing
these books but they're in terms of
economic capital but there's very high
barriers to produce these books in terms
of um labor human capital and that has
consequently attracted a certain type of
person a type of person who's willing to
assign themselves to a intellectual
underclass and that means a person of
means and maybe somebody who hasn't
traditionally been recognized by
people with university educations and so
on so what i'm specifically addressing
is the lack of diversity in publishing
in terms of class and race and ethnicity
because we know that the acquisitions
process is very quirky it's very
personal and so we publish the books
that we are as editors like and so um
there's only one type of publishing
going on so maybe there's an opportunity
to uh go outside of the type of
publishing going on in the big
conglomerates and uh there's
entrepreneurial opportunities if we
recognize that there's a broader reading
public that there isn't just a five
percent readership that there are more
people who do want to read
i wonder how you would direct to that
i i just look around the room how much
diversity do you see in this room
exactly
at my job yeah okay well i i would make
one point in relation to that which is
that
we're primarily publishers of
non-fiction and um
if we
think that there's an important area
that a book should be written in
um the only people that we can get to to
write that sort of book given the level
of advance that we can afford to pay
given the space which is available to us
in the market are either people who have
some independent means
or journalists who are being paid by
their newspapers or magazines or
academics the idea of getting someone to
go out and work on a book for a couple
of years research it and write it for us
and what how much would you have to pay
someone to do that you know even if they
were not living well i mean you'd have
to pay them 40
dollars fifty thousand dollars something
like that
that was when we don't pay that sort of
advance we can't
it would be far too risky for us and i
think um i think that's a real problem
those sorts of books are not being
because they're not being signed up by
the large
companies who are capable of putting the
marketing cloud behind them to get the
sales to return the advance they're not
being published any longer
i think your point about the lack of
diversity in the stats is very important
and when we started the new press we
made a great point of trying to have as
diverse as staff as possible and
publishing as diverse a program and in
fact we published a great many books
simply to challenge the assumptions of
publishers who normally redline a
minority audience and say well blacks
aren't going to read art history and so
on so forth and we did books on african
art history at very low prices to
precisely prove that that wasn't the
case but we've had to recruit from
outside the industry because they're not
in the industry and the few people in
the industry very often are so sickened
by the profit pressures that they they
want out anyway and if you look at
what's being published of course people
recognize there's a black reading
audience and the times had an article
the other day lauding the growth of
pornography for blacks and all sorts of
things of that kind well you will always
be able to find the lowest common
denominator and exploit a given audience
i don't think we won't exploit as
diverse an audience as possible the same
problems obtained that if you want to
publish good stuff for audiences
including you know political books for
blacks and chicanos and so which are
very few and far between you know you're
going to have to do it outside the
framework of the large corporation and
we're trying to do that verso has done
that very effectively but again look at
the catalogs the catalogs speak for
themselves see what is actually being
published by people and you will see the
degree to which people have been
redlined right and left
yes
there's always one little old lady
that's going to get up and ask a silly
question
i'm astounded at the fact that
i can't keep up with the book reviews
that are denying me
the time to read your books
so that mr sheeran
when you said we don't have enough
reviewing
of reviewers
available you said something about 50
markets
is that what you said
who was
well thank god
i mean i can't read them all i can't get
to the darn book you know i don't know
about a few other people but the new
york times has taken over my apartment
you know
i mean it's it's a fight between me and
and
this media
and i'm just wondering
how can we initiate the popular concept
of the times going back to size
that we could manage so that we could
have time off to read the books
i would love to see someone
write a column about that
it'll be in the new york times right
and everybody will clip the article
but nothing's going to happen if you
guys got any ideas on how we can read
your book since you're competing with
the newspapers
this is another conglomerate
you
know what i would say to that is that
one of the pressures in publishing right
now is is competition for the eyeball i
mean it's it's not you know whether
you're going to read a book or a
newspaper and see a a play or go to a
movie or that that's one of the real
challenges facing on publishing in the
future we've got to figure out how to
how to attract readers but in regard to
the new york times the daily dropped its
saturday review
what was it three years ago or something
like that so you now have you know five
books a week reviewed 52 times a year
that's
a very small proportion of the number of
books that are published and that's what
i'd say when you say it's hard to get
the message about what you're publishing
out i think there are a few we're
overwhelmed by the times
um daily but um i think in terms of
review outlets we we we need more
and we need more diversity i don't think
the time should be the only uh book
review we have to read
i think if you ignore the advertisements
in the new york times and the lifestyle
features
you find it's actually a pretty thin
publication
um
what are the small publishers doing to
cut back on the price because you talk
people are talking about the number of
copies of books being sold
yet
both small colleges and book publishers
keep on raising the price of books
so what are
the small folks are doing to cut back on
the price of i mean if they want to
close more books
is there are other ways they can cut
back
publish more books but well i mean
there's a very very um you know
direct relationship between the number
of books that you print uh and the price
that you can put on them
if the brain ran shorter the price goes
higher
and i think that's probably why prices
have
gone up
um on the versa list i still still think
their extraordinary value but
[Music]
to reach more people will be
good at a cheaper price well one of the
examples i talk about in my book is the
mass market paperback which when i was
working in mass market was the price of
a pack of cigarettes it was 25 cents
uh and now nowadays it's seven dollars
which is you know several packs of
cigarettes and compared
all right all right let's look at it
when i was working at the 8th street
bookstore i made 50 cents an hour i
could buy two books an hour right now if
i have the minimum wage i can't i can't
buy two paperbacks and that was a
decision that was made by the large
corporation simply to increase the
profit of on those books
paper mass market paperback does not
have to be 6.99 and there are a lot of
decisions that have been made precisely
for that i talk again in the book about
the decision to take trade paperbacks
from what used to be 195 to 795. again
that was done simply to increase the
profit and to meet the corporate targets
that's that's how you decide on higher
prices of course there's also the fact
that there's a physical cost of the book
that you can't do away with but if you
want people to make 15 or 20 a year it's
going to come out of your hide
it's also true that with the
conglomeration of book selling discounts
to booksellers have gone up quite
sharply
um and that's so the bookstores are
taking more than they used to
calvin
yeah i've got actually two questions i'd
be interested in having anyone on the
panel
react to i'm curious um how you see the
impact of specific technology uh
printout printing print on demand
technology affecting the future
economics of book production
and how that might affect small
publishers
perhaps uh having more resources to
market their books uh and i'm also
curious to get a reaction um uh what do
you think of the the perseus books group
um a uh
what seems to be a major trade house
being kind of constructed before our
eyes
with uh what seems to be
different uh corporate values uh perhaps
old-fashioned corporate values about
publishing i'm not sure if that's the
case but i'm curious to hear your
reactions
okay well i i write specifically about
perseus in the book as an interesting
new experiment and i think they've been
very smart in what they've done buying
up basic books and other houses that had
been dumped by the conglomerates because
they weren't being profitable enough
precious however is owned by a
consortium of banks and whether they're
going to make the money that their
investors want is something we'll have
to wait and see but it certainly was a
very clever and able enable move
um i think the print on demand
businesses
you know every time ever since radio
started we've always had these high
hopes for new technologies every new
technology is going to bring democracy
and culture to every corner of the
country and so on so forth it depends on
who controls it and for what purpose
i've listened you know print on demand
is certainly a very useful thing to get
an out of print book and so on and so
forth i've listened to the barnes noble
pitch on this very often
and what they're really looking to do is
just not having to stock all these books
and if some
united person wants an early thomas mon
novel grade we'll print it up for you we
don't need to stock it anymore the
publisher doesn't need to continue
printing it and the profit will go to
barnes noble so it can end up being as
much a negative thing as a positive
thing because we try to keep all of our
books in print we try to have them
available for the stores if the store
stops saying we're going to stock them
because we can print the one copy that
we might possibly sell you change the
store from being a place where now a
good bookstore is a place where you
don't just buy the book you wanted you
buy the book you didn't know you wanted
and if that goes away then you know
it'll be another another nail in the
coffin so any technological innovation
whether it's the internet or pod or
whatever really depends on who's going
to control it for what purpose
yeah at the bank
i have a very specific question there
are a lot of academic presses and small
presses
which
would you say are the ones to watch
besides your own of course
academic presses
there are all sorts of academic presses
and i think what's interesting about
some of the university press world is
that what they're serving is almost
regional publishing they're the
university of arkansas press for
instance which nearly went out of
business a year ago um is the only
publisher in arkansas and they said the
interesting thing to me about a lot of
the university presses and the academic
processes are what uh they can serve in
terms of their local population that
might be
diminishing them a great deal but that
that certainly interests me
nebraska was named as a very interesting
press in addition to the fact they
published all these uh french
translations they also have an excellent
western american history list
and fiction they brought they brought it
in and they've done very nicely i think
that's an interesting press there are
many others
i'll say this about the university press
world just to throw a few figures there
are only
um
eight american university presses that
have net sales of over six million
dollars a year i mean it's it's pretty
small and they're the obvious candidates
um
so so we're all working as very small
independent publishers
andre do you wonder well i mean uh you
know i mean there are there are a lot of
um
uh little independent presses and we
know each other so one has to be careful
if you're going to start listing your
favorites but
um
i quite like soft skull who are coming
out of the lower east side is very sort
of feisty punk left wing
publisher run by you know 20 year olds
and you know taking on the the mantle of
alternative publishing
um seven stories pretty good uh you know
they've had some they've had some uh
great books out including this nader
book that they're doing
and i mean i i'd have to pay a tribute
to the distributor of both they're not a
little press but they're not a huge
conglomerate either the distributor of
both andre and verso books w.w norton
who have got a unusual structure in that
they are owned by their employees
um it's a trust and they have been able
to maintain
very high
editorial standards with
combine those with considerable
commercial success over the last period
i think it's a you know an admirable
company and we depend on them a great
deal
and the one thing i i would suggest is
is use the web if you see a publisher
that has a book you're interested in
look at their catalog on the web all of
us have websites and you can see
everything that we're publishing and uh
people that is certainly something that
can make a huge difference that people
begin to look
most of the large review media will not
review that many books by small
publishers at least
not in many areas but if it all depends
on the field you're interested in but
everyone has a website
so i think we're going to um
wind it up there i'm sorry uh we
couldn't take all the questions but what
i would urge you to do is to i think
there's a reception over the road at
poseman's and you can come over and talk
with andre and lewis and bill
uh and myself there if you'd like to do
and have a glass of wine i would also
urge you
to buy a copy of andre's book by doing
by doing that you could not only find
out about the difficulties of
independent publishing but also help to
solve them so
i'd urge you to pick one up
[Applause]
[Music]
andre schifrin for 30 years was a
publisher at pantheon which was
co-founded by his father he's currently
the director of the new press
his book the business of books how the
international conglomerates took over
publishing and changed the way we read
is published by verso books